Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Sag mal, das Tier des Jahres, was ist das bei dir?
Dann nehm ich doch den Hamster.
Okay, ich glaub bei mir ist das das Mobile Tier. So, da ist er, der Oktober.
Doch ereignisreich und jetzt ein bisschen dämpfend am Ende, denn wir sitzen uns diesmal nicht analog gegenüber, sondern nur virtuell, da die Infektionszahlen hoch sind in Koblenz, aber auch in Frankfurt glaube ich noch etwas höher. Da haben wir uns entschieden, wir bleiben daheim, obwohl es doch sehr sehr schade ist, dass es noch mal schöner ist, wenn man, wo man ohnehin so wenig Kontakte gerade pflegt, wenn man jemanden trifft. Und wir essen ja gern danach, das dürfen wir glaube ich verraten, Schnitzel. Und das vermisse ich ein bisschen, dass ich heute keinen Wiener Schnitzel bekomme.
Ja, ich habe meinen Mittag gerade eben schon gegessen. Manchmal mache ich es ja so, dass ich das Kind in den Kindergarten bringe und dann haue ich mir gleich die Schnitzel rein. Allerdings, Merkel hat uns ja versprochen, im November klappt es dann wieder. Dafür machen wir das ja jetzt, ne? Also ein bisschen die Ansagen. Um Weihnachten abzusichern, macht man jetzt Lockdown. Na ja, was wollen wir sagen? Wir kommen noch auf Corona zurück. Lass mich trotzdem kurz eine kleine Beobachtung schildern. Wir haben uns auch schon lustig gemacht über die Diagnose-Gesellschaft im Salon. Es gibt diese eine Dessertation von Fran Ostratschke, der in Bielefeld eine Dessertation vorgelegt hat, in der sich ein bisschen lustig darüber macht, dass immer alle gleich mit so einem Bindestrich Gesellschaft zu Wort kommen, um das zu beschreiben. Ich glaube trotzdem, im Oktober kann man jetzt eine dieser Diagnosebegrifflichkeiten, wenn auch ein bisschen mit Humor, hervorkramen, nämlich wir leben in einer Stochastischen Gesellschaft. Denn wir haben zwei große Themen, Trump und Corona, bei der keiner so genau sagen kann, wann ist vorbei oder hat nicht Trump doch noch eine Chance? Also egal wie man darüber spricht, das Ereignis ist erst in der Zukunft und die Wahrscheinlichkeiten sind irgendwo zwischen 0 und 1. Aber sie sind nicht 0 oder 1. Also wir müssen jetzt mit so einer Ambivalenz bei beiden großen Themen klarkommen. Das Trump-Thema wird sich natürlich im November auflösen, wobei wir dann nachher neue Ambivalenzen aufmachen. Und bei Corona ist das auch so. Man weiß jetzt nicht genau, wollen wir es ausrotten, wollen wir es eher auf 1 halten oder wollen wir die exponentielle Dimension einfach runterbringen? Und dann kommt noch dazu, und das gehört eben auch zur Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung, wir wissen, wir kennen bei beiden die Dimensionen nicht. Was würde es wirklich bedeuten, wenn Trump nochmal gewinnt? Also es ist nicht nur dieses Ereignis, es könnte sein, sondern, und was würde es dann bedeuten? Und dafür haben wir keine Maßstäbe, wir haben keine Maßstäbe dafür, was eine zweite Trump-Amtszeit bedeutet. Und bei Corona haben wir derzeit auch keine Maßstäbe. 20.000 Infektionen am Tag, ist das viel oder nicht? In Deutschland, in Belgien, ja, in Amerika, also sind 20.000 eigentlich viel oder nicht? Und wir haben uns in ganz vielen Maßstäben, und das bringt sehr viele Leute in sehr große Unsicherheit, ist so meine Beobachtung.
Was ja sich dann auch politisch zeigt, dass da mitunter dann auch die Maßstäbe fehlen. Oder auch die Art, wie man darüber spricht. Oder ja, welche Maßstäbe man anlegt, wenn man nicht nur auf die Statistik blickt. Aber wir reden ja gleich über Corona. Es gibt ein sehr schönes Statement heute auch vom Staatstheater Mainz. Vielleicht kann ich das schon mal vorschieben. Weil das doch ganz interessant ist, dass das Stadtstheater Mainz hat, wie alle Theater in Deutschland, eigentlich die ersten Corona-Maßnahmen natürlich mitgetragen, unterstützt. Und hat dann auch online einiges dargeboten. Das haben ja die meisten Theater gemacht, dass sie doch irgendetwas tun. Vielleicht hinten mal eine Führung durch die Werkstatt oder einzelne Schauspieler, Monologe aufführen lassen, solche Dinge. Genau, und jetzt haben sie sich eben zu diesen neuen Maßnahmen geäußert auf der Facebook-Seite und da heißt es unter anderem gewünscht hätten wir uns einen politischen Gestaltungswillen, der aktiv nach Möglichkeiten sucht, einer durch die strengen Kontaktbeschränkungen zunehmenden Vereinsamung alles entgegenzusetzen, was entgegengesetzt werden kann. Wichtige Orte der Lebendigkeit als Rettungsinseln in einer Zeit, die jedem Einzelnen so viel abverlangt. Stattdessen wird in einem pauschalen Verhinderungsreflex, den wir kurzsichtig finden, diese kostbare Möglichkeit vertan. Wenn die Politik ihren eigenen Vorgaben nicht mehr traut, verliert sie an Glaubwürdigkeit und Maßnahmen erscheinen willkürlich. Das gesellschaftliche Klima verändert sich gerade merklich, die Akzeptanz für politisches Handeln schwindet. Wir hätten dem gern weiter etwas entgegengesetzt. Anders als im Frühjahr, als wir weniger wussten und nicht einschätzen konnten, wo die Gefahren lauern, tragen wir diese politische Entscheidung, die Theater zu schließen, nicht mit. Und jetzt nochmal, um das zu verdeutlichen, darum werden wir auch nicht mit virtuellen Formaten im Internet den analogen Phantomschmerz mildern. Also sehr, sehr scharf formuliert, also für eine Institution, die sich jetzt zu Wort meldet. Nicht jetzt ein einzelner Künstler, da ist das ja immer nochmal was anderes, aber sehr überraschend Staatstheater Mainz. Und von anderen Theatern hat man Ähnliches jetzt schon gelesen. Ich fand das jetzt hier besonders pointiert, denn es ist ja so, dass wir gerade in diesen Institutionen einen sehr hohen Infektionsschutz hatten. Wir haben das auch zum Beispiel in Koblenz, dort gibt es Kammerkonzerte. Die wurden natürlich nicht im Kammermusiksaal mehr aufgeführt, weil der sehr, sehr klein ist, wie sich das für Kammerkonzerte eigentlich hört, sondern man ging tatsächlich in den großen Saal, dort, wo normalerweise 1200 Leute Platz nehmen und beim Kammerkonzert kommen dann 70. Und ich habe allerdings dann auch eine Freundin, die über 80 ist, die sagt, ich gehe auch da nicht hin. Das ist mir zu riskant, was man ja sehr nachvollziehen kann. Aber es gab Konzepte und das finde ich sehr interessant, was sie hier schreiben, vom Staatstheater Mainz, aber wir kommen ja auf die anderen Corona-Sachen noch zurück.
Genau, wir fangen nicht mit Corona an, sondern hier jetzt nur der kleine Brückenschlag als Fragestellung. Und die Antwort kann man sich ja dann überlegen. Wenn wir das öffentliche Leben aussortieren, aus dem Leben, ist es dann weg das Leben oder verlagert es sich ins private? Und was war eigentlich? Das haben wir selbst im letzten Salon noch kurz angeschnitten. Was ist eigentlich der große Infektionstreiber, das öffentliche oder das private Leben? In der Ansicht ist das wirklich sehr dramatisch, was wir hier Ende Oktober, Stichtag gestern sozusagen erleben. Wir kommen darauf zurück, aber wir beginnen mit Drohnen. Wolfgang, du hast die Drohnen mitgebracht, denn es gibt das ein oder andere Thema. Überwachung wäre auch so ein Thema jetzt für Oktober. Wie die Überwachung zurückkommt und der Krieg gegen die Verschlüsselungstechnologien und Drohnen, da wündet sozusagen alles ein bisschen drin.
Ganz genau zu der Frage der Überwachung kommen wir dann am Ende dieses Drohnenteils nochmal zurück und schauen da auch noch auf einen aktuellen Konflikt. Aber bei den Kampfdrohnen haben wir schon seit Jahren die Debatte, soll die Bundeswehr solche anschaffen oder nicht. Die CDU ist dafür. Die AfD hat mal einen Entwurf reingebracht. Die sind natürlich auch dafür. Dann gab es einen Entwurf von der FDP. Der wurde kurz vor Weihnachten 2019 debattiert. Ich habe mir diese Debatte angesehen, 35 Minuten Bundestag. Ich dachte mir, keinen einzigen Clip muss ich hier vorspielen aus der Debatte, weil die nicht besonders geistreich geführt wurde. Sie war zum einen polemisch von den Befürwortern und dann auch von einem Demutstolz, möchte ich es nennen. Dieser Demutstolz, von diesem Demutstolz geprägt, nämlich, dass dort dann immer diese Bundestagsabgeordneten, die also für eine Aufrüstung sind, stehen und sagen, für unsere Soldaten und wenn ich mir vorstelle, wie diese Soldaten jetzt fernab von ihren Familienweihnachten feiern und dieses ganze Rhetorische, was dann so kommt, dann muss ich sagen, ich glaube komischerweise oder interessanterweise diesen Leuten nie, wenn sie diese Demutsgesten dort machen. Eigentlich wollen sie sich selbst so unglaublich in den Mittelpunkt rücken mit ihrer Betroffenheit und wollen eigentlich dafür Applaus ernten und ob ihnen die Soldaten wirklich so wichtig sind. Ich glaube das nicht.
Wir sehen selten diese Art von politischer Rhetorik, die so trickreich ist und deswegen auch so beliebt angewendet wird. Obwohl sie durchschaut wird, funktioniert sie trotzdem. Das nehmen die CDU-Leute wirklich auf der Bühne stehen und sagen, das dient ausschließlich dem Schutz der eigenen Soldaten. Das hat nichts mit Krieg nach außen, sondern mit Verteidigung zu tun. Und das ist eine ganz perfide Argumentation, weil du eben ganz rasant in diesen psychologischen emotionalen Argumentationen bist. Gerade wenn es dann Richtung Weihnachten geht.
Ganz genau, die Soldaten, manche, die jetzt nach Hause kommen und die sich doch wünschen, dass wir aufrüsten. Man muss sagen, es kam da aber auch von linker und grüner Seite. Die sind ja gegen die Drohnen. Nicht besonders viel Fundamentales, was dann auch in so einer Bundestagsdebatte schwer möglich ist. Auch gerade in einer solchen Stimmung. Und die SPD, die schwankt ja etwas hin und her. Und inzwischen ist es aber so, dass die SPD sich doch damit anfreunden kann, dass man Kampfdrohnen wohl anschaffen könnte. Im Koalitionsvertrag steht das ja auch ein bisschen verschwurbelt da. Man möchte eine Grundlage schaffen für die Anschaffung von. Und als ich diese Bundestagsdebatte jetzt mir angesehen habe, dachte ich an Roger Wilhelmsen. Roger Wilhelmsen hat ja ein Jahr lang das Hohe Haus besucht. So heißt auch das Buch Das Hohe Haus, hat sich alle Bundestagsdebatten angesehen, oben auf der Zuschauertribüne. Und dann gab es eine Aussprache mit Julia Klöckner. Und sie diskutieren darüber, was dann eigentlich die Funktion des Bundestags ist. Ich werde jetzt keine Klöckner-Clips vorspielen, aber zwei von Roger Wilhelmsen. Denn Roger Wilhelmsen wurde ja dann auch vorgeworfen, dass er zwar die Bundestagsdebatten da beleuchtet und dann nicht nur kritisiert, dass die meistens wenig rhetorisch ausgefeilt sind, sondern dass diese Reden in der Regel nicht mehr dazu dienen, dass es wirklich um eine Auseinandersetzung mit den Argumenten des anderen sich handelt. Dass Roger Wilhelmsen also verkennt, wo doch die eigentlichen Entscheidungen gefällt werden, wo wirklich diskutiert wird. Und wir hören da mal in den ersten Clip rein aus dieser Auseinandersetzung.
Natürlich ist es ein naheliegender Vorwurf zu sagen, da hat sich jemand das Plenum angeguckt und er redet vom Parlament. Und dann belehren mich die Zeitungen darüber, dass es ja den Ausschuss gibt. Und man denkt, Mensch, das habe ich ja gar nicht gewusst. Ausschüsse, was machen die denn? Da bin ich so dankbar, dass wir kritischen Journalismus haben, der mir das beibringt, denn das wäre mir gar nicht aufgefallen. Ich habe ja ganz bewusst dieses Plenum genommen und habe ganz bewusst das genommen, was das Parlament dem Publikum zu sehen und zu verstehen gibt. Und darunter sind sehr beeindruckende Leistungen, übrigens auch von CDU-Abgeordneten.
Die lobt er dann auch in seinem Buch.
Thomas Oppermann ist jetzt gestorben als Bundestagsvizepräsident. Das ist natürlich zum einen eine wichtige Sache und zum anderen gibt es da auch eine Feierstunde dann im Plenum. Und der Deutschlandfunk hat zweimal, beispielsweise bei der Tageszusammenfassung und dann später nochmal drauf verwiesen, dass ja Thomas Oppermann immer so verschmitzten Humor hatte und dann haben sie zweimal den gleichen Ausschnitt gespielt, wie er nämlich die Sitzung leitet. Und jemanden ermahnt, nehmen sie die Zeitung nicht so hoch. Das sähe dann nämlich für das Publikum aus, als wäre das hier ein Teehaus. Es ist aber ein Arbeitsparlament. Da habe ich gedacht, es stimmt, es ist ein Arbeitsparlament, aber nicht im Plenum. Im Plenum wird nicht gearbeitet, da wird geredet, da wird für die Fernsehkameras, ja, da wird, es gibt keine Debatte, also es gibt eine Debatte, aber es ist jetzt keine, die politische Debatte, es werden die Ergebnisse der Arbeit aus den Ausschüssen noch mal im Plenum vorgetragen. Und das fand ich sehr schade, dass man Thomas Oppermann eigentlich den falschen Clip da spielt. Also dass er noch mal die Leute eigentlich die Irre führt, denn Thomas Oppermann hätte, glaube ich, einen anderen Clip ausgewählt, wenn man noch mal an ihn erinnert.
Und es ist aber so, wenn man sich diese Debatte zu den Kampfdrohnen ansieht, dann denkt man, naja, diese Leute entscheiden jetzt gerade darüber, ist mir das so recht, wenn sie schon so nachlässig eine solche Debatte führen. Und wir hören hier noch mal, was Roger Wilhelmsen sagt dazu, wenn er das da beobachtet hat, wie zum Teil eben Bundestag im Plenum agiert wird.
Ich muss das Parlament an dem messen können, was es der Öffentlichkeit zu verstehen gibt. Und ich empfinde es als Ärgernis, wenn als Einwand eines CDU-Abgeordneten namens Kampeter mir gesagt wird, ach Herr Wilhelmsen, nehmen Sie das doch alles nicht so ernst. Wenn das der Einwand ist, zu sagen, es lohnt sich nicht, diese Reden genau zu betrachten, es lohnt sich nicht zu fragen, welche, und ich wähle dieses Wort bewusst, Ideologie, sich in manchen Sätzen verrät, wie mit Armut umgegangen wird, mit welcher Empathielosigkeit Rüstungsexporte von fünf Parteien des Deutschen Bundestages verteidigt werden, dann werde ich als Anwalt draußen stehen und sagen, lasst mich in Frieden mit euren Ausschüssen. Die sagen erst mal nur Undurchsichtigkeit, hier gibt es keine Kameras, hier gibt es keine Quellen, und wir sind eine parlamentarische Demokratie, die auf Transparenz aus ist. Selbst das ganze Gebäude ist transparent, und wir geben uns so viel darauf zugute, dass wir transparent sind. Diese Transparenz hat in mir dann einen Anwalt. Und der sagt, wenn ihr noch Erregung zeigt im Parlament, und das Gefühl ist eine Form der Vervielfältigungsform oder des Geschmacksverstärkers in der Rede, dann muss das Gefühl doch getragen sein von echter Empörung oder von Verzweiflung über die Nichtdurchsetzbarkeit von Positionen, über die Erschöpfung an bestimmten Punkten, in denen man Jahre im Ausschuss gearbeitet hat und man hat schließlich sieben Minuten Redezeit, um sie zu vertreten.
Aber wie sollte man daraus eine Fernsehshow machen?
Genau. Und das ist ein bisschen, jetzt passiert eine Fernsehshow, denn nicht alle Ausschüsse sind ja intransparent, nicht öffentlich, sondern manchmal werden sie auch gefilmt und man kann sie sich ansehen. Und so gab es jetzt einen Ausschuss über die Frage, sollen wir Kampfdrohnen anschaffen oder nicht? Dann sind ja alle vertretenen Parteien im Bundestag dürfen dann jemanden als Experten dort benennen. Jeder Experte darf acht Minuten etwa reden. Danach gibt es so solche Fragerunden. Und ein solcher Ausschuss wurde dann live gestreamt und ist auch bei YouTube abrufbar auf der Bundestagseite, also auf dem Bundestag-YouTube-Kanal. Und was soll ich sagen? Als ich mir das jetzt angesehen habe, gab es immerhin 208 Aufrufe. Ich war also der 209. Da ist genau diese Frage, wie kann man sowas öffentlich machen? Und wir müssen jetzt aber uns diesen Ausschuss einmal ansehen. Denn was passiert denn da eigentlich jetzt? Das ist nämlich etwas, was schon bemerkenswert ist, da man gleich merkt, hier wird auf einem ganz anderen Niveau debattiert. Allein dadurch, dass man Experten dort hat, die sich dazu äußern, die in kurzen Reden das Problem schildern und die Frage erörtern, soll man Kampfdrohnen anschaffen oder nicht. Und ich habe jetzt vor allem die Experten zu Wort kommen lassen, da dann die Fragen doch auch eher wiederum sehr gelenkt sind. Oder man kitzelt nur noch mal aus den Experten raus, was sie eigentlich schon gesagt haben. Denn man muss sagen, auch diese Ausschüsse sind so konzipiert, dass es jetzt nicht darum geht, dass die Parteien, die zum Beispiel für Kampfdrohnen sind, sich noch mal Leute dorthin holen, die dagegen sind. Sondern man versucht eigentlich nur jemanden zu finden, der die Position unterstreicht. In der Regel ist das so. Aber dennoch haben diese Leute ganz interessante Argumente. Und da geht es natürlich auch um den Schutz der Soldaten. Wir hören jetzt erst einmal den Oberstleutnant André Wüstner, der sich dazu äußert.
Ich will immer wieder betonen, dass es sich um keinen Beruf jeden anderen handelt. Aber weil das so ist, erwarten die Angehörigen der Bundeswehr und ihre Familien von ihrem Auftraggeber, also auch von Ihnen, dass er die bestmögliche Ausstattung zur Erfüllung der Aufgaben der Aufträge in den Einsatzgebieten zur Verfügung gestellt bekommt. Dies bedeutet, im Kontext dieser Debatte optimalen Schutz für die eigenen Kräfte sicherzustellen. Dass bis heute keine bewaffneten Thronen zur Verfügung stehen, obwohl doch schon seit vielen Jahren dieses Thema politisch bewegt wird, können übrigens sehr viele Soldatinnen und Soldaten nicht nachvollziehen.
Dieser Verweis auf die Besonderheit des Berufes ist schon interessant. Denn da kann man ja auch zurückspiegeln, dass die Besonderheit vor allem das besondere Risiko ausmacht. Diese Argumentation ist fast ähnlich wie am Finanzmarkt, wo eben manche ihre hohen Renditen wollen und das Risiko dann trotzdem über wie auch immer, too big to fail und so weiter, wieder versuchen zu externalisieren. Und das haben wir hier auch. Wenn es ein besonderer Beruf ist, liegt es daran, dass es dieses Risiko gibt. Dann kann man sich zwar dafür einsetzen, aber dann müsste man auch einsehen, dass manche andere auch sehen, das ist ein besonderer Beruf wegen des Risikos. Und das können wir nun nicht einfach mit Kampfdrohnen beseitigen.
Und diese Risikominimierung ist, das habe ich dann nochmal nachgelesen, eine lange Debatte auch, die eine juristische Debatte ist. Inwieweit muss der Staat nachkommen oder muss das Parlament, wir haben eine Parlamentsarmee, dem nachkommen, dass die Soldaten sicher sind? Also man kann ja jetzt nicht Soldaten zum Beispiel ohne Helme losschicken. Aber gehören jetzt zum Beispiel auch Kampfdrohnen dazu. Muss man einfach sagen, ja, das ist wie ein Helm. Das wird also immer wieder debattiert dort. Und man sieht ja aber schon ganz klar, Wüstner sagt ihr, ihr verschlaft das hier. Und er baut jetzt nochmal mehr Druck auf im nächsten Clip.
Ich bin heilfroh, dass bisher nicht die Situation eingetreten ist, in der sie als Abgeordnete, Angehörigen und Kameraden hätten erklären müssen, dass ein Kamerad im Einsatz gefallen ist, weil die Fähigkeit einer bewaffneten Drohne fehlte. Gleicherweise hoffe ich inständig, dass auch kein Mitglied der Bundesregierung Angehörigen und Kameraden erklären muss, dass ein Kamerad fallen musste, weil nach der entsprechenden Entscheidung die Beschaffung nicht schnell genug verlief.
Ja, das ist also doppelt Druck aufgebaut auch schon.
Und das müsst ihr aber auch schnell tun, denn sonst könnte die euch wieder schuldig machen.
Also sowas, wie soll ich sagen, man ist ja immer gleich so werturteilend, aber sowas nervt mich. Denn wenn wir das Argument auf so eine Dimension der Eskalation entspinnen, könnten wir auch sagen, es ist sowieso unverantwortlich, Soldaten in einen Krieg zu schicken, wo sie Faustkampf- und Schusswaffeneinsatz machen müssen, wo wir doch genauso gut einfach Flächenbombe-Battemauer machen könnten. Dann kriegen wir die auch aus der Gefahrenzone raus, weil wir die Gefahrenzone selbst vorher zerstören. Und spätestens da werden Nebenfolgen und so weiter klar. Und diese Nebenfolgendiskussionen muss man dann eben aus diesem Extremszenario vorziehen in die Diskussion über Kampffrohnen. Weil wir haben Erfahrungen mit Kampffrohnen. Und wenn man sie auch nur anschafft zum Zwecke der Verteidigung, wissen wir ganz genau, jetzt wo sie einmal da sind und so, wollen wir wirklich den Panzer darüber schicken, können wir nicht schnell mit der Drohne rüberfliegen. Also das liegt eigentlich auf der Hand, dass man so nicht argumentieren kann. Dass das trotzdem im Verteidigungsausschuss so macht, finde ich so ein bisschen, das sagt immer recht viel, welche Argumentation man sich da zutraut in so einem Setting.
Wir behalten das mal im Hinterkopf. Schutz der Soldaten, das Parlament muss die Soldaten schützen. Das denken wir mal weiter, bald mit den nächsten Clips. Du hast aber erstmal noch ein weiteres Argument, das ja gegen Thronen oft kommt. Du hast es jetzt auch gerade schon so angedeutet. Wie ist denn das mit der Hemmschwelle? Wird die denn gesenkt? Das wird ja gern bezogen auf die Soldaten. Die sind dann nur noch Joystick-Soldaten und dann spielen die Krieg wie Computerspiele. Da sagt Wüßner was ganz Interessantes, der spielt den Ball zurück.
Die Befürchtung einer Entmenschlichung der militärischen Gewalt oder einer Herabsetzung der Hemmschwelle zum Einsatz teilt im Deutschen Bundeswehrband niemand, zumindest nicht mit Bezug zu den Soldatinnen und Soldaten. Wie weit es sie im Rahmen der Politik und ihr Agieren verändert, müssten sie selbst beantworten.
Also Soldaten arbeiten, wenn es kritisch wird, für gewöhnlich nicht mehr auf deutschem Staatsgebiet und auch unter sich. Und das sind zwei Argumente, die einfach für eine sehr niedrige Hemmschwelle sprechen. Da stehen einfach nicht Journalisten daneben und gucken sich das auch mal an, was da vor sich geht.
Und zugleich hat er Recht, dass sicherlich die Hemmschwelle auch sinken könnte, bei denen, die die Bundeswehr in einen Einsatz schicken.
Das auch.
Jetzt kommt ein weiterer Experte zu Wort, der sich über Slippery Slope äußert. Also der auch eigentlich hier fragt, welche Folgen hat das dann, wenn das eingesetzt wird. Und das ist Carlo Massalla von der Universität der Bundeswehr in München.
Wir haben immer wieder das Argument, dass bei unseren drei engsten, also Verbündeten der NATO, man dieses Slippery Slope sehen kann. Also bei den USA die Drohnen einsetzen, bei Großbritannien die Drohnen einsetzen. Und sozusagen, Herr Kollege Zimmermann hat es erwähnt, bei Mali die bewaffnete Drohnen auch zu Signature Strikes einsetzen. Diese Beobachtung dieser drei Staaten ist meines Erachtens deshalb empirisch nicht zulässig im Vergleich zur Bundesrepublik Deutschland, weil keine dieser drei Staaten eine solche Parlamentsarmee hat wie die Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Dort wird exekutiv zum größten Teil entschieden, wie Drohnen eingesetzt werden und in welchem Szenario sie eingesetzt werden. Hier ist es die Legislative. Und von daher sozusagen ist dieses Slippery Slope Argument empirisch ganz einfach aus der Sicht einer Parlamentsarmee einfach nicht aufrechtzuerhalten.
Das wird jetzt so ein durchgehender Faden in dieser Argumentation, dass man immer wieder sagt, ist eine Parlamentsarmee, ist eine Parlamentsarmee. Wir hören jetzt gleich im Anschluss mal...
Aber es ist eben auch eine Parlamentsarmee eines Parlaments, das noch niemals nein gesagt hat zu einem Regierungsansinnen. Das muss man immer dazu sagen. Es gibt kein anderes Thema im Bundestag, das wirklich mit 100 zu 0 ausgegangen ist bislang.
Stefan, wir bauen die Spannung noch auf. Da kommt nämlich noch eine Abgeordnete, die da sehr wohl widerspricht und die etwas ganz Ähnliches sagt. Jetzt hören wir noch einen weiteren Experten. Und zwar hören wir Andreas Zimmermann von der Universität Potsdam, der auch jetzt nochmal sagt, naja, wir sind ja hier in Deutschland.
Die ganze Diskussion in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, wie ich glaube, ist in hohem Maße geprägt von der aus meiner Sicht völkerrechtsfähigen Praxis der USA extralegaler Tötungen mit bewaffneten Drohnen. Das ist aber glaube ich nicht das Szenario, über das wir reden. Ich glaube, das Szenario, über das wir reden sollten, wirklich ist der Einsatz bewaffneter Drohnen in einem Kontext bewaffneter Konflikte, wo der räumliche, zeitliche Anwendungsbereich des humanitären Völkerrechts eröffnet ist. Und das ist eine grundsätzlich andere Frage, als der Einsatz bewaffneter Drohnen außerhalb bewaffneter Konflikte.
Das leuche ich zunächst mal ein, dass es sicherlich Dinge gibt, die von der USA aus stattfinden, die wir in Deutschland vermutlich nicht machen würden. Und zugleich ist aber hier schon etwas, was er anspricht, was wir auch im Hinterkopf behalten sollten. Na ja, das ist ja alles einzugrenzen, und das ist ja doch genau festzulegen, was dann diese Kampftronen machen. Da kommt dann Widerspruch sehr viel später. Aber was ja diese große Frage ist bei Kampftronen, inwiefern sie überhaupt so anders sind als irgendwelche anderen Waffen. Denn Massalla sagt beispielsweise dann in dieser Diskussion, ja, das sind keine Game-Changer-Kampftronen. Das ist nicht anders als irgendetwas anderes, das in die Ferne zielt und dort treffen soll. Und etwas sehr Ähnliches sagt dann auch Zimmermann mit Bezug auf Drohnen und Fernziele.
Einsatz oder eine Rakete, die von einer Drohne abgefeuert wird, unterscheidet sich nicht grundsätzlich von anderen Waffen, die eingesetzt werden. Die kritische rechtliche Frage ist, ob im Einzelfall der spezifische Einsatz mit den Vorgaben des humanitären Völkerrechts vereinbar ist. Das ist die Frage. Und keine andere Frage, die es zu beantworten gilt.
Ja, aber Drohnen lassen sich halt auch schön skalieren. Vor allem durch die Automatisierung. Klar, bisher brauchte man noch, oder was heißt bisher, vor fünf Jahren war ja immer so der Stand, für eine Drohne braucht man 100 Leute, die die Operation übernehmen. Aber dieses Verhältnis kann sich auch einfach mal umdrehen, dass einer dann 100 Drohnen steuert. Und so ein Szenario ist ja auch nicht weit entfernt.
Genau, und wir sprechen gleich noch ganz kurz über Bergkarabach. Da sehen wir schon, da ist kein riesiges Hightech-Center, das da die Drohnen steuert, sondern das ist eigentlich zum Teil auf einem sehr primitiven Niveau, aber eben effizient in dem, was diese Drohnen dann anrichten. Zimmermann macht dann einen Punkt, der doch nicht ganz von der Hand zu weisen ist. Wie ist es denn eigentlich, wenn wir jetzt Drohnen für uns ablehnen, wenn wir sie nicht anschaffen, wie ist es denn mit den Bündnispartnern, wenn wir da verwickelt sind in Konflikte?
Wenn wir einen Einsatz deutscher Drohnen für unzulässig, für unmoralisch oder sonst wie nicht verantwortbar halten, dann hielte ich auch einen Einsatz oder eine Beteiligung an einem Einsatz, wo Partnerstaaten solche Drohnen einsetzen, ebenfalls für nicht vertretbar. Das kann man so wollen, das kann man so wollen, aber dann muss man das, glaube ich, auch in dieser Konsequenz so sagen.
Wir sind jetzt 20 Jahre in gemeinsamen Einsätzen, wo teilweise... Und die Frage ist dann wirklich, wie viele Drohnenangriffe in Afghanistan und auch vielleicht in Pakistan, also außerhalb von Kriegsgebieten, offiziellen Kriegsgebieten, sind denn schon auf Ansinnen von NATO-Partnern, beispielsweise konkret Deutschland, losgeflogen worden? Das konnte uns auch noch keiner sagen.
Ja, aber schön, dass er das mal anspricht. Ja, die Realität sieht schon anders aus. Insofern kann man natürlich auch von der Befürworterseite sagen, naja, es ist ohnehin begott, wir sind ja eh schon lange dabei, dann können wir auch noch selbst ein paar anschaffen. Ich würde jetzt nochmal einmal auf Masalla zu sprechen kommen, der jetzt nochmal diese Parlamentsarmee ganz stark machen möchte.
Welche Folgen für Nichtkombatanten hat der Einsatz bewaffneter Drohnen? Die Studien, die wir kennen, beziehen sich alle auf die Frage von ziviler Bevölkerung und Drohnen-Einsatz bei Antiterroroperationen. Und da muss man natürlich sagen, in dem Moment, in dem Sie eine permanente Drohnenüberwachung haben, in dem Moment, in dem sozusagen viele Zivilisten sterben, in dem Moment, in dem Kinder ihre Eltern verlieren, herrscht natürlich ein extrem hohes Maß an Traumatisierung vor. Also es gibt Studien über den Jemen, die sind erschreckend. Aber nochmal, es bezieht sich hier auf Signature Strikes, also gezielte, nichtlegale Tötungen von Personen, bei denen dann halt auch in der Vergangenheit, wie wir das alle kennen, in größeren Menschenmengen Drohnen ab, also die Wirkmittel abgeschossen worden sind. Das ist in der Tat Terrorisieren für die Bevölkerung, diese permanente Luftraumüberwachung, dieses Nicht-Wissen, wann geschossen wird und wohin geschossen wird. Es traumatisiert kleine Kinder. Aber noch mal, es ist ein komplett anderes Einsatzszenario als das, was gegenwärtig hier in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland diskutiert wird.
Da kann man sich fragen, für wen ist der Clip? Ist der jetzt für jemanden in Afghanistan, der dann sieht, ist eine Bundeswehrdrohne, ich kann entspannt meinem afghanischen Alltag weitergehen?
Ja, das frage ich mich auch, dass man auch glaubt, dass immer der Status Quo so bleiben wird. Also, dass sich durch diese Waffen nicht etwas verändern kann. Von Hegel gibt es ja diesen Satz, das Wesen des Kriegers ist seine Waffe. Also, die Waffe macht, die prägt quasi auch das Bewusstsein und prägt das Bewusstsein derer, die einen Angriff befehlen, derer, die den Angriff ausführen, derer, die überhaupt dafür sind, dass man angreift. Und man öffnet sich damit neue Spielräume. Das sehen wir einfach daran, dass wir in viele Konflikte eher nicht reingehen oder zögerlich reingehen oder versuchen, das nicht so öffentlich zu machen, wenn Soldatenleben tatsächlich bedroht sind und es dann passieren kann, dass dann einige Zinkserge zurückkommen. Dann sagt man immer, das machen wir lieber mal nicht, während man eben bei anderen Konflikten dann viel schneller dabei ist.
Wir haben hier zu Hause zum Beispiel jetzt einen vierjährigen Geburtstag gefeiert. Da tauchte die erste Drohne als Geschenk zu Hause auf. Also so eine kleine, vierrotorige, die dann so im Wohnzimmer fliegen kann. Und man muss schon sagen, so Drohnen haben schon so eine sehr hohe technofetischistische Attraktivität. Man überlegt sich sofort, was wie hier jetzt der Looping und so. Und man will das dann alles austesten. Und das könnt ihr mir nicht erzählen, dass sie im Krieg hier bei der Bundeswehr im Auslandseinsatz, wenn dann so eine Drohne auf dem Flugfeld steht, dass sie da nicht auch anders über ihre Möglichkeiten nachdenken als vorher. Egal was sie hier im Ausschuss, wie sie darüber reden.
Jetzt kommt ein Rechtsanwalt zu Wort, Andreas Schiller, vom European Center for Constitutional and Human Rights. Und der sieht das, wie man ahnen kann, etwas anders.
Was umfasst der Schutz der Soldatinnen und Soldaten? Zählt zum Objektschutz etwa ein Angriff auf den Tanklaster, wie im Fall Kundus. Gehört zum Konvoischutz der Angriff auf mutmaßlich Terroristen, um einen nicht näher definierten zukünftigen Angriff zu verhindern, wie im Fall der Tötung des deutschen Staatsbürgers Benjamin E durch einen US-Drohenangriff in Pakistan. Die beiden genannten Fälle sind nicht aus der Luft gegriffen, sondern fanden mit deutscher Beteiligung bereits statt. Sie waren jeweils auch Gegenstand parlamentarischer Untersuchungsausschüsse, weil es Anlass gab, die deutsche Beteiligung genauer zu untersuchen. Die Fälle zeigen, dass Zweifel an der Glaubwürdigkeit der Bundesregierung und des Verteidigungsministeriums angebracht sind.
Sehr, sehr gut. Ich glaube, ich muss mir gar nicht groß kommentieren. Können wir einfach mal so stehen lassen und hören gleich den nächsten Clip von Schüller.
Die bisherige Praxis der Bundesregierung begründet erhebliche Zweifel daran, dass die bewaffnete Drohne tatsächlich nur in einem engen Rahmen einsetzen würde. Bewaffnete Drohnen sind das Werkzeug dafür, das Völkerrecht weiter auszuhöhlen und seiner friedenssichernden, gewaltbegrenzenden Funktion zu berauben. Die Unterstützung des US-Drohnenprogramms durch Datenweitergabe und Nutzungserlaubnis für den Luftwaffenstützpunkt Ramstein sprechen eine andere Sprache. Die Verfügbarkeit bewaffneter Drohnen lässt die Hemmschwelle für Einsätze sinken, eine Eskalation von Gewaltzulasten der Zivilbevölkerung ist zu befürchten.
Das ist, glaube ich...
Jetzt können wir einfach raten, wer hat ihn eingeladen?
Ganz genau. Und wir hören jetzt nicht eine Entgegnung direkt darauf, aber doch eine Entgegnung auf das Argument von Wüstner.
Sondern es geht um asymmetrische Bedrohung und ein Agieren, größtenteils außerhalb des humanitären Völkerrechts. Das soll nicht zur Folge haben, dass wir, das keinesfalls, weder das Grundgesetz zu- noch, glaube ich, dass es jemals ein entsprechendes Mandat geben würde. Aber das soll nicht die Folge haben, wir kämpfen gleichermaßen außerhalb des humanitären Völkerrechts. Aber es ist natürlich so, dass wir in den letzten Jahren erlebt haben, wie andere Akteure kämpfen. Und das ist geprägt von Hinterhalten, Handstreichen und vielen Dingen mehr. Und wenn wir klassisch aufklären, auf Patrouillenfahrten gehen, mit anderen Akteuren, auch zivilen Akteuren, in Zusammenarbeit bestimmte Projekte innerhalb bestimmter Regionen voranbringen wollen, dann besteht natürlich immer eine enorm hohe Bedrohung.
Das ist ProSAR-Produktion, das könnte man unendlich lange machen. Da haben die auch immer den Vorteil des Anekdotischen, weil sie dann selber entscheiden können, was sie aussortieren und was sie da auch ausblenden. Dass man sowieso Auslandseinsätze mittlerweile nur noch reduziert auf den militärischen Aspekt und den Zivilen dann nicht mehr sieht. Das ist ja auch schon so ein Erfolg für solche Ansinnen.
Ja, was ihr hier nochmal anspricht, ist die asymmetrische Kriegsführung. Das ist ja ein Begriff, der sehr stark in Deutschland geprägt wurde durch Herfried Münkler, der dieses Buch geschrieben hatte, Die Neuen Kriege. Das wurde ja nach dem 11. September auch sehr stark rezipiert. Das ist allerdings auch eine viel ältere Debatte. Es gibt ja schon eine Theorie des Partisanen von Karl Schmidt, die er nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg schreibt. Er interessiert sich da auch sehr für linke, guerilla-Kriege und ist da sehr fasziniert von. Und diese Problematik, die entsteht durch asymmetrische Kriegsführung, ist ja folgende, dass der zwischenstaatliche Konflikt in einer regelbasierten Situation stattfand, in der auch Friedensschlüsse möglich sind, in der es gewisse Regeln gibt, wie man zum Beispiel mit Kriegsgefangenen umgeht, während wir im asymmetrischen Krieg eigentlich diese Regelhaftigkeit ständig unterlaufen sehen. Ja, das ist eigentlich das Prinzip dieses asymmetrischen Krieges, wodurch dann auch der staatliche Akteur plötzlich heruntergezogen wird, kann man sagen, dazu, dass er auch in irgendeiner Weise Guerilla-Kämpfer werden muss. Das ist ja im Übrigen auch eine Geschichte, die Hollywood dann immer wieder aufgegriffen hat, sicherlich am berühmtesten mit Rambo. Ja, da kann man das genau sehen. Und dann wird Rambo nachher auch der Guerilla-Kämpfer, der erst mal nur für sich selbst und seine Freiheit kämpft, dann eingesetzt von der Ronald Reagan-Regierung in den 80er Jahren. Und das bedeutet aber eigentlich, dass genau solche rechtsfreien Räume, solche Ambivalenzen und Ambiguitäten entstehen, die doch nochmal ganz deutlich machen, welche Büchsen der Pandora man da gerade alle öffnet, indem man versucht, noch weiter das Ganze auszubauen, durch Aufrüstung. Insofern ist es ein bisschen widersprüchlich, wenn diese drohenden Befürworter immer wieder sagen, ihr im Parlament, ihr entscheidet doch so ganz klar, und wir haben doch dann das Mandat. Aber diese ganzen Unwägbarkeiten, die Ambivalenzen, die können gar nicht davon abgedeckt werden, sondern man begibt sich da eigentlich in eine Bredouille, aus der man nicht mehr aufrechten Hauptes als staatlicher Akteur hinauskommt.
Vor allem besteht halt immer die Gefahr, dass man dadurch, dass man plötzlich diesen ganz situativen, spontanen Krieg ausgesetzt ist, dass man immer in diese Notsituation kommt, in der Nothilfe, also in der es nötig wird, jetzt zu handeln. Und da nützt dann die parlamentarische Dimension im Hintergrund gar nichts, weil die Selbstverteidigung ist natürlich immer erlaubter. Und da wird dann auch das Parlament nicht im Nachhinein, das haben wir ja gesehen, im Kunos der Fall wurde ja eben angesprochen, diese Lkw, dieser Angriff auf diesen Tank-Lkw, der ging ja nun in der juristischen Aufarbeitung in Deutschland nicht so aus, dass auch irgendeinem da in Afghanistan was geholfen wurde. Also dramatisch.
Wir springen ein bisschen, gehen nochmal zu Wüstner und thematisieren jetzt mal, wie ist denn das mit der Rüstungsspirale? Ist das jetzt etwas, was dieser zu pass kommt, wenn die Kampfdrohnen angeschafft werden?
Es ist auch richtig, dass ein technologischer Wettlauf schwerlich oder gar nicht durch einen einzelnen Staat aufgehalten werden kann oder durchbrochen werden kann. Dennoch bin ich der Überzeugung, dass die Begrenzung der internationalen Rüstungen anbetracht gegenwärtiger weltweiter Aufrüstungsbestrebungen ein zentraler Aspekt der langfristigen internationalen Friedenssicherung ist. Ich denke, es sollte hier nicht unterschätzt werden, dass auch vom Handeln einzelner Staaten und insbesondere auch vom Handeln der Bundesrepublik Deutschland erhebliche Signalwirkungen im internationalen Bereich ausgehen könnten, die in Richtung einer glaubhaften Perspektive auf eine internationale Rüstungsbegrenzung wirken.
Das ist wirklich ein toller Literat, der Typ. Also langfristig sind wir alle für Frieden, weil alles andere wäre ja Quatsch. Aber das hat ja keine Aussagekraft für die Kurzfristigkeit. Die drängenden Probleme, die wir jetzt lösen müssen auf dem Schlachtfeld.
Zimmermann sagt jetzt, na eigentlich ist das ein bisschen spät. Also wir können jetzt gar nicht mehr abspringen von den Kampffrohnen.
So leid mir das tut. Also der Zug dürfte abgefahren sein. So dann durch einen völkerrechtlichen Vertrag, heute noch ein Verbot bewaffneter Drohnen durchzusetzen, halte ich für unrealistisch, halte es für unrealistisch, dass die Staaten, die heute bereits über bewaffnete Drohnen verfügen, sich noch nachträglich ex post facto darauf einlassen, diese abzurüssen. Das bedauere ich wirklich zutiefst, aber das ist wohl so. Wo die völkerrechtliche Musik meines Erachtens auch spielt, ist die Frage der automatisierten Waffensysteme und der automatisierten Drohnen. Und da bemüht sich ja die Bundesregierung wirklich, in Genf was auf den Weg zu bringen. Und das ist extrem schwierig, das wissen wir auch. Das ist vermutlich in diesem Kreis hier auch schon thematisiert worden. Wir wissen, dass bestimmte Akteure, die auch da technologisch weit vorne sind, kein Interesse haben, sich darauf einzulassen. Aber da hat man vielleicht am ehesten noch die Chance, auf den Verhandlungsprozess einzubringen und noch einen Verhandlungsprozess hinzukriegen. Aber doch nicht, so leid mir das tut, bei den Waffensystemen, die es nun mal schon gibt.
Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Vielleicht einer der wichtigsten überhaupt. Drohnen hätte man echten können, als sie als Möglichkeit im Raum standen. Aber nicht, nachdem Amerika 15 Jahre lang allen, der Türkei, Pakistan usw. vorgemacht hat, China vor allem, was man mit Drohnen so machen kann. So, und jetzt ist diese Büchse der Pandora einfach offen.
Aber wir erinnern uns, ich glaube, es war die zweite Ausgabe, die Februar-Ausgabe der Neuen Zwanziger. Da haben wir über die Bundestagsdebatte gesprochen zu den automatisierten Waffen und haben dort auch schon grausliche Argumente für diese Systeme gefunden. Und wir erinnern uns, es war selbstverständlich Schutz der Soldaten. Dass ich da doch sehr, sehr skeptisch bin, dass man dort zu etwas Sinnvollem kommt. Sicherlich, man versucht da auf EU-Ebene was durchzudrücken. Aber man muss auch da sagen, ist der Fortschritt ja schon sehr, sehr weit. Und es ging damals bei der Bundestagsdebatte um eine Ächtung dieser automatisierten Systeme. Der Entwurf kam von den Linken und wurde selbstverständlich abgeschmettert. Und wenn man jetzt mal hört, was Wüstner sagt zum Thema autonome Waffen, naja.
Der Punkt ist nur der, bei dieser Frage jetzt aktuell, Bewaffnung von Her und TP, sind wir extrem spät dran. Extrem spät dran. Und meine Sorge ist so ein bisschen, auch wenn Sie, Herr Professor, zu Recht gesagt haben, die Bundesregierung setzt sich in Genf ein mit Blick auf das Thema automatisierte Waffensysteme. Ich hoffe nicht, dass wir erst in zehn Jahren vielleicht dann hier darüber diskutieren, wie wir vor dem Hintergrund künftiger Entwicklungen, Stichwort Autonomersysteme, auch in Europa verfahren werden.
Mit anderen Worten, er will sie eigentlich auch möglichst bald haben. Und jetzt wollen wir nicht wieder so viel Zeit verstreichen lassen wie mit den Kampftronen. Es ist sehr, sehr dramatisch. Aber es gibt dann auch Lichtblicke, nämlich von Seiten der Abgeordneten. Und da bin ich auf einen Namen gestoßen, einer Abgeordneten, die ich vorher überhaupt nicht kannte. Vielleicht manche unserer Zuhörer kennen sie. Katja Keul von den Grünen. Und die hat wirklich gute Arbeit hier mal geleistet. Die stellt nämlich entscheidende Nachfragen, beziehungsweise sie kommentiert, was sie sich da jetzt anhören musste. Und da hören wir uns schon mal den ersten Clip an.
Also würden Sie sagen, dass auch die Einsätze, wie Sie hier die amerikanischen Einsätze, die hier ja ganz klar von allen als völkerrechtswidrig bezeichnet wurden, dass auch diese sich letztlich auf den Begriff drohende Gefahr stützen könnten und damit eben auch genau diese gleiche Legitimierungsmuster greifen würde? Denn auch die Amerikaner machen natürlich geltend, dass diejenigen, die sie töten, im Zweifelsfall ein Risiko darstellen.
Man sieht jedenfalls in der sicherheitsrechtlichen Debatte, also eigentlich in der polizeirechtlichen Debatte, eben eine Tendenz dahin, dass man Einsätze nicht mehr nur knüpfen oder Eingriffe nicht mehr nur knüpfen möchte an konkrete Gefahren, sondern eben auch den Begriff nunmehr der drohenden Gefahr eingeführt hat. Das sind auch entsprechende Verfahren vom Bundesverfassungsgericht gerade anhängig und auch vom Bayerischen Verfassungsgericht. Und das sind eben Situationen, wo man natürlich nochmal mehr rechtliche Unsicherheit erzeugt, wo man sehr viel argumentativen Spielraum hat, beispielsweise dann eben doch zu sagen, es entwickelt sich hier eine Gefahrenlage und eben dann trotzdem auf der Grundlage dessen einzugreifen und insbesondere in Verbindung damit, dass es eben keine Rechtsschutzmöglichkeiten gibt, halte ich das für hochproblematisch.
Sehr gut. Das ist richtig gut. Wenn man so Technik mitbringt, wenn man plötzlich technische Möglichkeiten schafft, eröffnet man Möglichkeitenräume. Etwas, was nicht vorher denkbar war, wird plötzlich sogar praktikabel. Und da gibt es diesen großen Brückenschlag zum Umgang mit den Gefährdern hier in Deutschland. Wir haben das jetzt aktuell auch bei Corona gehabt. Karl Lauterbach meinte, dem Virus ist ja egal, was ein privater und was ein öffentlicher Raum ist. Also sollte das der Virusbekämpfung auch egal sein. Und ja, die Polizei ist für Virusbekämpfung zuständig, also auch in privaten Räumen. Also da fallen einfach solche Tabus. Soziologisch kommt es immer wieder vor, wenn man ein Wirkmittel hat, und eigentlich wäre es ganz gut, man hätte auch ein Problem dafür. Dann klappert man die Möglichkeiten so ab. Wo könnte man dieses neue Wirkmittel dann so einsetzen? Und das ist dann so wichtig, dass man dann wirklich parlamentarisch darüber diskutiert. Denn dann kommen die Ideen auf, dass man konkrete Gefahren, aber auch drohende Gefahren plötzlich hat. Und dann hat man doch plötzlich jetzt so ein Wirkmittel, also das Wirkmittel, die Lösung, erzeugt überhaupt erst das Problem. Und plötzlich hat man es mit Drohenden, es gab schon immer Drohende Gefahren, nur man hat sie halt juristisch noch nicht so gefasst, dass man plötzlich mit der Unverletzlichkeit der Wohnung und mit Drohnen und diesem ganzen Technophetischismus anders umgehen konnte. Also in der Sicht sehr guter Abgeordneter, Keul ist ein Abgeordneter.
Das war jetzt die Frage, die gestellt hat, ist Katja Keul. Und das andere war, glaube ich, Marxen, der auch ein Experte ist. Drohende Gefahr, das bedeutet eigentlich auch permanenter Kriegszustand. Also man muss eigentlich die ganze Zeit damit rechnen, dass ein Krieg kommt. Ein bisschen das, was wir auch ganz kurz angesprochen hatten bei den autonomen Waffensystemen im Februar. Da hatte ich zitiert aus diesem Buch von Grégoire Chamayou, Theorie der Drohne. Und dann gibt es noch ein anderes gutes Buch, das ich dazu empfehlen kann, die Regierung des Himmels. Da geht es um Luftkriege bis hin zu drohen. Und da kommt man eben auch genau in diese Situation, dass man dann eine permanente Kriegssituation schafft. Und Keul sagt jetzt was sehr Schönes, mal in puncto Schutz der Soldaten. Denn davon haben doch jetzt alle geredet.
Bei dem Nutzen ist für uns ganz klar, dass der Schutz von Soldatinnen und Soldaten das entscheidende Argument ist, dass hier in die Waagschale zulegen ist. Und dass ich deswegen auch etwas erstaunt bin, dass wir in den letzten Wochen, wo wir mehrfach Gelegenheit hatten, uns nochmal nachzufragen und Beispiele schildern zu lassen, wo der Vorteil der bewaffneten Drohnen im Vergleich zur herkömmlichen Luftunterstützung ist, sehr, sehr wenig Beispielsfälle konkret benannt bekommen haben. Ich habe auch nochmal schriftlich mehrfach nachgefragt, wie oft wir denn in Afghanistan davon abhängig waren, dass uns Bündnispartner mit bewaffneten Drohnen zur Hilfe kommen. Daraufhin die schriftliche Antwort der Bundesregierung. Das könne sie nicht sagen. Darüber hätte sie keine Statistik. Das finde ich schon sehr erstaunlich, gerade wenn wir hier in dieser Debatte auf diese Argumente ganz offensichtlich angewiesen sind.
Grandios! Katja Keul, Grüne, Rechtsanwältin.
Einfach mal nachgefragt, wie ist es denn da? Sag doch mal die Fälle, wo war das denn so hilfreich?
Genau, wie oft ist denn Deutschland schon? Wir haben ja, wie heißt das bei den Atomwaffen, damit doch dieses Mit-Teilhabe, die Dings der Bombs-Teilhabe. Das gibt es doch hier anscheinend irgendwie so auch. Das sind doch alles Bündnis-Koalitionen. Katja Keul, die müssen wir uns mal merken. Genauso wie Franziska Brandner. Es tauchen jetzt so viele grüne Frauen auf im Parlament, wo man wirklich aus den Socken ist, wenn man die Redebeiträge so hört.
Jetzt nochmal Zimmermann. Wir hören nochmal Keul. Es geht nochmal um die Frage, inwieweit diese Drohnen jetzt den Krieg entgrenzen.
Ich will jetzt nochmal auf die Zusicherung kommen, die uns die Bundesregierung gemacht hat, dass diese bewaffneten Drohnen immer nur im Einsatzgebiet, selbstverständlich nur im Einsatzgebiet gesteuert werden würden. Anders als bei den völkerrechtswidrigen Einsätzen der USA. Was machen wir denn damit, dass wir erleben, dass die Einsätze sich geografisch zunehmend entgrenzen? Ich möchte zwei Beispiele nennen. Sea Guardian erstreckt sich über das gesamte östliche Mittelmeer und ist gar nicht mehr genau zu begrenzen, wo der Einsatz anfängt und aufhört. Und auch Mali, EUTM Mali, haben wir im letzten Mandat entgrenzt. Die Staatsgrenze Malis ist nicht mehr maßgebend. Wir haben unbestimmterweise fünf Nachbarstaaten mit einbezogen. Also Niger bis hin zu Mauritanien, die bisher überhaupt gar nicht mit Kampfhandlung involviert sind. Was machen wir denn jetzt mit der Zusage der Bundesregierung im Hinblick auf diese geografisch inzwischen völlig entgrenzten Bundeswehrmandate?
Da kommt jetzt die Entgegnung von Zimmermann.
Der Einsatz bewaffneter Drohnen auf das Staatsgebiet von Mali beschränkt würde. Das ist durchaus denkbar, dass der Bundestag darauf hinwirkt, dass die Bundesregierung sagt, wir mandatieren einen Einsatz insgesamt für die fünf Sahelstaaten, also Niger, Maritainien, Mali und andere, aber Drohnen-Einsatz nur im Bereich von Mali oder von Teilbereichen von Mali oder in Afghanistan, Einsatz von Drohnen nur im westlichen Teil von Afghanistan, während die deutschen Truppen ansonsten fiktiv in ganz Afghanistan eingesetzt werden dürfen. Das obliegt dann der politischen Verantwortung des Deutschen Bundestages, ob ein Mandat, welches keine solche geografische Eingrenzung von Drohnen-Einsätzen vorsieht, ob ein solches Mandat dann vom Deutschen Bundestag mandatiert und gebilligt würde. Oder ob im Vorfeld der Bundestag und die Fraktionen, die die Bundesregierung tragen, in Abstimmung mit der Bundesregierung darauf hinwirken können, dass ein Mandat ebenso eingegrenzt wird. Aber das ist eine Entscheidung von Ihnen, Mitglieder des Hohen Hauses, ob Sie sich diese politische Verantwortung zutrauen, dass Sie das so einhegen können. Und ich habe, vielleicht bin ich naiv, aber ich habe das Vertrauen in diese deutsche Demokratie, dass sie bis heute jedenfalls dazu noch in der Lage ist. Und ich hoffe, bis auf weiteres noch.
Vielen Dank, Herr Zimmermann. Ein bisschen verräterisch, das Ende, das dann nochmal gesagt wird. Und ich hoffe, dass sie es auch bleiben wird. Denn man weiß ja auch nie, wer in der Bundesregierung einmal sitzen wird und wer da das ein bisschen anders sieht. Und zugleich wird hier ja im hohen Maße verschleiert, dass wir ja schon bei ganz vielen Entgrenzungen teilnehmen. Und dass es keineswegs so ist, dass wir noch heute im Jahr 2020 von so prima eingehegten Kriegen sprechen können.
Ja, vor allem dieser pseudo-legitimatorische Verweis auf das Parlament wird das schon, also gerade wenn es da, klar, einen neuen Krieg anzufangen, also den Einsatz dann in Afghanistan zu eröffnen, das erfordert dann schon den 11. September und sowas. Aber diese Verlängerung, die rutschen einfach so durch. Und wir wissen alle, wo die Beschlussvorlagen herkommen, wenn der Afghanistan-Einsatz verlängert wird. Da kommt direkt aus der Feder von den waffenführenden Menschen da vor Ort, die genau wissen, worum es geht und was sie brauchen. Und da sagt das Parlament nicht nein. Und wenn er dann sagt, aber sie entscheiden ja dann, dann ist das so eine Verlagerung, die klar formal richtig ist, aber inhaltlich eben nicht.
Wüstener bläst ins gleiche Horn.
Auch ich und auch wir vertrauen dem Primat, auch wenn es manchmal eine Debatte so scheint, als vertrauen sie sich nicht selbst. Also wir gehen davon aus, dass wir von Ihnen allen völkerrechtskonforme Mandate erhalten mit klaren Zielbeschreibungen. Davon gehen wir aus.
Jetzt noch einmal Keul, die noch einmal einen wunderbaren Moment hier hat.
Da will ich nur noch mal sagen, ich glaube schon auch an unsere parlamentarische Demokratie. Aber im Zusammenhang mit Bundeswehreinsätzen ist es glaube ich nicht so wirklich realistisch zu glauben, dass wir im Einzelnen hier das Mandat zusammenstellen im Parlament, sondern das ist hier ein exekutives Recht. Das Mandat wird von der Exekutive erstellt, ausgeplant und uns so vorgelegt, dass wir als Parlamentarier nur noch Ja, Nein oder Enthaltung votieren können. Es gibt auch keine Möglichkeit von Änderungsanträgen oder Ähnliches wie bei Gesetzen. Also das läuft hier ein bisschen anders. Und von daher glaube ich, geht es so ein bisschen ins Leere hier zu glauben, wir könnten sozusagen hier im Detail als Parlamentarier die Bundeswehreinsätze durchplanen. Das funktioniert also nicht.
Sehr, sehr gut argumentiert. Und damit endete das dann auch sobald, also es gab noch ein paar Nachfragen, aber das ist jetzt Stand der Dinge. Die SPD ist inzwischen eher für Kampfdrohnen, doch kann sich dazu durchringen. Wir werden sehen, und ich würde das mal hier prophezeien, dass das im nächsten Jahr dann auch noch kommen wird, wahrscheinlich noch vor der Wahl wird man sich doch dazu durchringen können. Denn es sind jetzt alle im Prinzip für Kampfdrohnen, außer Grüne und Linke im Bundestag. Insofern steht dem ja eigentlich nichts mehr im Wege. Und das andere wird dann in den Ausschüssen geklärt, die Details. Aber dann werden wir sehen, dass damit auch wieder neue Konflikte auf uns zukommen.
Ich müsste fast zynisch vermuten, dass es ja vor der Bundestagswahl stattfindet, weil das auch im Grünen Interesse ist, dieses Thema aus einer Koalitionsverhandlung rauszuhalten. Weil sie wissen auch, wo ihre Grenzen sind. Und man will sich da nicht das Leben gegenseitig schwer machen. Aber wer weiß, das wird genau zu beobachten sein.
Das ist natürlich ein sehr guter Punkt. Und Keul sagt dann auch, doch ein bisschen resigniert. Naja, eigentlich ist diese Debatte ja hier schon vorab geklärt. Also da zeigt sich auch jetzt ein bisschen bei diesen Ausschüssen, das hat man ja Roger Wilmsen davor geworfen, die Ausschüsse diesen zu entscheiden. Man kann hier, wenn man sich diese drei Stunden ganz ansieht, doch auch merken, naja, da wird jetzt nochmal auf das verwiesen, auf das man seit Jahren verweist. Und eigentlich sind die Würfel gefallen. Und es hat ein bisschen was von Theater. Insofern ist es schön, dass Keul hier nochmal ein paar Argumente bringt, die auch diese Experten ein wenig zumindest aus der Reserve locken. Und deswegen, weil wir das, was vermutlich dann bald auch in Deutschland haben werden, mit den Kampfdrohnen, sollten wir mal auf einen aktuellen Konflikt ganz kurz blicken, in denen Drohnen eine ganz, ganz große Rolle spielen. Wir blicken nach Bergkarabach. Uns geht es jetzt nicht darum, das alles geopolitisch einzuordnen, mit Aserbaidschan, mit den Armeniern, sondern uns geht es jetzt einfach mal nur um diese Drohnenfrage. Und da habe ich etwas sehr Interessantes gehört, in dem Podcast Sicherheitshalber von Thomas Wiegold. Thomas Wiegold, genau. Und da gibt es jetzt schon in der 34. Folge einen sehr interessanten Podcast über solche militärischen Fragen. Dort war dann auch jemand, der im Verteidigungsausschuss zu Gast war. Aber wir lassen jetzt mal zwei andere zu Wort kommen. Und zwar ist da zunächst einmal Ulrike Franke, die das ein bisschen einordnet, was jetzt da gerade mit den Drohnen in Bergkarabach geschieht.
Einer der ersten Punkte, den ich erwähnen würde, wäre dieser Propaganda- oder tatsächlich ja fast Twitter-Krieg. Also wir haben beide Seiten, vor allen Dingen aber auch das Aserbaidschanische Verteidigungsministerium ist ganz, ganz stark auf Twitter unterwegs, mit eigenen Hashtags und mit eben vielen Videos, Videoclips, die in der Tat vor allen Dingen von Drohnen umwerden. Und das ist so etwas, was wir sehen. Wir haben in diesem Konflikt auf beiden Seiten, aber vor allen Dingen auf der aserbaidschanischen Seite, mehrere Drohnen im Einsatz. Auf der aserbaidschanischen Seite reden wir von israelischen und türkischen Systemen vor allen Dingen und auf der armenischen eher von ja selbstgebauten, kann ich gleich noch was zu sagen, die haben nicht ganz so viele Systeme. Und der Clou ist natürlich, dass alle Drohnen-Systeme sensorisch mit sich tragen und vor allen Dingen eben Kameras. Bedeutet jedes Mal, wenn man eine Drohne einsetzt, egal ob jetzt für einen Angriff oder für Überwachung oder befür auch immer, ist es wie als hätte man quasi ein Fernsehteam dabei.
Das ist also ein medialer Krieg auch, der da geführt wird. Und ich habe dann aufgrund dessen mir das nochmal genau angesehen, wie diese Bilder inszeniert werden, wie sie dann auch angeteasert werden bei Twitter und so. Und das ist, davon mal abgesehen, was das ohnehin schreckliches auslöst, wenn diese Kampfdrohnen dort eingesetzt werden, ist das nochmal dieses Stahlgewitter der Pixel. Das ist auch nochmal etwas, was zum einen eine positive Seite hat, insofern als wir überhaupt nach Bergkarabach blicken, auch wenn das gerade viele noch nicht so wollen und sagen, ach, das ist aber auch so ein ganz ungünstiger Konflikt, wo man gar nichts gewinnen kann.
Wahnsinnig versteckt auf der Landkarte.
Genau, also wir blicken dann dahin und zugleich zeigt das natürlich, dass dieser Einsatz von Drohnen die medialisierte Kriege hervorruft, die sehr, sehr billig zu produzieren sind. Denn das war ja immer diese Frage auch bei den Golfkriegen, beim ersten schon, inwieweit der schon nur noch medial ist. Da gab es ja solche Äußerungen dann auch von Jean Baudrillard, dem Simulationstheoretiker, der sagte, der Golfkrieg hat überhaupt nicht stattgefunden. Damit wollte er nicht leugnen, dass es den Golfkrieg gab, sondern er wollte sagen, es ist nur noch ein medialer Krieg. Und man setzt sich eigentlich nur noch einen Bildschirm gegenüber oder ist als Zuschauer in der Analystenposition, wenn man das dann abends in den Nachrichten sieht, diese Bilder. Und das vervielfältigt sich jetzt, ist jetzt in den sozialen Medien extrem vertreten. Also Kriegsbilder, die wir sonst eher im ernsten Nachrichtenjournal vermuten. Und dass man das auch populistisch dann sehr stark einsetzen kann, das passiert ja da bei dem Konflikt in Bergkarabach auch, ist, glaube ich, ein ganz guter Punkt.
Ja, man hat ja wirklich eine erstaunlich virtuelle Dimension seit diesem Vietnamtrauma, also seitdem man in Amerika weiß, die Bevölkerung muss irgendwie mitmachen. So, und dann hatten wir ja diesen Golfkrieg 91 mit diesen grünen Bildern und CNN, große Momente und so weiter, hat man ja dann so gemacht, dass man quasi mitfiebern konnte. Das ging ja dann so weit, dass im Kosovo-Krieg, der sehr von der NATO dann so richtig gemacht wurde, dass dann, und auch mit erster deutscher Beteiligung, dass die dann hier nur alle drei Tage oder so Pressekonferenzen hatten, bis dann der Wesley Clark, der das als Befehlshaber von Amerika ausgemacht hat, so ein richtiges 200-Mann-Presse-Team nach Brüssel schickte, nach Europa, um dann einfach mal eine tägliche Pressekonferenz, um den News-Cycle voranzutreiben und nicht immer nur Fragen zu beantworten, die Journalisten haben, sondern sozusagen die Story schon herzustellen und so. Und seitdem werden ja Kriege so geführt, außer Afghanistan. Sie schlafen so medial ein. Dann ist quasi fast alles möglich. Dann bekommt auch keiner mal mit, dass es in Amerika einen neuen Präsidenten gibt, der dreimal mehr bombt als der vorherige, der auch schon als sehr bombwütig und drohendenfetischistisch galt. Und dass Trump da nicht nur die größte Bombe, die größte Nicht-Atombombe aller Zeiten abgeworfen hat, sondern auch dreimal mehr Wirkmittel pro Tag einfach abschmeißt. Das ist nicht groß thematisiert worden.
Du hast ja gerade schon angesprochen, beim Kindergeburtstag, dass man jetzt da schon als Vier- Fünfjähriger mit einer Drohne spielen kann. Man kann sagen, Drohnen sind auch relativ billig. Und das zeigt sich jetzt auch in der Kriegsführung. Dazu äußert sich hier Frank Sauer auch im Podcast.
Es verschiebt die Kalkulation mit Blick auf die Kosteneffizienz, weil diese Systeme einfach sehr billig sind im Vergleich zu beispielsweise bemannten Systemen, das, was man vielleicht früher mit Kampfhubschraubern oder Flugzeugen gemacht hätte.
Das steht schon mal fest.
Und ich glaube, es unterstreicht auch nochmal eine Sache, die ja in der Forschungsliteratur schon seit Längerem diskutiert wird und natürlich auch in der politischen Diskussion immer wieder im Raum steht.
Diese Erkenntnis, das Vorhandensein von unbemannten, ferngesteuerten Systemen drohen, erhöht den politisch-militärischen Handlungsspielraum.
Vulgo, die Hemmschwelle sinkt. Auch das, glaube ich, kann man relativ klar sagen, weil man kann mit diesen Systemen eben Dinge tun, die man vorher mit anderen Systemen nicht tun konnte. Christopher Lauer, der ehemalige Berliner Abgeordnete, der hat jetzt Abschlussarbeit im Studium über Werner von Braun geschrieben. Der immer als Gründer der raketengestützten Waffentechnik gilt und so weiter. Und dann zur NASA abgeworben wurde. Und als wir jetzt diese Drohne zu Hause hatten, diese kleine, musste ich es auch nochmal so vergleichen, einfach was es so bedeutet. Die größte technologische Errungenschaft, um so Raketen zum Fliegen zu bringen, war, dass sie aufrecht bleibt. Dass sie weiß, wo hinten und wo vorne ist. Und dass sie sozusagen richtig fliegt und nicht plötzlich in sich verkreiselt, weil der Druck hinten falsch ausgesteuert wird. Und dann fällt sie einfach unkontrolliert zu Boden. Und dieses gerade Ausfliegen oder auch leichte Steuern hat man dann hinbekommen, indem man in die Spitze der Rakete einen Kreisel eingebracht hat. Der hat sich dann wahnsinnig schnell gedreht, hatte dadurch eine eigene Trägheit, die sich von der Trägheit oder von der Bewegung der Maschine, der Rakete um diesen Kreisel herum unterschieden hat. So hat sich die Rakete jetzt so bewegt, dass die Rakete weiß, was sie tut. Das war mehr als ein Manhattan-Projekt, solche Raketen fliegen zu kriegen. Heute hast du diese Drohnen, die einen Knopf auf der Fernbedienung haben, wo es heißt, wenn du den drückst, fliegt die zu dir zurück, egal wo sie vorher war. Man fragt sich ein bisschen, die Drohne weiß immer, wo sie ist. Dieses größte Problem des Zweiten Weltkriegs, diese Raketen fliegen zu kriegen, ist da einfach drin, weil wir nämlich alle in unseren Handys diese Bewegungssensoren haben, die in der Herstellung also nur noch 3, 50 Cent kosten oder sowas. Und die baut man jetzt einfach in 17 Euro kleine Spielzeug-Plastik-Drohnen. Und da sieht man, wie dieser technologische Fortschritt Wasser ermöglicht. Das haben wir jetzt sozusagen als Spielzeuger, aber wir wissen genau, was das bedeutet.
Und selbst gebastelte Drohnen kommen da in Bergkarabach zum Einsatz, zumindest von armenischer Seite.
Bauteile sind alle verfügbar.
Ja, wir hören nochmal Frank Sauer.
Mehr unbemannte Systeme, auch mehr Automatisierung in diesen Systemen und was die Konsequenzen daraus sind. Und ich muss schon sagen, diese loitering munitions, das ist jetzt aber so ein bisschen so eher so, wie mich das anmutet. Es hat so ein bisschen was von fliegende Minenfeld. Also es hat sowas gerade, wenn man an so HP denkt, wo eben kein Mensch mehr darüber entscheidet, ob das Ziel bekämpft wird oder nicht.
Es hat sowas von Opferaktivierung.
Man hat eben Pech, dieses Ding hängt gerade oben im Luftraum rum. Und wenn man Pech hat und zum falschen Zeitpunkt an der falschen Stelle ist, dann fällt einem das auf den Kopf.
Hätte eigentlich auch in dem Ausshow sprechen sollen, denke ich. Wir hören jetzt ganz zum Schluss. Minen.
Minen sind die einzige Kriegstechnologie, bei der es wirklich mal gelungen ist, globale Ächtung zu erzeugen. Das ist uns ansonsten bei Flächenbombardements und so etwas ein bisschen. Aber Minen durch Lady Di und so weiter, das war ihr großes Thema. Bei Minen haben wir es wirklich mal geschafft. Eine der ganz wenigen, wir haben auch schon über die Gesichtserkennung, die eigentlich auch mal so eine Ächtung bräuchte, hier schon gesprochen. Und das, was er jetzt sagt, das sind im Grunde fliegende Minenfelder, ist, was diese historische Dimension angeht, wirklich nicht falsch. Das ist wirklich sehr gut, sollte man sich merken.
Da müsste man sehr händige Juristen dran setzen, die dafür sorgen, dass sie als Minen tatsächlich definiert und anerkannt werden und deshalb dann verboten werden. Vielleicht wäre das durch die Hintertür noch möglich dann. Jetzt erinnern wir uns ganz am Anfang haben wir und das zog sich dann durch diese ganze Debatte im Ausschuss durch immer wieder gehört. Das machen wir zum Schutz der Soldaten. Nun ist es allerdings ja so, dass wenn es um kriegerische Auseinandersetzung geht, in der Regel nicht einfach so ist, dass man dort sich ein bisschen beschießt und irgendwann schließt man wieder Frieden, sondern in der Regel geht es ja auch darum, dass man ein Land okkupiert oder sich wieder aneignet, annektiert, wie immer man es auch nennen möchte. Und dazu braucht man aber dann doch wieder Soldaten. Und das ist jetzt der Schluss Clip. Da kommt noch einmal Ulrike Franke zu Wort.
Also gerade eben ja so Leute wie ich, die sich mit eben ja Hightech und neuen Technologien und so beschäftigen. Ich finde, man hat oft die Tendenz zu denken, dass die Zukunft des Krieges dann total anders aussieht, wegen diesen neuen Technologien. Also es wird dann auch teilweise, dass die Debatte geht dann bis zu ja blutlosen Kriegen. Und es ist dann alles irgendwie von Maschinen und Robotern und all so weiter. Ich glaube da ja überhaupt nicht dran. Meines Erachtens kommen diese ganzen Fancy-Technologien im Zweifel eher oben drauf, anstatt dass sie anstelle genutzt werden. So heißen, wir haben zwar vielleicht eben Fancy-Drohnen, aber am Ende, und das muss man eben auch wirklich so klar sagen, hat man dann doch noch den 18-jährigen Soldat, der irgendwo im Schlamm stirbt.
Das war jetzt ein ernstes Thema, das aber glaube ich sehr wichtig ist. Ich denke, wir müssen diese Entwicklungen, die wir uns im Silicon Valley ansehen, wenn wir über Smartphones reden, die sich optimieren oder so, auch im militärischen Imblick behalten. Denn hier haben wir auch eigentlich wieder so einen Punkt, der sich jetzt ein bisschen auch als Leitfaden durch unseren Podcast sieht, dass gerade technische Veränderungen die politischen Räume extrem verändern und die Politik wieder reagiert und oft eben hinterher hinkt und dass aber sehr viele Entscheidungen von der Technik, so scheint es fast, gefällt werden. Und die Politik sagt dann auch oft, naja, so ist es ja jetzt auch, was sollen wir denn nun machen? Das ist ja etwas, was du, glaube ich, schon in der ersten Folge diagnostiziert hast, das von der Politik wenig zu erwarten ist, sondern dass das woanders herkommt, dann zum Beispiel aus der Wirtschaft oder aus der Technik und da zeigt sich das eben in sehr grausamer Weise.
Genau, neue Ideen, das war Schirmachers Mantra, kommen entweder aus der Technologie oder aus den Büchern. Steht die Politik da weit hinten an. Okay, dann kommen wir doch mal zu einem nächsten Thema, bei dem wir Technophetischismus sehen, Parlamentsarbeit, Ausschussarbeit, die in dem Falle wirklich grandios misslingt, wie wir gleich sehen. Wir beginnen aber mit einer historischen Dimension, und zwar einem Werbevideo der Bundesregierung. Genau genommen geht es um das Agrarministerium Landwirtschaft, also Klöcken aus Laden. Und es gibt eine neue, wie soll man sagen, durch die Nachrichten ging das so als eine Agrareform, oder so Brüssel hat eine Agrareform gemacht, und alle sind so ein bisschen unzufrieden. Das ist nicht ganz richtig.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wer hat gesagt, es sei ein Systemwechsel?
Ein Systemwechsel, genau.
Was willst du da so kleinreden?
Genau, eigentlich wurde nur der neue Haushalt beschlossen. Das ist halt Teil des großen Haushalts. Wie verteilen wir die nächsten 7 Jahre den größten Posten, den die EU zu vergeben hat, nämlich diese Agrarsubvention? Da geht es um 350 Milliarden Euro oder so. Also jedes Jahr 50-60 Milliarden Euro, die da verteilt werden. Naja, Systemwechsel, wir nähern uns mal auch über das System. Wie begann das eigentlich mit dieser Agrarpolitik? Warum ist das so ein mega Thema? Das ist ja in Deutschland ein mega Thema. Wenn der Bundestag ein Haushaltsding macht, dann heißt das ja nicht, ein Drittel fließt jetzt hier zu den Bauern oder so. In Brüssel ist das mega Thema Butterberge. Wir kennen es alle noch. Es ist virulent. Und wenn wir uns über die Bundesregierung nähern, diesem Thema, was ist denn passiert ist im Oktober, beginnt es hier bei 1957. Es ist ein Werbevideo aus Klöckners Laden.
1957 war nicht nur das Geburtsjahr der heutigen EU, sondern es wurde auch der Grundstein für die gemeinsame Agrarpolitik gelegt. Sie stand ganz am Anfang der europäischen Integration. In der Nachkriegszeit ging es der Wirtschaft in Europa schlecht. Viele Orts herrschte Hunger. Alleine konnte kein Staat diese Probleme lösen. Daher war es unter anderem das Ziel der sechs Gründerstaaten, der europäischen Landwirtschaft gemeinsam auf die Beine zu helfen und so die Versorgung mit Nahrungsmitteln sicherzustellen.
So, was kann man denn da dagegen haben? Das ist so ein bisschen wie wenn die Bundesregierung sagt, wir brauchen auf jeden Fall Krampfdrohnen, denn wir müssen ja unsere Soldaten verteidigen. Wir brauchen auf jeden Fall eine gemeinsame europäische Agrarpolitik, denn wir wollen ja den Hunger besiegen. 1957, kurz nach dem Krieg, da wurden vom Kanzleramt, vom Bundestag noch Kartoffeln gesät. Na ja, dann schon nicht mehr, aber wir wissen ungefähr, welchen Gründungsmythos, welche große Erzählung hier dahintersteckt. Heute, zum Glück, ist es natürlich ein bisschen anders.
Heute orientiert sich das Angebot der 14 Millionen europäischen Landwirte in 27 Mitgliedstaaten daran, was der Verbraucher wünscht. Und durch offene Märkte kommen nicht nur ihre eigenen, sondern vielfältige Produkte aus aller Welt auf unsere Frühstückstische.
Es ist eine Erfolgsgeschichte, Sorte das Gleiche. Der Tisch ist gedeckt, Tischlein deckt dich, genau. Also in dem Video hier auch, das ist ein Europa League zu Tisch. Und dann wird dieser Tisch gedeckt. Und zwar auch mit exotischen Früchten aus den fernen Ländern.
Nun ja, damit argumentiert man ja auch immer, warum Freihandel so eine prima Sache ist. Dann macht man auch mal gerne so ein Szenario auf, dass wir sonst nur sieben Produkte im Regal hätten. Und jetzt können wir wirklich einmal wählen.
Jetzt kannst du aus den Vollen schöpfen. Sie haben jetzt diesen Dreh Oktober 1957 Hunger besiegt. Und jetzt nicht nur Hunger besiegt, sondern auch noch mit Benefits. Die diese Geschichte fortgeführt. Also eine ganz grandiose Siegesgeschichte der europäischen Agrarpolitik. Wenn denn nur nicht so viel Kritik daran käme, beispielsweise hier von Attac. Die haben nämlich auch ein Infovideo gemacht.
Die europäischen Institutionen, Kommission, Rat und Parlament entscheiden über die Zukunft der GAP. Doch sie meinen immer noch, am wichtigsten seien Wirtschaftswachstum und die globale Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der europäischen Lebensmittelindustrie. Das heißt, europäische Lebensmittelkonzerne sollen möglichst billig Essen in Nicht-EU-Länder exportieren.
Export Europas, nicht nur bei Lebensmitteln, sondern grundsätzlich, zerstört ja auch andere Märkte, wenn man da plötzlich durch Subventionen mega krasse Niedrigpreise oder sei es nicht Subventionen, sondern dass man einfach, Stichwort Tönnies, Arbeitsbedingungen in Deutschland hat, bei denen selbst in Afrika man sich an den Kopf kratzt und fragt, hä, wieso können wir hier nicht mithalten mit diesen Preisen, ist ja unglaublich. Dann hat man halt sowas. So, und jetzt haben wir, steigen wir ein, in die politische Dimension, denn wir haben einige Politiker, beispielsweise im U-Parlament Albert Dress, Albert Dess von der CSU, unserer lieben Bauernpartei CSU, der auch nochmal in einer SWR-Doku, die ich auch verlinke, weil die wirklich ziemlich gut ist, von 2019 diesen Spin, Europa, das ist und so, wir haben zwar den Hunger besiegt, aber wir dürfen ihn jetzt nicht nachlassen, weil man kann dieses ganze Narrativ noch in die Zukunft schlagen. Wir haben es jetzt von 1957 zu den 2000ern und was ist eigentlich so in der Zukunft?
Wir müssen die Produktivität steigern. Wir brauchen bis zum Jahr 2050 60% Landesmittel mehr auf der Welt. Und die Produktivitätsteigerung bedeutet nicht, dass die Umwelt geschädigt wird, weil das kann man so wissenschaftlich nicht feststellen.
So, 2020, also der Clips von 2019. Wir haben durch diese grandiose Überproduktion in Europa, also das kann man echt nicht feststellen, dass wir erstens dadurch die Umwelt geschädigt haben, zweitens wissen wir doch, sehr viel mehr Menschen 2050 brauchen 60% mehr Lebensmittel. Wer, wenn nicht wir Europäer, sollte die denn herstellen, sonst verhungert ja die Welt. Also dieses 1957er Argument wurde jetzt nochmal 100 Jahre in die Zukunft strapaziert und damit rechtfertigt und wir fragen uns alle, wer ist dieser Herr Dess? Können wir uns den gleich nochmal, ja, wir lernen ihn gleich nochmal ein bisschen kennen. Vorher allerdings Glöckner. Glöckner strägt auch an diesen politischen Narrativen natürlich mit.
Es ist schnell, sind Empfehlungen für Landwirte ausgesprochen. Vielleicht war man selbst noch nie auf dem Feld, aber Empfehlungen sind immer sehr schnell ausgesprochen. Aber diese Arbeit zu machen und erfolgreich so zu machen, dass 450 Millionen Menschen ernährt werden in der Europäischen Union, das ist die Grundlage für alles andere, was an politischen Zielen überhaupt da ist. Ein hungriger Magen findet keinen Frieden und dass wir uns keine Gedanken darüber machen müssen, ob wir Essen haben. Das war nicht immer so.
Ja, also wir könnten auch jetzt nochmal über die Trümmerfrauen vielleicht an dieser Stelle noch reden oder so. Also es ist wirklich toll, nochmal ganz alte Bundesrepublik wird hier nochmal aufgegriffen. Und auch so dieses Feld wird aufgetan im buchstäblichen Sinne von der Ernte. Mir fällt da gleich das Volkslied ein. Wir haben das Korn geschnitten mit unserem Plankenschwert. So ist es heute noch.
Du dachtest gerade noch, die Soldaten haben einen besonderen Beruf. Nein, das sind natürlich die Bauern. Weil auch ein Soldat findet mit leerem Magen keinen Frieden. Deswegen setzt sich Klöckner dafür ein, dass hier alle ihr Essen kriegen. Weil ansonsten ist alles nichts. Und das ist das Tolle. Angenommen, du kennst ein paar Podcaster, die machen sich drüber lustig, dass die Bundesministerin die historische Dimension nochmal aufmacht. Dann nimmst du dir ein aktuelles, nachrichtliches Thema.
Ich will auch noch mal betonen, das kommt auch immer so kurz. Hier geht es auch um unsere Nahrungsmittelproduktion. Das ist nicht unerheblich. Gerade in Corona-Zeiten haben wir gemerkt, wie wichtig das ist, dass wir das auch gewährleisten.
Die Corona-Zeiten, wir sind quasi immer in der Krise. Deswegen muss die Nahrungsmittelindustrie die ganze Zeit immer mit 60 Milliarden subventioniert werden. Gibt es da vielleicht andere Ideen? Nein. Wer treibt uns diese Ideen aus? Na klar, es ist die Lobby. Die Agrar-Lobby, vielleicht lohnt sich der eine oder andere Vergleich. Wir kennen alle die Waffen-Lobby in Amerika. Die haben so Listen, welcher Kongressabgeordneter ist auf unserer Seite, wen müssen wir wie bestächen. Sie bestächen quasi durch die Bank alle und schrecken auch nicht davor zurück. Schulmassaker dann in der Öffentlichkeit als diesen Selberschuld und so. Also die Schuld zur Weisung zu machen entsprechend. Wir denken, die Waffenlobby in Amerika ist die schlimmste Lobby auf der Welt, die man sich in westlichen Demokratien vorstellen kann. Und ich widerspreche und sage, nein, es ist die europäische Agrarlobby. Die ist noch krasser und schlimmer als die amerikanische Waffenlobby. Das ist die These, mit der wir jetzt hier reingehen. Dieses SWR-Ding, was ich euch verlinkt habe, das ist wirklich sehr gut. Das könnt ihr euch mal angucken. Es kam letztes Jahr, es wird dann so gesendet und dann versendet. Dann ist es wieder nicht verfügbar. Aber egal, die Agrarlobby ist eine Megalobby.
Was ist so besonders in der Agrarpolitik? Unsere Recherchen beleuchten ein dichtes Interessengeflecht. Getragen von Unternehmen der Agrarindustrie, einversreichen Multifunktionären und Abgeordneten, die mit ihnen eng verbunden sind.
So, und das Ding ist, wir sprechen immer von Lobby im Sinne von, da sind die Parlamentarier und dann kommen so die Lobby-Abgeordneten und dann quatschen die so miteinander und gehen wieder auseinander. Nur das ist hier nicht so. Hier kommt die Agrarlobby, lässt sich wählen und ist dann die Politik. Also hier kann man gar nicht von Lobby sprechen. Hier brauchen wir einen ganz anderen Begriff. Und wir kommen zurück zu Albert Deß von der CSU. Wir hören hier, wie er im Parlament sitzt und die ganze Sache mal so ein bisschen runterspielt mit diesen Megasubventionen.
Wenn alle öffentlichen Ausgaben in Europa über Brüssel abgerechnet werden, dann wäre der Agraranteil unter 1%. Aber da müssen Sie schon nochmal ein bisschen Klartext reden, auch in der Öffentlichkeit, dass die Landwirtschaft nicht der große Subventionsempfänger ist, wie er immer dargestellt wird.
So, sein Argument, wenn man alle öffentlichen Finanztransaktionen, also alle staatlichen, kommunalen, europäischen, in einen Top wirft, dann ist ja das bisschen Agrarsubvention gerade mal 1%. Und das sollte man sich jetzt nicht so dran abarbeiten.
So argumentiert man ja auch gerne bei Aufrüstung. Oder wenn es darum geht, dass der Militäretat erhöht werden muss, dann sagt man auch, ja, das ist natürlich eine große Summe. Aber wenn man das mal ins Ganze rechnet, und da man noch die Länder und Kommunen dazu nimmt, dann ist das ja auch verschwindend gering.
Genau, 2% für die Verteidigung, damit alles andere ermöglicht wird. Die anderen 98%, die wir uns hier gönnen wollen, da müssen die 2% Verteidigung schon sein. Genau, also so sitzt er im Parlament. Und hier gibt er noch mal ein Statement gegenüber. Es ist ein Wunder, dass er überhaupt bereit war, mit Journalisten zu sprechen. Aber man hört auch so am Sing-Sang, wie seine Bereitschaft sich darstellt.
Investitionen in den Umweltschutz sieht er skeptisch. Die Diskussion, dass die Landwirtschaft bei uns noch viel umweltfreundlicher werden muss, das finde ich vollkommen unternehmen. Wenn wir jetzt sagen, da muss 20% der Fläche für die Umwelt zur Verfügung gestellt werden, die Folge wird sein, wir verlagern Produktion in andere Gebiete der Welt. Er argumentiert, wenn Land für ökologische Zwecke verwendet wird, weichen die großen Produzenten ins Ausland aus. Albert Deß will den bisherigen Ansatz erhalten, nachdem die Gelder pro Hektar ausgezahlt werden.
Ansonsten verlagern wir die Produktion unserer Milch doch nur nach Somalia. Das ist doch eine große Gefahr, wir wollen das hier behalten. So wäre es jetzt, diese Albert Deß. Es ist wirklich unglaublich.
Auch Albert Deß gilt als gut vernetzter Funktionär. Der gelernte Landwirtschaftsmeister ist Ehrenkreisobmann beim Bayerischen Bauernverband. Seit über 20 Jahren ist der Vorstandsvorsitzende einer der größten Molkereien, der Bayernland AG. Sie produziert Käse für Rewe oder Aldi und für den Export. Jahresumsatz über eine Milliarde Euro. Und der Abgeordnete ist Beiratsmitglied im größten deutschen Agrarhandelskonzern, der Bayvar AG, die ebenfalls stark im Export von Nahrungsmitteln engagiert ist. Einen Interessenkonflikt sieht Albert dessen nicht. Er sagt, er könne die Vorstandstätigkeit bei der Molkerei mit dem Abgeordnetenmandat vereinbaren.
Herr Stefan, der sorgt dafür, dass du auch was auf dem Teller hast. Und der steht auch mit der Sense auf dem Feld.
Absolut, das ist ganz leidenschaftliche, ganz besondere Arbeit, die er macht. Ich frage mich dann wirklich, wie kann das denn sein, dass man als Chef einer Milliarden-Molkerei und als Teilhaber da in diesem gigantischsten Großhandel weltweit und nach Bauernverbandes Ehrenobmann und so was, wie kann man denn da noch ein Mandat überhaupt haben? Also wie ist das denn überhaupt vereinbar? Das ist doch unglaublich. Dafür braucht man jedenfalls wirklich einen neuen Begriff. Hier kann man nicht einfach Lobby sagen, sondern das ist, wie damals als Dick Cheney und die ganze Ölbranche Ramsfeld und so ins Weiße Haus gesetzt wurde. Das war jetzt das Europäische Parlament. Da gibt es natürlich noch welche, die halten hier in Deutschland den Laden zusammen. Das ist zum Beispiel im Agrarausschuss Franz Josef Holzenkamp.
Wir informieren uns auf der Messe Münster. 6 Milliarden Euro Jahresumsatz macht die Agrarvis mit Futtermitteln, Schadgut und Pestiziden. Kurz, alles, was die Agrarindustrie dem Bauern bietet. Auch Mineral- und Stickstoffdünger sind ein Geschäftszweig. 2016 warnte der Vorstand im Geschäftsbericht. Sollte die Düngeverordnung verschärft werden, erwartet das Unternehmen deutliche Umsatzeinbußen. Damals schon im Aufsichtsrat der Agraris Franz Josef Holzenkamp. Auf der Homepage des Bundestages sind seine Nebentätigkeiten angegeben. Während er die Düngeverordnung verhandelt, wird sein Einkommen bei der Agraris angehoben. Von Stufe 2 auf 3. Er verdient also statt maximal bis zu 7000 Euro, dann maximal bis zu 15000 Euro monatlich.
Also der Typ arbeitet für ein Unternehmen, das einen Milliardeninteresse daran hat, dass der Dünger nicht zurückgefahren wird. Gleichzeitig kommt Europa und sagt, Deutschland, pass mal auf, ihr habt ja ganz schön nitratverseuchten Boden. Wir haben ja jetzt so eine neue Regelung. Das ist nicht ganz so gut, ihr müsst da mal was machen. Und der Typ ist jetzt im Bundestag, im entsprechenden Ausschuss dafür zuständig. Ja, was denn eigentlich? Das Gemeinwohlinteresse, formuliert von der Europäischen Union, nämlich die Nitratverseuchung zurückzufahren, gegen oder mit seinem privaten Interesse, nämlich dieses Unternehmen, das Milliarden damit verdient, Dünger zu verkaufen, jetzt muss er irgendwie ausbalancieren. Gelingt sowas denn?
Und auf Gehaltsstufe 3 zu bleiben dabei.
Genau, er kriegt dann auch 5-stellig im Monat extra, neben seinem Bundestagsgehalt, das ist unglaublich. Naja, er ist jedenfalls, wie soll man sagen, so ein kleiner Wechseltyp. Da wechselt man ja immer gerne mal hin und her. Das ist dann ihm auch biografisch passiert.
Einer der Multifunktionäre ist demnach Franz Josef Holzenkamp. Die Düngeverordnung ist das letzte Gesetz, das er mit auf den Weg bringt. Danach wechselt er endgültig in die Wirtschaft und wird Präsident des Reifeisen-Verbandes, dem größten Wirtschaftsverband der Agrarindustrie.
So, also er bringt im Bundestag noch die Düngeverordnung mit auf den Weg. Jetzt können wir alle überlegen, entspricht jetzt dem europäischen Standard weniger Nitrat und so oder eher nicht. Die Antwort liegt natürlich auf der Hand. Das ging jetzt nicht gerade zum EU-Sinn aus. Aber jetzt hören wir hier mal eine Zahl, bei der wir uns fragen, können wir sowas nicht als persönliche Zurechnung noch mal in Rechnung stellen als Bürger?
Seit Monaten läuft eine Klage der EU gegen Deutschland, weil die Düngeverordnung das Trinkwasser nicht effektiv schützt. Immer noch droht eine Strafzahlung. 850.000 Euro täglich. So lange, bis Deutschland die Gesetze endlich nachbessert.
Also der Typ hat als Bundestagsabgeordneter noch die Düngeverordnung im Agrarausschuss mitverabschiedet und mitgestaltet, von der er weiß, die kostet Deutschland 850.000 Euro am Tag Strafzahlung, weil sie nämlich den europäischen Vorgaben nicht entspricht. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich würde gerne, dass er das Geld bezahlt. Warum soll das jetzt von meinem Steuergeld bezahlt werden? Das ist doch, also hier haben wir es doch nur wirklich mit, das ist doch nicht nur Lobbyismus, das ist doch reine Korruption, was hier stattfindet.
Und der Typ würde es schon leisten können.
Genau, der wurde doch nachweislich dafür bezahlt, uns alle hier schlecht dazusteht zu lassen finanziell. Also wir werden jetzt quasi alle als Straftäter behandelt von der Europäischen Union zu Recht, weil er da so ein Gesetz mitgemacht hat. Also in deren Sicht, das ist schon erstaunlich. Und so ein Agrarausschuss kann halt machen, was er will, wenn er entsprechende Mehrheiten hat.
Die Vorbereitung der Gesetzesvorlage geschieht unter Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit. Hier im Agrarausschuss. Wie Tiere gehalten werden und wie unsere Lebensmittel produziert werden, wird hier entschieden. Die Analyse der Besetzung zeigt, knapp die Hälfte der Abgeordneten hat einen direkten Bezug zur Landwirtschaft.
Also die Hälfte ist die Lobby. Und dann ist ja noch die Lobby selber mit drin.
Ein großer Teil von ihnen hat außerdem hohe Posten in der Agrarindustrie, im Bauernverband oder in der agrarnahen Finanzwirtschaft.
Es ist die Agrarwirtschaft selbst, die dort die Gesetze macht.
Und jetzt muss man sich noch mal in Erinnerung rufen, was Roger Wilhelmsen vorgeworfen wurde. Er würde sich so auf das Parlament konzentrieren. Aber das wirklich Tolle, da wo unsere parlamentarische Demokratie lebt, da blickt er nicht hin in die Ausschüsse. Und da blicken wir jetzt mal hin.
Ja, da geht es übel zu. Und selbst Klöckners Beirat, also die Ministerien haben ja immer so ein paar Beiräte, die sie sich so halten, um sozusagen Sensorium dafür zu haben, was man als nächstes bekämpfen muss. Selbst der ist ein bisschen besorgt.
Der wissenschaftliche Beirat des Bundeslandwirtschaftsministeriums stellte schon vor vier Jahren fest, dass die Agrarpolitik stark von Interessengruppen beeinflusst wird. Verantwortlich sei die gut organisierte Lobby der Landwirtschaft und der Agrarindustrie.
Ja, kann man damit Frau Klöckner mal konfrontieren. Ja, haben Sie hier gemacht. Es ist ein sehr lustiger Clip.
Parlamentarier im Agraroschuss, das ist ja vor allem in der CDU-CSU-Fraktion ziemlich industrielastig besetzt. Also wenn man die Nebenjobs so anschaut. Wie sorgen Sie da für einen Ausgleich in der Politik?
Das ist mir neu, dass das industrielastig sei. Also wenn jemand einen eigenen Hof zu Hause hat, dann ist er für mich ein Pragmatiker zum Beispiel.
Ich spreche von Aufsichtsratsposten bei großen agrarindustriellen Unternehmen.
Also ich kenne Gitta Connemann, die hat diesen Aufsichtsratsposten nicht, oder Marlene Mortler oder andere. Also ich glaube, wir sollten da schon fair sein und nicht mit diesen Schwarz-Weiß-Kategorien arbeiten. Es gibt überall Interessen.
Es gibt überall Interessen.
Und ich finde aber sehr schön, dass sie am Anfang dieses Narrativ versucht. Ich bin ja hier die Weinkönigin aus Rheinland-Pfalz. Die haben zu Hause einen Hof, sieben Kühe und ein Feld. Und da willst du denen doch jetzt nicht vorwerfen, wenn die sich noch in Berlin ein bisschen politisch engagieren. Und dass aber dann die Interviewer sehr schön dazwischen gehen. Und so inszeniert sie sich ja hier immer. Also sie ist hier wirklich so als Kristel von der Post. Fährt sie hier durch die Lande und geht auf Einfeste. Und das glaubt sie ist auch, bisweilen habe ich den Eindruck, glaubt sie tatsächlich, dass irgendwas mit Agrarproduktionen heute zu tun hat, wenn sie hier auf einem Weinfest ist und dann eine selbstgemachte Marmelade angetreten bekommt.
Ja, also das erinnert mich auch immer so an die ganzen Diskussionen zum Thema Erbschaftssteuer und sowas, wenn es dann immer heißt. Nee, das sind ja alles Vermögen im Sinne von Betriebe, die den Familien gehören. Und den kann man das ja nicht aus der Hand schlagen, nur weil der Vater stirbt, weil der Sohn soll es ja weiterführen und so.
Der will doch auch Schreiner sein und der will doch die schöne Werkstatt vom Papa behalten.
Genau, die fünf Gesellen, was wird denn dann aus denen? Und die Realität ist aber, dass wir in Deutschland eben Clans haben, die mal an 300, mal an 500, mal an 800 Unternehmen beteiligt sind. Und das geht dann als Familienunternehmen durch, denen man nicht mal da ein Stück irgendwie abschöpfen kann. Und in der Ansicht ist das schon gruselig. Und jetzt nähern wir uns dieser gemeinsamen europäischen Landwirtschaftspolitik, der GAP. Und da gibt es Herbert Dorfmann, das ist ein Südtiroler. Der spricht also Deutsch, ist gleichzeitig natürlich Verbandschef des Südtiroler Bauernverbandes und ist auch da so ein Unternehmer. Und wie soll das anders sein, ist natürlich der Berichterstatter für das Thema. Es ist ja immer die EU-Kommission macht einen Vorschlag. Da muss das Europäische Parlament sich dazu verhalten. Also müssen sie jemanden auserwählen, der für sie die Strippen in der Hand hat und die ganzen Anträge und Wünsche der Parlamentarier zusammenarbeitet. Und derjenige, dieser Berichterstatter für die GAP, also für diese großen 350 Milliarden, die jetzt wieder neu verteilt wurden, ist selber Verbandschef des Südtiroler Bauernverbandes. Wir hören jetzt einfach mal sein Statement. Das ist so ein beliebiges, wurde halt kurz mal gefragt. Und nach allem, was wir jetzt gehört haben, ernähren wir uns jetzt diesem Thema. Die Bauern kriegen Subventionen für Fläche, dann kommt ein bisschen qualitativ, ein bisschen für Bio kriegen sie doch noch was extra. Und dann gibt es ja noch Marktpreise. Man will ja vielleicht auch nochmal ein bisschen Marktwirtschaft bewähren lassen. Und dazu äußert er sich hier.
Ich war immer schon dafür, dass wir in der GAP, in der Gemeinsamer Agrarpolitik, zwei Dinge bedenken müssen. Einerseits sicher eine Unterstützung der Einkommen über die erste und über die zweite Säule. Aber daneben muss die Gemeinsamer Agrarpolitik doch auch Voraussetzungen schaffen, damit der Markt in Europa funktioniert. Und sicher sind wir nicht mehr in einer Zeit, in der die Gemeinsamer Agrarpolitik Mindestpreise festgelegt hat. Aber trotzdem denke ich, dass Marktpolitik nach wie vor ein wichtiges Element sein muss. Das zeigen im Übrigen auch die Erfolge, die wir haben.
Also wir merken uns mal das Wort Marktpolitik.
Solche Politik noch machen, zum Beispiel im Bereich Obst und Gemüse, im Bereich Wein, aber auch die Unterstützung im Bereich Promotion. Und ich glaube, dass wir auch in anderen Sektoren, ich denke besonders an die Milch, uns überlegen müssen, welche Marktinstrumente gibt es, damit Angebot und Nachfrage halbwegs ins gleiche Weg kommen und wir vor allem verhindern, dass die Preisausschläge und die Preisunterschiede über die Zeit, dass die Variationen zu stark werden.
So, also das Einkommen der Bauern in Europa besteht erste Säule, einfach nur Subventionen für Fläche. Zweite Säule, also die erste Säule ist schon 80% aller Subventionen, das ist quasi schon überflächerte Art bedeckt. 20% gibt es noch so für ein paar Bio-Qualitätszuschläge, wenn man dann doch mal ein bisschen Freifläche oder Grün oder sowas hat, gibt es ein bisschen extra. Und dann gibt es ja als dritte Säule in Anführungszeichen noch den Markt. Man tritt ja noch als verkaufender Verkäufer, also als jemanden, der ein Gut abgibt und Geld einsammelt auf den Markt auf. Und er ist sich hier so sicher, dass Säule 1 und 2 sowieso im Sinne der Bauern ist, dass er die ganze Zeit über die Säule 3, also das Marktgeschehen, spricht im Sinne von, es wäre cool, wenn wir da auch noch mal eine Marktpolitik haben, die uns erstens den Markt abschließt, zweitens die Gewinne sichert, drittens Kartelle ermöglicht. Und so geht da irgendwie die Liste so insgeheim durch. Verpackt das natürlich in Worte, dass wir das nicht so ganz deutlich verstehen. Aber wenn die am Ende so frech sind, dass sogar der Berichterstatter hier nochmal sagt, es wäre schon gut, wenn wir auch noch ein bisschen Unterstützung bei der Promotion vom Staat bekämen. Dass sie jetzt in Afrika und in Asien und in Südamerika ihr Zeug bewerben und das auch noch vielleicht irgendwie steuerlich absetzen oder was ist so die Idee. Dass man auch das noch finanziert bekommt. Also es ist wirklich eine dramatische Ausprägung von Gier einfach, würde ich mal sagen.
Ich mache mir ja bei solchen Argumentationen jetzt immer Argumente der Neoliberalen zu eigen. Denn dann fällt ja gleich auf, dass es Marktpolitik nicht geben kann. Also Märkte sollen ja frei von Politik sein, sagen die Neoliberalen. Und das könnte man ja hier wirklich einmal ganz neoliberal verfechten und sagen, ja dann soll das mal an den Märkten geregelt werden. Und dann wird sich zum Beispiel zeigen, dass es durchaus sinnvoll ist, wenn in Südamerika, wenn in Nordafrika dort Menschen selbst etwas anbauen und dort selbst eine prosperierende Agrarindustrie entsteht und dass es nicht so ist, dass diese angewiesen sind auf Importe aus Europa. Und genauso kann man auch sagen, Freihandel, ja was ist denn Freihandel? Freihandel meint, dass ungleiche Verträge ständig geschlossen werden, dass man eben, wie du es jetzt auch gerade genannt hast, Kartelle versucht in irgendeiner Weise zu bilden. Und diese Kartellstrukturen, die lösen sich irgendwann wieder, aber die formieren sich sofort wieder neu. Und wenn wir uns diese Verflechtungen, von denen wir jetzt schon einiges gehört haben, einmal vergegenwärtigen, was das bedeutet, dann heißt das, wenn das eine Kartell sich aus irgendwelchen Gründen auflöst, kann sich sofort in diesen Formationen wieder etwas Neues bilden. Mit freiem Markt hat das überhaupt nichts zu tun. Also hier sollte man eigentlich mal als Neoliberale auftreten und sagen, ja jetzt aber mal wirklich radikaler Markt.
Denn das, was wir hier sehen, ist Kommunismus der Reichen. Hier ist einfach Sozialisierung von allem. Also die europäische Agrarwirtschaft braucht keine subventionierten 40% Überschüsse, die man in den Export gibt. Das ist völlig unnotwendig. Das ist eben nicht mehr 1957, wo die Grundversorgung nicht gesichert ist. So, was könnte eine Alternative sein? Das kritische Bauernbündnis, wir haben es satt, äußert sich. Sie machen immer mal so Demos und haben auch ein paar Konzeptpapiere. Aber wenn sie dann mal zugeschaltet werden im Fernsehen, ist es dann doch nur die Tagesschau 24, mittags irgendwie. Und hier hören wir uns doch ein paar Argumente an. Erstens zum bäuerlichen Einkommen.
Also ich kenne keine Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die sagen, ich freue mich, dass ich auf diese Subvention angewiesen bin. Was die aktuellen Erzeugerpreise angeht, ist es so, dass ein Drittel bis 50% dieser Subventionen für uns Bäuerinnen und Bauern unser Einkommen ausmachen. Das zeigt, wie wichtig diese Subventionen für die Bäuerinnen und Bauern sind. Aber wenn wir ordentliche Marktpreise hätten, also wir Bäuerinnen und Bauern von dem Liter Milch oder dem Kilo Kartoffeln oder der diezeit hohende Getreide, die wir produzieren, leben könnten, dann sind wir gerne dazu bereit, auf diese Subventionen zu verzichten.
So, also Subventionen, was heißt das eigentlich? Das ist übrigens, wie heißt der eigentlich sein Name? Philipp Brändle.
Brändle.
Brändle, der hier gesprochen hat. Also wir haben es satt von dem Bündnis. Was er hier sagt, ist ja, wir haben keine ordentlichen Marktpreise und dafür ganz schön viele Subventionen. 30 bis 50 Prozent des bäuerlichen Einkommens besteht aus Subventionen. Subventionen, man könnte ja nun auch sagen, es ist ja eigentlich Quatsch. Also beziehungsweise es ist ja eigentlich am Ende egal, ob der Bauer 50 Prozent seines Einkommens von mir aus der Hand bekommt oder 50 Prozent erst aus meiner Hand über Steuereinnahmen zum Start, dort dann in irgendeinem komischen Modus nach Größe verteilt und dann kriegt der größte Bauer den größten Berg von diesem Geld. Warum kann nicht einfach alles über Marktpreise gelöst werden? Warum rechnen wir nicht einfach aus, dass die Mehrwertsteuer von den 16 oder 19 Prozent 2 Prozent in bäuerliche Subventionen fließen? Also sind jetzt alle Supermarktpreise um 2 Prozent niedriger? Und dafür müssen die Bauern oder die Produzenten mich direkt überzeugen als Käufer? Und es wird nicht nochmal durch so einen staatlichen Lobbyismus, Agrarausschuss im Bundestag geleiert, dieses ganze Geld. Wozu eigentlich? Da könnte man wirklich mal drüber nachdenken, ob wir jetzt, wir kennen es ja von Marx, ab und zu erreicht man ja so gesellschaftliche Niveaus, wo man sagen kann, ab jetzt, herzlichen Glückwunsch an alle, macht mal eine große Party, stehen neue Möglichkeiten zur Verfügung. Wir haben die Grundvorsorge gesichert, dann machen alle eine große Party und sagen, wir können es jetzt neu machen. Wir haben es jetzt erreicht, wir können es jetzt neu machen. Wir können von den Subventionen jetzt Abstand nehmen. Also darüber könnte man ja wirklich mal nachdenken. Zweiter Punkt Agrarrealität, das ist vielleicht ein ganz wichtiger Punkt jetzt für 2020. Wir stoßen an ökonomische und ökologische Grenzen mit diesem System.
Uns vereint die Kritik an der aktuellen Agrarpolitik sowohl der deutschen als auch der europäischen, die für uns Bäuerinnen und Bauern ganz stark eben das Wachsen oder Weichen propagiert. Das heißt, wir Bäuerinnen oder Bauern sollen zu immer schlechteren Preisen immer günstiger Rohstoffe für den Weltmarkt produzieren. Und dieses System, was wir Bäuerinnen und Bauern seit Jahren gelehrt bekommen, das stößt eben sowohl an seine ökonomischen Grenzen. Das zeigen auch die vielen bäuerlichen Proteste der letzten Wochen und Monate. Aber auf der anderen Seite stoßen sie eben auch an ökologische Grenzen. Also wir haben immer mehr Probleme mit dem Klimaschutz, mit der Biodiversität. Und hier stehen wir für ein Umsteuern von Bäuerinnen und Bauern gemeinsam mit der Zivilgesellschaft hin zu einer ökologischen und auch sozial verträglichen Agrarpolitik, die für uns Bäuerinnen und Bauern eben auch funktioniert.
So, und jetzt ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Dieser Alpades oder dieser, wie hieß er der andere, Holzenkamp. Das sind ja gar nicht die Bauern. Das sind ja gar nicht die Produzenten der Rohstoffe, sondern das sind ja die, die die Raffinerien haben. Also die Molkereien und so weiter, die kriegen das ja angeliefert. Nur die Bauern, die sitzen ja gar nicht in diesen Ausschüssen, sondern das ist ja Politik der Produzenten, die hier stattfindet. Also hier muss man mal ganz klar unterscheiden zwischen erzeugt tatsächlich das Fleisch, die Milch, das Getreide und bekommt das angeliefert und macht dann eben ein großes Auswahlverfahren. Deine Milch kostet halt zwei Cent mehr. Nee, scheiß drauf, nimm dein LKW wieder mit nach Hause. Hier stehen noch drei andere Schlange, die ich genauso ausquetschen kann, weil meine Molkerei ist die einzige hier im Umkreis von 300 Kilometern. Und da muss man als Bauer marktwirtschaftlich überlegen. Lohnt es sich jetzt 400 Kilometer mit 400 Tonnen Milch zu fahren? Ja oder nein? Und es lohnt sich halt meistens nicht. Also hier findet ja Marktschließung über Marktkonzentration der Produzenten statt. Und wenn die Klötner sagt, also die Bauern ehrenwerterweise lassen sie sich fünf Uhr morgens aus dem Bett klingeln, um die cool zu melken, die spielen ja hier gar keine Rolle. Also die spielen ja in diesem ganzen Lobbydruck gar keine Rolle.
Sehr schön sehen an einem Konzern wie Ferrero. Also Ferrero, da gehört ja Nutella dazu. Und für Nutella braucht man Haselnüsse. Diese Haselnüsse, die müssen ja irgendwo herkommen. Die kamen sehr häufig aus der Türkei. Dort gab es dann kleine Höfe. Da kann man wirklich mal von Höfen sprechen. Wo diese Haselnüsse dann angepflanzt wurden, geerntet wurden. Und das wurde dann geliefert an Ferrero. Und selbstverständlich gab es da auch schon immer ein gewisser Druck, der von Konzernseite ausgeübt wurde. Zugleich aber sind jetzt auch Haselnüsse nicht überall zu finden. Das ist also gar nicht so leicht. Das heißt, man war in einem recht guten Abhängigkeitsverhältnis. Aber bei Ferrero ist es auch so, dass man immer mehr sagt, na ja, noch besser wäre eigentlich, wenn wir das alles in einer Hand hätten. Da müssen wir uns keine Preise diktieren lassen. Und dann versucht man in irgendeiner Weise, halt diese Bauern auch dazu zu bringen, dass sie ihre Höfe verkaufen. Und da merken wir, wie diese Konzernkonzentrationen dazu führen, dass eben solche Bauern, wie wir hier einen sehen mit Philipp Prentle, eigentlich immer weniger stattfinden sollen, da die ja nicht nur durch diese Äußerungen hier in der Tagesschau, sondern auch durch das, was sie da eigentlich machen, sehr unbequem sind für Herrschaften wie Des und Co.
Genau.
Weil wenn die sich durchsetzen, die haben sie am Ende eigentlich in der Hand. Das ist ja, wie letzte Woche schon, beim Lieferkettengesetz. Es gibt ja letzten Monat dieses Paradox. Warum haben eigentlich diejenigen, die Rohstoffe haben, so wenig Macht? Das kann man ja jetzt widerstellen. Warum sind die Bauern eigentlich so schlecht dran und die Produzenten, also die Molkereien und die Schlachter, warum sind die eigentlich so, die Spinnen im Netz? Dritter Punkt, den er hier auch anspricht, das ist natürlich, hier kann man auch wieder ganz groß denken, was Fluchtursachen und so weiter angeht.
Unser Ansatz ist, dass wir sagen, wir wollen eine lokale Qualitätsproduktion und wir wollen Produkte produzieren für den deutschen und europäischen Markt und eben nicht für den Export, weil ja auch das Meer an Schweinefleisch zum Beispiel, da haben wir einen Selbstversorgungsgrad von 120 Prozent, und exportieren einen großen Teil an Schweinefleisch, das macht wieder Märkte in anderen Teilen der Welt kaputt. Also diese Subventionen machen durchaus Sinn, wenn sie eben richtig angewandt werden.
Ja, weiterhin führt er dann aus, diesen Argument kennen wir alle. Es wäre doch, also Subventionen, ja, aber wenn schon, dann doch für qualitative, ja auch nicht für quantitative Arbeit. Und er hat am Ende hier nochmal einen ganz wichtigen Punkt. Der ist für wirtschaftlich denkende Menschen wie du, aber auch für die Allgemeinheit. Wir haben jetzt ja so einen Punkt, wo wir merken, die Politik stößt schon an Grenzen. Beispielsweise bei dem ganzen Corona-Kram, weil es ist nun mal in dem privaten Bereich, irgendwo hört Politik auf. Und das haben wir hier halt auch wieder, wie schon beim Klima, vielleicht weniger Politik und mehr Wirtschaft wagen.
Wenn man aber das Agrarsystem und die Agrarpolitik so lässt, wie sie ist, und auf der anderen Seite dann versucht, die verursachten Fehler über Ordnungsrecht wieder einzufangen, also wie sie es richtig sagen, bei der Düngeverordnung auf Verbote setzt oder auch beim Einsatz von Pflanzenschutzmittel auf Verbote setzt, dann führt das bei den Bäuerinnen und Bauern natürlich zu Frust. Was wir brauchen ist ein Anreiz- und ein Motivationssystem, das Bäuerinnen und Bauern ökonomisch die Möglichkeit gibt und sie motiviert, mehr für den Natur- und Umweltschutz zu tun. Und wenn man dann diese Agrargelder eben umleiten würde, also hin zu mehr Ökologie und zu mehr an einem Tierwohl, dann würde das ein Motivationssystem schaffen. Also inhaltlich haben sie recht. Wir stehen dafür, dass wir in Bezug auf die Düngung und auch in Bezug auf die Nutzung von Pestizide zur Einschränkung kommen. Aber unser Ansatz ist es nicht, das innerhalb von kurzer Zeit über Verbote durchzusetzen, sondern wir müssen an die Wurzeln des Problems, und das ist die Verteilung der Gelder der gemeinsamen europäischen Agrarpolitik.
Anreize, kognitive Überzeugung statt Verbote und normativen Zwang. Das sind zwei ganz gegensätzliche Sachen, mit denen man vermeintlich das selber erreichen kann, aber es spielt auf zwei ganz unterschiedlich erfolgsversprechenden Dimensionen statt.
Zugleich muss man ja sagen, jedes Unternehmen arbeitet profitorientiert. Also auch jemand wie Bauer Brändle wird eine Profitorientierung vor Augen haben. Das bedeutet dann nicht unbedingt, dass man alles tut, um irgendwie Profite zu bekommen. Also da hat man dann persönliche Grenzen oder andere Grenzen, an die man sich halten muss. Aber man kann sagen, durch Anreizsysteme ist es ja möglich, dass man genau dieser Profitlogik, die nicht in einem selbst irgendwie liegt, das hat auch mit Gier und all dem nichts zu tun, sondern die systemimmanent ist, dass man dadurch eben gewisse Dinge auf den Weg bringt und andere Dinge deshalb liegen lässt, weil sie wenig sinnvoll sind. Und da glaube ich auch an Anreize. Ich glaube, wir brauchen auch Verbrote, insofern als gesagt werden muss, was alles nicht mehr geht und welche Düngemittel nicht mehr verwendet werden dürfen. Und wir haben jetzt gerade so einen Film im Kino gehabt wie Vergiftete Wahrheit. Da ging es darum, wie ein Chemiekonzern für diese Teflonfahnen dafür gesorgt hat, dass unendlich viel Leid geschehen ist, dass Menschen an Krebs erkrankt sind, dass ganze Flüsse verseucht waren. Also da sehen wir schon, dass wir da auch viel strenger verbieten müssen. Ich glaube aber, dass wenn man jetzt einfach in einer marktwirtschaftlichen Logik erst mal nur bleibt, dass man da schon sehr viel auf den Weg bringen könnte. Und man könnte auch vor allem argumentativ genau solchen Leuten wie Julia Klöckner den Wind aus den Segeln nehmen, weil sie ja doch immer sagen, ja der Markt und der Wettbewerb und alles. Und dann sagen gerne, machen wir das doch mal.
Genau, also Verbote sind ganz gut bei Gefahr im Verzug. Wenn ein Gefahrgut-Transporter hinten tropft, dann hält man ihn lieber an. Aber wenn man eine ganze Flotte von Autos und dann so ein großes Thema wie Klima oder so, also wenn man so einen ganzen Shift von Wirtschaftsbereichen, von ganzen Gesellschaften organisieren will, dann schafft man das nicht mit Verboten. Sondern das ist dann sehr viel erfolgsversprechender, wenn man Anreize schafft und Verständnis hervorruft. Denn nur Anreize, also einfach nur Nudging zu machen, das wäre auch so ein bisschen, wenn die Leute zwar ihr Verhalten ändern, aber wissen gar nicht wieso. Wenn das lieber so in so einer Aufklärung mit, also mit den Bauern gemeinsam, die große Dimension denken, dann ist auch einiges möglich. Und der EU-Parlament, das EU-Parlament-Mitglied Martin Häusling, jetzt wechseln wir die Seite, wir sind jetzt bei den Grünen, der erklärt ja mal, was er sich von Agrarsubventionen eigentlich verspricht.
Diese ganze Ernährungsindustrie ist einer der Hauptexportbereiche der EU. Und die werden natürlich dafür sorgen, dass ordentlich Geld von der EU in den Agrarbereich kommt.
Martin Häusling kritisiert, dass die Steuergelder derzeit benutzt würden, um indirekt die Industrie zu unterstützen.
Das ist doch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Was nützt mir denn die billige Milch auf dem Teller, wenn um mich herum die ganze Welt auseinanderfällt? Das muss man doch jetzt ganzheitlich denken. Und dieses grüne Ansinnen, grandios. Maria Neuchel von der SPD sitzt auch im Europaparlament. Und sie kommt mal hier auf die Flächen zu sprechen. Was wird eigentlich subventioniert?
Für mich wäre die Frage, welche Landwirte unterstütze ich?
Für mich ist ganz klar die Ansage, öffentliche Gelder für öffentliche Leistungen. Das heißt nicht nur fürs Landhaben Geld kriegen, sondern was mache ich auf dem Land, um Geld zu kriegen? Die Tätigkeit muss entlohnt werden, nicht der Besitz.
So, die Tätigkeit und nicht nur den Besitz. Die Tätigkeit. Dafür ist Politik dann da. Für eine Flächenprämie brauchen wir eigentlich gar keine Politik. Da könnte man das auch alles lassen.
Fast ein bisschen Marxistisch hier nochmal die SPD. Geht nochmal zurück zumindest zu wirklichen sozialdemokratischen Wurzeln. Nämlich die Arbeit. Die schafft hier den Wert.
Genau. Die Arbeit schafft den Wert. Und die Tätigkeit, die kann man dann... Also wir haben in Bayern jetzt schon dieses Gesetz, das dann wirklich im hohen Prozentbereich, also im zweistelligen Prozentbereich Grünstreifen und sowas vorsieht. Und es eben ganzheitlich zu betrachten, was wird denn mit Grund und Boden gemacht? Und dann ist Nahrungsmittelproduktion ein Sektor von vielen, die von denen mit betrachtet werden, die die Nahrungsmittel produzieren. Also es ist eine ganz wichtige Öffnung sozusagen dieses Themas in so eine neue politische Handlungsfähigkeit, die da eigentlich auch dazu kommt. Martin Häusling hören wir hier nochmal von den Grünen zur Lobby.
Wenn die Ernährungsindustrie und deren Vertreter hier im Parlament nicht so mächtig wäre, dann ging es tatsächlich, glaube ich, in eine andere Richtung. Weil die Ernährungsindustrie lebt davon, dass sie mit günstigen Preisen, die ja quersubventioniert werden durch die Direktzahlung, auf Exportmärkte gehen kann.
So, also die gehen auf Exportmärkte, die breiten sich aus, die nutzen ihr Geld und verursachen Probleme. Dieser Bericht, also dieser ganze Film hier, der beginnt übrigens mit dem schönen Satz. Die Agrarwirtschaft produziert ganz schön viele Umwelt-Sorgen. Also ja, die produzieren Essen, aber die produzieren auch Umwelt-Sorgen. Und dafür brauchen wir auch noch eine Lösung. Und es ist ja Klöckners Aufgabe, für die Agrarindustrie, inklusive des ganzen parlamentarischen Armens, ihn zu schützen und eine andere Idee vorzustellen als weniger herstellen, besser herstellen und so weiter. Weil das wollen die ja alles nicht. Und trotzdem muss sie ja irgendwas als Alternative anbieten. Und wir kommen auf ihren Technifittichismus zu sprechen. Erstmal hier als Vorwurf wieder vom kritischen Bauernbindnis.
Also Julia Klöckner setzt immer auf die technische Lösung. Also jetzt ist ja Digitalisierung eben viel beschrieben. Die neuen Gentechniken werden wieder aus Tableau gehoben. Das ist immer der technologische Ansatz. Und da ist es letztlich so, dass meistens die Industrie an diesem Geld verdient. Was wir aber brauchen, sind wissensbasierte Systeme. Also Bäuerinnen und Bauern, die eine Bodenbearbeitung machen, die den Boden und die Artenvielfalt schützt, wenn wir weitere Fruchtfolgen haben. Dann sind das wissensbasierte Systeme, die auf uraltem bäuerlichen Wissen beruhen. Und Julia Klöckner schützt im Prinzip immer die Interessen der Agrarindustrie. Also sie versucht sozusagen, die Probleme, die wir jetzt haben, dadurch zu lösen, dass sie Antworten gibt, die früher schon nicht funktioniert haben.
So, also die Agrarindustrie, von der wir eben schon gesagt haben, da sind die Produzenten, nicht die Rohstoffproduzenten, also die Bauern, sondern da drüber, die Molkereien, die Schlachtereien und so weiter. Die haben noch einen zweiten Arm und das sind die Roboter und Maschinenhersteller, der ganze Maschinenbau, der Agrartechnik herstellt. Und anstatt, das ist ja von dem Brändel die Lösung, wir transferieren jetzt das alles wieder runter auf die bäuerliche Ebene, sagt Klöckner, seinem Vorwurf nach, ne, die zieht das einfach nur in so einen nächsten Markt, der Industrielobby und Agrarindustrie, wo sie wieder in die Milliarden scheffeln können, gerade wenn sie sich wieder parlamentarisch durchsetzen und es heißt, naja, also wir brauchen jetzt diese neuen Maschinen und so weiter. Und das sollte uns auch was kosten, weil es uns ja was wert ist, dass die jetzt damit besser die Umwelt schützen und so weiter. Also da wird wieder nur Geld hingeschoben.
Und wir ahnen ja, wenn es jetzt um die Digitalisierung geht, künstliche Intelligenz hat sie ja auch schon gerne bei solchen Gelegenheiten angesprochen, dass es darum geht, Patentierungen vorzunehmen. Dass also Leute wie Bauer Brändle dafür dann irgendwann noch zahlen müssen, dass sie überhaupt mit irgendeiner Software etwas tun dürfen. Und wieder wird natürlich hier der Bauer, der tatsächlich noch einen Hof hat, in einem Maße hintergangen, dass es so skandalös ist. Also man wundert sich dann doch eigentlich, wie wenig diese Bauern protestieren. Also dafür sind die ja noch alle viel, viel zu zahm.
Oder wie wenig man es sieht. Aber das mit den Lizenzierungen ist wirklich interessant, denn es droht nicht nur bei der Technologie dann dieses Lizenzierungszeug, sondern wir haben es ja jetzt schon beim Saatgut. Du hast ja jetzt schon, dass du bei Bayer das Saatgut dir Lizenzierst, du darfst es dann verwenden und gleichzeitig den Dünger, der passt genau dazu, ist noch dazu. Du kannst ja nicht irgendeinen Dünger benutzen. Also es wird dann auch biologisch ausgeschlossen, dass andere Dünger funktionieren. Du musst dann genau den genmanipulierten Dünger dazukaufen. Also in der Ansicht, da sind wir schon ganz schön Outer Space. Ich habe mich dann gefragt, als ich den Clip geguckt habe, also wie klingt das denn, wenn die Klöckner ihren Technophetischismus so voran stellt? Hat er denn Recht? Ich habe von Klöckner jedenfalls noch nicht so viel mit Technik usw. gehört. Deswegen war ich dann, ich habe dann ein bisschen die Ohren aufgestellt, als sie jetzt ihre Pressekonferenz gemacht hat, als sie vom Systemwechsel sprach, als sie aus Brüssel da zurückkam und die große Einigung erklärt hat. Und ja, wenn man mal drauf achtet, es ist wirklich hochgradig bekloppt.
Es gibt heute keine neuen Spritstechniken, die nicht präzisionen, die werden ja zugelassen im Übrigen, das wissen Sie. Also es gibt nicht irgendwelche Spritzmöglichkeiten, die keine Zulassung haben mit Auflagen. Und das heißt zum Beispiel mit der Digitalisierung, die hilft uns wirklich Zielkonflikte zu lösen, zwischen Schwarz und Weiß, Gut und Böse und den polarisierten Enden. Wir werden Pflanzenschutzmittel weiterhin brauchen. Wer was anderes erzählt, ist nicht ehrlich zu den Menschen.
Schwarz und Weiß, Gut und Böse, links und rechts, alles vereint. Die Digitalisierung bringt es zusammen und löst das Problem.
Wir spritzen ja ganz präzise. Es wird ja nicht mal irgendwie kreuz und quer, sondern und so. Und ja, sie bringt das auf einen ganz schönen Nenner runter.
Da sind neue Techniken gefragt. Dass Deutschland zum Beispiel führend mit Precision Farming, im Übrigen auch gerade für die Ökolandwirtschaft, Sie waren ja wahrscheinlich auch auf der Bio-Fach, haben Sie gesehen, wie wir auch damit hinkommen, zum Beispiel mit Bodenbearbeitung. Da hilft im Übrigen auch die Präzisionslandwirtschaft, die Digitalisierung. Das ist ein Invest in mehr Nachhaltigkeit, wenn es zum Beispiel um Ackerbearbeitung geht, wenn es um Bodenbearbeitung geht, der mechanischen Art. Aber Sie finden doch kaum noch Menschen, die das machen.
Ach, jetzt plötzlich. Eben hat sie noch das Bild da aufgetan von den Landarbeitern.
Es ist grandios. Also es ist grandioser Bullshit, sagen wir uns mal so. Es ist wirklich unglaublich, was wir uns da anhören müssen. Sie weiß nicht, wovon sie spricht, weil das ist alles nur Fata Morgana. Sie wünscht sich das und träumt davon.
Und das finde ich auch, weil wir das ja jetzt schon öfters hier haben. Und wir könnten jetzt, wenn wir uns die Verkehrspolitik ansehen, ähnliche Bullshit-Clips von Scheuer ansehen. Das ist auch immer das, was ich dann doch auch ein bisschen mal auch in Merkels Schuhe schieben möchte. Denn es gibt so auch so einen linksliberalen Konsens, gerade bei Twitter, der dann immer sobald Angela Merkel irgendwie mal einen R-Wert erklärt oder irgendwas mal zwei multipliziert, sagt man gleich toll, eine Wissenschaftlerin, wunderbar. Und man denkt, ja, also wenn sie das nicht könnte, dann hätte sie ja nicht mal im Grundstudium gestanden. Also das ist ja löcherlich. Und da muss man sagen, na ja, wenn man solche Minister um sich scharrt, dann wirkt man natürlich geradezu genialisch. Das ist so dieser alte Fernsehtrick, wer mit den wilden Herzbuben auftritt, wirklich immer schlank. Und so ist es dann auch hier, also das sollte man aber auch mal sehen, das ist auch Merkel. Also sie hat auch dafür gesorgt, dass solche Leute da sind. Ich kann es alleine, aber sie hat auch schon entscheidend dazu beigetragen.
So, wie sieht der Status Quo jetzt aus, wo wir freudig erwartend die geile Technik bald bekommen. Und es ja sowieso alles kein Problem ist mit dem Lobbyismus. Also der Status Quo ist wie folgt, es gilt weiterhin, was in der SWR2-Doku zum einen über den deutschen oder den europäischen Export gesagt wurde von Agrarmitteln.
Jahr für Jahr steigen die Produktionszahlen. Deutschland ist weltweit zum drittgrößten Exporteur von Lebensmitteln geworden.
Und wir können heute diese, wie soll man sagen, Verzweiflung nochmal teilen. Da sitzen ja immer Menschen zusammen und machen dann so einen Film. Und die verstehen ja auch das Problem, was sie da behandeln. Und sie wissen auch, warum daraus nichts wird. Dass es allerdings so weit getrieben wird, dass die Journalisten sich selbst nochmal dabei filmen, wie sie verzweifelt ihren Film, während sie ihn produzieren, reflektieren. Das sieht man dann selten. Also das ist ja ein ganz besonderer ARD-Fernsehmoment, den wir hier sehen.
Wir haben einen gesellschaftlichen Wandel. Die Akzeptanz zum Beispiel der Massentierhaltung ist nicht mehr da und trotzdem verändert sich nichts.
Das heißt, es hat sich ein System aufgebaut, das ist starr. Und es ermöglicht keine Alternativen.
Das ist die Schwierigkeit.
Das sind jetzt die Filmemacher, die das diskutieren.
Die sagen sich hier noch mal, mit mir dabei sind.
Das erinnert mich an einen Film, den ich gerade gesehen habe von Kam Lussmann, Ökonomia, der im Kino lief. Man ihn da wohl kaum sehen konnte, pandemiebedingt. Ich hoffe, dass er sehr bald im Fernsehen zu sehen ist. Und der handelt von den Finanzmärkten. Und warum müssen die denn eigentlich in dieser Weise Wachstum generieren? Und was ist denn da eigentlich mit dieser Geldpolitik? Warum müssen wir uns immer weiter verschulden? Und das ist ein so analytischer Film, der aber dann auch diese Idee hat. Gut, ich kann jetzt die Experten zu Wort kommen lassen. Die äußern sich doch sehr eigenartig dazu. Und dann setzt man aber noch mal Leute so außerhalb dessen zusammen und reflektiert darüber, was da so eigentlich vorgeht. Und wir sehen die Regisseurin bei der Recherche, also die hört immer Statements und fügt sie dann auf ihrem Desktop zusammen und macht sich dann da ein Bild. Und wir sehen selbst ihre Rechercheleistung. Und wir sehen auch, wie sie das Ganze durchdenkt und dann zu gewissen Schlüssen kommt. Das ist wahrscheinlich, wenn man in solchen verfahrenen und komplexen, aber zugleich auch ganz heillosen Situationen recherchiert, wahrscheinlich die einzige Möglichkeit, um da noch rauszukommen und auch um den Zuschauern noch mal auf einer anderen Ebene eine Reflexion zu ermöglichen, die sagt, na, es müsste eigentlich nicht ausweglos sein, wenn man denn zum Beispiel vernünftig Politik betreibt.
Ja, also dass sie diesen Kniff gewählt haben als filmische Methode, finde ich auch wirklich, das sagt einiges aus. Aber guckt euch die ganze Reportage mal an, das ist wirklich gruselig. Nachrichtlich, jetzt Oktober, es fand ja keine große Berichterstattung statt. Ja, es war halt wie es ist und die Pressekonferenz fand statt. Zusammen geschnurzelt, ja, was fand jetzt 2020 unter allen Klimabedenken und so weiter statt. Das ist halt das Ergebnis von dieser gemeinsamen Agrarpolitik 2020.
Das Agrarbudget ist der größte Posten im EU-Haushalt. Es geht um etwa 58 Milliarden Euro jährlich. Etwa 40, 6 Milliarden davon sind Direktzahlungen, geknüpft einzig an die Betriebsgröße. Etwa 17, 4 Milliarden sind für Klimaschutz, Umweltschutz und Tierwohl vorgesehen. Neu ist jetzt, ab spätestens 2025, sollen circa 8, 1 Milliarden der Direktzahlungen an klimafreundliche Maßnahmen geknüpft werden.
Ja, also 8, 1 von 40 Milliarden. Es geht jetzt um 20 Prozent. Aber die Kriterien dafür müssen erst noch entwickelt werden. Wir wissen, wer die entwickelt, nämlich die Agrarschüsse und so. Und das ist alles verloren. Also wir haben uns wirklich mit komplett verlorener Politik zu tun. Und wir spiegeln uns gleich nochmal mit dem eigentlichen Ansinn, über das wir ja auch schon sprachen, nämlich European Green Deal und so weiter. Da hat die EU-Kommission da nicht was ganz anderes vorgehabt. Und bevor wir das machen, eigentlich ist sowas mehr so Fernsehpodcast, aber Markus Preiß, der ARD-Brüssel-Korrespondent, hat das wirklich auf den Punkt kommentiert in einer Minute. Also wirklich grandios.
Die EU ist gefangen in ihren internen Zwingen. Ein großer Dinosaurier, der sich oft wegen seiner eigenen Fesseln kaum noch bewegen kann. Gewaltige Ziele werden von der EU-Kommission regelmäßig ausgegeben. Große Erwartungen geweckt unter Mondlandung macht man es häufig gar nicht mehr. Und dann kreist der Berg und gebiert eine Maus. Das war heute bei der Agrarreform so, das ist bei der Verteidigung der Rechtsstaatlichkeit in der EU so. Und das wird wohl auch so sein, wenn Ursula von der Leyen versucht durchzusetzen. Dass bei der nächsten Europawahl aber wirklich nur jemand Chef der EU-Kommission wird, der auch zur Wahl stand. Natürlich werden Brüsseler Diplomaten jetzt widersprechen, werden erklären, wie kompliziert alles ist und dass die Kompromisse doch große Erfolge sein. Als jemand, der das täglich aus der Nähe beobachtet, kann ich diese Haltung sogar verstehen. Aber nicht als Bürger, der sich Sorgen macht, ob die EU noch die Kraft hat, sich selbst zu verändern. Für eine Welt, die das um uns herum in rasender Geschwindigkeit tut.
Ja, also so toll die EU-Kommission auch irgendwas vorschlägt. Und umso wichtig, alle immer sagen, Europa, Europa, Europa. Die Hälfte oder wie auch immer groß dieser Anteil ist, dessen, was die Europäische Union finanziell tatsächlich steuert, also über Finanzierung steuert politisch, ist dieser Agrarbereich. Und da hat sie jetzt eine richtige Bauchlandung, was alle Probleme außer die Profitinteressen der Agrarindustrie angeht, hingelegt. Da muss man einfach sagen, also 2020 dieses Ding in diesen Klimazeiten und so, das ist einfach nicht zu verantworten. Markus Preiß schöpft so einen Kommentar natürlich aus allem, was er da mitbekommen hat vor Ort, was wir nicht mitbekommen. Deswegen gucken wir zumindest noch mal ein bisschen jetzt aus Schnittsweise in diese Regierungspressekonferenz oder Bundespressekonferenz zum Thema Brüssel von Klöckner darein, weil das ist wirklich schlimm. Hier zum Beispiel nennt sie mal so eine Zahl, die so einfädelt, von der sie uns glauben machen lassen möchte, dass es jetzt eine Megadimension hat.
Viele der Mitgliedstaaten, auch die kleinen, haben die Sorge, dass durch diesen Systemwechsel Anrechnung, das heißt für Deutschland zum Beispiel 20 Prozent, wir werden eine Milliarde Euro in Öko-Regelung mehr rein geben. Sie wissen, wir haben rund, ich würde jetzt mal sagen, 1, 8 Milliarden Euro, wenn wir uns die zweite Säule anschauen und die erste Säule anschauen, allein nur für Öko-Regelungen. Und viele der Mitgliedstaaten, also in Deutschland wird es eine Milliarde mehr Euro investiert werden für Nachhaltigkeit, für ökologische Regelungen.
Sie verkauft uns hier eine Milliarde.
Ja, sie sagt ganz oft eine Milliarde, damit dann Oma Erna zu Hause sitzt und denkt, wir haben noch so viel Geld.
Man muss sich wirklich mal, Apple ist das größte Unternehmen der Welt. Zwei Billionen Marktkapitalisierung. Und zwar, weil Leute irgendwann mal bereit sind, in so einem Jahr oder vielleicht mal alle zwei Jahre 1.000 Euro für ein Telefon auszugeben. Diese 1.000 Euro sind ein Witz gegen das, was wir für Nahrungsmittel ausgeben. Also wir haben hier einen so viel höher dimensionierten, wir sprechen hier von der größten Industrie der Welt. Das ist nicht Öl, das ist auch nicht Tech, sondern das ist, was wir essen. Und sie möchte uns jetzt 1 Milliarde, die man jetzt vielleicht so ein bisschen auch, die Kriterien werden erst noch geklärt vom deutschen Agrarausschuss, den wir gerade kennengelernt haben, 1 Milliarde, wird vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen Richtung, könnte auch was mit Klima zu tun haben, hingebogen. Das ist einfach blamabel. Nächster Ausschnitt, das ist wirklich, also grandios.
Ich meine, man muss auch Mehrheiten akzeptieren. Ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwann außer Kraft gesetzt werden soll, Mehrheiten in Europa zu akzeptieren.
Welche Mehrheiten? Dass die Mehrheit des Agrarausschusses aus Industrie besteht?
Auch das gehört ja dazu, mein ich. Also man kann ja nicht so tun, als hätten wir irgendwas gegen andere Überzeugungen durchgeträumt. Der europäische Geist, der hat es geschafft, einen Kompromiss hinzubekommen. Und ich glaube, Kompromiss ist nicht Schwäche, sondern Kompromiss zeigt eine Stärke, dass man gemeinsam vorankommen will und nicht zurückfallen will in Nationalismen.
Das ist so übel, wirklich.
Ne, und Deutschland hat ja gar keine, also hat sich da wieder ganz zurückgenommen.
Das europäische Geist, der sich hier durchgesetzt hat. Und die demokratische Mehrheit. Wer will was gegen den europäischen Geist und die demokratischen Mehrheit sagen? Es ist unglaublich. Sie reagiert ja mal auf Kritik. Ist zwar coronabedingt fast niemand da in der Bundespressekonferenz, aber kritische Stimmen gab es wohl doch.
Man könnte jetzt viele Stimmen zitieren, die sich, ich kann Ihnen jetzt auch ein paar andere Stimmen noch nennen, die sich zur Agrarpolitik jetzt geäußert haben, denen das viel zu weit geht.
Und was ist jetzt mit dem Höfesterben? Also ich verschwendet Sie noch einen Gedanken an die Produzenten dessen, was dann in Fleischerei, Milliardenindustrien und Schlachthöfen und Molkereien so passiert?
Sie kennen ja sicher die Zahlen. Das hat seit 2005 30 Prozent der bäuerlichen Betriebe in der EU zugesperrt haben. Es gibt auch Analysen aus Ihrem eigenen Haus, die darauf hindeuten, dass die Flächenprämien eine der Ursachen sind, weil vor allem natürlich Kleinbauern darunter leiden. Können Sie mir noch mal erklären, was haben Sie jetzt genau an diesen Flächenprämien geändert, damit dieses Höfesterben, das mit sehr, sehr viel europäischem Geld anscheinend unterstützt wird, damit das Höfesterben endet?
Das müssen wir, glaube ich, auch zu Beginn, wenn wir das analysieren, auch ehrlich sein über die Vielfältigkeit, warum Höfe nicht weitergeführt werden.
Ja, es hat ganz vielfältige Gründe.
Da hat sie ja wissen, vermutlich auch das Bauersuchtfrau.
Ja, es ist wirklich schlimm. Hier hat sie allerdings einen sehr schönen Versprecher gehabt. Das ist wirklich, selbst wenn man im Lobby und so, keine Ahnung, aber dieser Versprecher, den wir jetzt hören, der ist gar nicht ausreichend.
Ich kann es nachvollziehen, dass Sie gerne jetzt ganz konkret was gewusst hätten für Deutschland. Wir haben jetzt erstmal einen Etappensieg, oder ein Etappenziel erreicht.
Ja, es ist ein Etappensieg, nee, es ist ein ganz großer Sieg. Ihr habt den Krieg gegen das Klima gewonnen und gegen uns Europäer als Bürger. Wir hören in den letzten Clip von ihr, da geht es 37 Sekunden. Alle, die verstehen, was sie sagt, oder die glauben, dass sie selber weiß, wovon sie redet. Können wir mal kurz einen Hinweis schicken, hinsichtlich, was wollte sie uns eigentlich sagen?
Es ist ein weiteres, haben wir beschlossen, dass der Artikel 17 Risikomanagement, ein Mitgliedstaat kann bis zu einem Prozent der Direktzahlungen einbehalten, das heißt nicht direkt auszahlen zu den Landwirten, wenn der Landwirt, also wenn der begünstigte Risikomanagement betreibt. Also eine Risikoversicherung nachweist zum Beispiel. Oder Investitionen in Jungland fertig. Ich glaube, das muss ich auch nicht weiter vertiefen. Dann glaube ich, weil sie ja auch Nachfragen stellen wollen, glaube ich, sind das Hauptpunkte.
Sag mal, war die überhaupt dabei?
Ich glaube, das ist die schlechteste Pressekonferenz, die jemals ein Politiker aus dem deutschen Kabinett gegeben hat. Naja, zwei kleine Clips zum Finale. Zum einen, ja, die Europäische Union hatte doch eigentlich irgendwas vor.
Immer mehr Pflanzen und Tierarten gehen dem Planeten verloren, auch in Europa. Deshalb will die EU nun gegensteuern, mit einer Biodiversitätsstrategie. Heute stellten sich die Mitgliedstaaten hinter das Vorhaben. Es sieht weniger Pestizide und Gülle vor und mehr Naturschutzgebiete. 30% der europäischen Land- und Meeresfläche sollen bis 2030 unter Schutz stehen, ein Drittel davon unter Strängern.
Also die EU-Kommission mag mächtig sein als Organ, aber sie kann unmöglich es ernst meinen, in der Woche, in der die gemeinsame Agrarpolitik dieses Resultat hingelegt hat, und zwar Budget umfassend 350 Milliarden Euro, dann ein Ziel ausgeben. Und bis 2030 wollen wir im Übrigen die Pestizide um 30% runter haben, und die Hälfte Fläche soll Naturschutzgebiet sein. Das passt nicht zusammen. Und deswegen, und es ist jetzt keine Werbung für die Grünen Partei, auch wenn ich jetzt wirklich sehr viele Sympathien langsam gewinne, aber Robert Habeck am 19.10. vor 10 Tagen, hinsichtlich, die machen einmal in der Woche so interne und dann Pressekonferenz, und wie er sich hier als letztes Thema in seinem Eingangsstatement noch mal zweieinhalb Minuten lang zur gemeinsamen europäischen Agrarpolitik geäußert hat, ist einfach grandios. Und weil jetzt vielleicht bisher auch alle dachten, oh nee, das ist wieder Politik, Lobby und so weiter, da kann man nichts machen. Nein, es wäre möglich, eine konstruktive Wende hinzubekommen, wenn man nur Wahlstimmen in dieser Rentenrepublik anders verteilt. Also das Statement hier von Robert Habeck hat mich überzeugt.
Heute tagt der EU-Agrarministerinnenrat unter dem Vorsitz von Frau Klöckner, so wie eben alle Räte im Moment deutschen Vorsitz haben.
Ja, das ist natürlich auch so eine Sonderpoente, zu deiner Frage, war sie überhaupt dabei? Ja, sie hat diese Sitzung geleitet. Deutschland ist ja gerade Ratspräsident.
Das ist eine wichtige Tagung für das Thema Klimaschutz, aber damit verbindet sich auch die Einkommensperspektive für Landwirtinnen und Landwirte und gleichzeitig die Ökologisierung der Landwirtschaft. Und die Zeichen, die wir bekommen, die wir aus Brüssel einordnen, die wir von der deutschen Ratspräsidentschaft bekommen, sind nicht vielversprechend. Die Europäische Kommission hat den Green Deal verabschiedet und beschlossen. Also ein Programm, ein umfängliches Programm zum Klimaschutz. In diesem Green Deal gibt es zwei Strategiepapiere, die Biodiversitätsstrategie und die sogenannte Farm-to-Fork-Strategie, die sehr ambitionierte Vorgaben gemacht hat, Biodiversität, Ökologisierung der Landwirtschaft verbindlich zu erreichen. Beispielsweise soll die Pestizidmenge bis 2030 um 50 Prozent reduziert werden, der ökologische Landbau auf 25 Prozent erhöht werden, 30 Prozent der europäischen Fläche sollen unter Naturschutz gestellt werden, 10 Prozent davon unter streng geschützte Auflagen, also wirklich Naturschutzgebiete. All diese Vorgaben müssten sich wiederfinden in dem Hauptinstrument in der Landwirtschaftspolitik der sogenannten GAP, der gemeinsamen Agrarpolitik, und das tun sie nicht. Insofern ist das, was die Länder dort gerade verhandeln, unzureichend und genügt nicht dem, was die Kommission vorgeschlagen hat. Unzureichend ist allerdings auch der Kommissionsvorschlag selbst. Wir erwarten von der deutschen Ratspräsidentschaft im Agrarbereich, dass sie vorangeht, dass sie die Ökologisierung vorantreibt, und zwar entlang der Ziele, die Europa sich mit dem Green Deal gegeben hat. Die Notwendigkeit zu agieren ist dringlich, weil die Landwirtinnen und Landwirte wissen müssen, wie die Gelder in Zukunft verwendet werden. Ein weiter so rumlavierend jedem ein bisschen was geben sorgt dafür, dass die Unruhe an den Höfen immer größer wird und die Spaltung der Gesellschaft, die Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher, die Umweltschützer auf der einen Seite, die eine andere Landwirtschaft wollen, und die Landwirte, die sich an die Regeln halten müssen, aber die Regeln sie quasi animieren, immer stärker zu industrialisieren und immer weiter zu wachsen oder eben pleite zu gehen, nicht mehr zusammenpassen. Also eine moderne Landwirtschaftspolitik ist eine Politik, die Umwelt- und Klimaschutz verbindet mit der Produktion. Das erkennen wir im Moment nicht, ist, dass das Frau Klöckner verhandeln will, soweit von meiner Seite.
Ja, da könnte Frau Klöckner auch lernen, dass man durchaus zwei, drei Nebensätze bilden kann, wenn sie denn am Ende zu einem Ziel führen. Ja, das gebietet wird von einem Punkt. Und das kann Habeck und ich würde sagen ja, mit Rot-Rot-Grün wäre da sicherlich vieles denkbar, mit Schwarz-Grün.
Ich würde sagen, mit den Grünen in der Regierung, das wäre mal wieder ein Versuch wert, sagen wir es so.
Du bist ja ein hoffnungslose Optimist.
Und ich finde es sehr gut, dass er hier nochmal darauf hinweist.
Du bist der Ältere, du müsstest eigentlich doch noch mehr Horizont überblicken und wissen Nein, nein, nein.
Also meine Losung ist, wir können es auf den Versuch anlegen lassen. Und ich finde es sehr gut, dass ein Politiker jetzt einfach mal auch sagt, ich weiß, dass wir parlamentarisch in den Federführungen und in den Zuteilungen irgendwie trennen zwischen Klimapolitik findet hier statt, von Montag 18 bis 19 Uhr und Agrarpolitik ist Mittwoch 17 Uhr. Aber es ist tatsächlich in der Realität ein Thema. Und das kann man auch nicht auseinander zerren, nur weil ein Lobbyausschuss irgendwas hinbekommt, was den anderen dann davon abschirmen. Sondern das muss man integrieren und schon dieser Hinweis, den finde ich sehr gut von Robert Habeck. Naja, ich glaube auch, dass schwarz-grün besser ist als schwarz nicht grün.
Wir gehen in die Unterhaltungsbranche, würde ich sagen. Da ist viel passiert und das ist auch eine kleine Lockerungsübung vielleicht nach so schweren Brocken, Agrarpolitik, Drohnen, die angeschafft werden sollen. Wenden wir uns doch dem Wendler zu. Es kommt dir nur noch ganz selten vor, dass ich wirklich vor dem Fernseher sitze, um dort mir etwas im Fernsehen anzusehen. Wenn ich vor dem Fernseher sitze, dann ist das in der Regel nur deshalb, weil ich mir eine DVD oder eine Blu-ray reingeworfen habe, dann sitze ich natürlich noch vor dem Fernseher, aber sonst gucken wir ja alle in Mediatheken und ohnehin ist für mich das Privatfernsehen, wenn nicht gerade das Dschungelcamp kommt, dass ich ja eher aus soziologischem Interesse, so rechtfertige ich es, vor mir zumindest gucke. Genau, warum ja auch viele Leute noch den Playboy kaufen, immer wegen der Interviews, aber es ist selten, dass ich noch mal was mir im Fernsehen ansehe und dass es auch noch mal so einen Moment im Fernsehen gibt, dass ich denke, okay, das will ich jetzt auch auf dem Fernsehen sehen, das will ich auch jetzt genauso haben, wie das alle Menschen jetzt gerade, die den Sender eingeschaltet haben, erleben. Und das war ein Moment, ich glaube, es war an einem Donnerstagabend im Oktober. Ich saß am PC, war gerade einen Artikel am Schreiben und man geht ja dann hin und wieder mal um sich zu zerstreuen auf Twitter und dann sah ich Wendler in den Schlagzeilen bzw. in den Trends. Was ist da los? Wendler schließt sich den Verschwörungstheoretikern an. Es gab dann dieses merkwürdige Statement, das da kursierte und eigentlich war es ja so, dass dann auf RTL um 23.15 Uhr die Sendung von Oliver Pocher und seiner Frau laufen sollte. Und da sollte auch eigentlich, glaube ich, sogar der Wendler zugeschaltet sein wegen irgendwas, weil er ja bei DSDS in der Jury sitzt und auch einige andere RTL-Produktionen macht. Und dann wurde aber schon verkündet, dass diese Pocher-Sendung vorverlegt wird, dass der Wendler nicht dort sein wird, dass man aber das Wendler-Thema dort aufgreift. Und erst einmal war der Twitter-Reflex bei einigen doch da zu sagen, ach, das ist bestimmt so ein Riesen-Prank, das ist fake. Da hat Olli Pocher sich irgendwas Lustiges ausgedacht, um die Corona-Leugner jetzt mal wieder gegen sich aufzubringen. Denn tatsächlich hatte es ein bisschen den Anschein, wir hören jetzt mal einen Zusammenschnitt von diesem Wendler-Statement, das auf Instagram zu erleben war.
Bevor wir das machen, du hast jetzt beschrieben, wie gefesselt du warst. Ich weiß noch von wenig, also ich kenne so ein bisschen, aber ich weiß nichts von dem, was wir jetzt gucken. Du hast mich allerdings schon darauf hingewiesen, dass du das guckst und ich habe dann erst überlegt, gucke ich es auch noch mal vorher oder nicht, lass mich überraschen. Ich wollte nur eben darauf hinweisen, dass wir jetzt alle überprüfen, wie weit das Niveau jetzt auch insgesamt sinkt, denn du hast tatsächlich eben den Satz gesagt, du saßt am Schreibtisch und warst einen Artikel am Schreiben und hier scheint sich schon die eine oder andere Wendler-Kopfduseligkeit bei dir reingeschlichen zu haben, denn so redet man nicht, Wolfgang. Ich war ein Artikel am Schreiben.
Ich schrieb einen Artikel.
Also ich bin gespannt, wir hören jetzt hier rein.
Good morning in the morning, ich bin Micha Wendler und für alle, die mich nicht kennen, ich bin Komponist und Texte, habe hunderte von Werken geschrieben und seit über 20 Jahren in der Musik- und TV-Branche. Aktuell bin ich Juror in der RTL-Show DSDS und ich möchte jetzt und hier eine Mitteilung bekannt geben. Ich werde mit sofortiger Wirkung an der Teilnahme der DSDS-Show als Juror ausscheiden. Ich werfe der Bundesregierung bezüglich der angeblichen Corona-Pandemie und deren resultierenden Maßnahmen grobe und schwere Verstöße gegen die Verfassung und das Grundgesetz vor.
Die Verfassung und das Grundgesetz, beide, ja? Das ist ja krass.
Und er las diesen Text ab, muss man dazu sagen.
Alle Fernsehänder, inklusive RTL, machen sich mitschuldig, sind gleichgeschaltet politisch gesteuert. Ladet euch so schnell wie möglich Telegram oder Telegram ist die einzige Möglichkeit, zensurfrei Meinungen auszutauschen. Alle anderen Portale wie Instagram, YouTube oder Facebook sind zensiert.
Es ist grandios, alle, die auf Twitter teilnehmen, wissen, Telegram ist eigentlich so eine Schifre. Man macht sich so drüber lustig, das ist so dieses, ja ja, jetzt auch Telegram und so. Und dass er mit aller Ernsthaftigkeit hier nochmal Telegram bewirbt, das ist wirklich so grandios neben der Spur, das ist unglaublich.
Und ich dachte auch, als ich es sah, das wird jetzt so eine ganz lustige, lustig sein sollende Aktion von Olli Pocher sein. Und ich dachte schon, oh Gott, das wird eher ins Gegenteil umschlagen. Viele werden dann aus dem Corona-Leugner-Lager sehen, na ja, jetzt werden wir wieder einmal veralbert. Also, na ja, ich dachte, ich komme nicht umhin. Ich muss vor das Fernsehgerät schaltete den Apparat an, saß dann dort. Und sehr, sehr schnell sagte dann Olli Pocher auch, dass es hier sich keineswegs um einen Prank handelt. Sie sind selber vollkommen überrascht davon, was hier passiert. RTL hat sehr schnell reagiert, hat die Sendezeit dieser Pochersendung ausgeweitet. Und monothematisch ging es dann nur um den Wendler. Eigentlich sollte Dieter Bohlen auch noch zugeschaltet werden. Die kappeln sich ja ein bisschen in der DSDS-Jury. Da war schon einiges zu hören. Dann wurde nachher, also es war eine absolut abstruse Sendung, noch Matze Knob eingeschaltet, der eine Dieter Bohlen-Imitation gegeben hat. Es ging eigentlich nicht zusammen. Aber man machte sehr schnell den Ernst der Lage klar und machte auch deutlich, dass man sehr überrascht ist von diesen Entwicklungen, die zumindest RTL so nicht hat kommen sehen. Ein bisschen anders ist es bei dem Manager vom Wendler, der ins Studio geeilt ist, um sicherlich auch zu sagen, dass er nichts damit zu tun hat. Wir hören uns dieses Wendler Manager Statement von dieser Abend-Sendung einmal an.
Und das lief alles wirklich gut. Und ich habe aber so seit drei Wochen gemerkt, auch am Anfang bei DSDS, oder wir haben einen großen Deal ja bis eben gehabt mit Kaufland. Die haben natürlich jetzt alles gesperrt und alle Partner, ich habe jetzt in den letzten zwei Stunden, glaube ich, ungefähr 15 Anwälte am Apparat gehabt, bundesweit. Auch RTL-Anwälte natürlich, die alle Verträge sofort auflösen werden und die Karriere von Michael Wendler beenden mit sofortiger Wirkung. Und es ist so gewesen, dass vor drei Wochen mir das aufgefallen ist, dass er immer krasser in seinen Aussagen wurde, was so Corona angeht. Wir waren bei dem Drehverkaufler und dann hat er das Team immer aufgefordert, zieh die Masken ab.
Das ist alles Mumppel, da ist nichts dran.
Habe ich ein paar Mal erinnert, ich sag einmal, hier ist ein großes Team, hör auf mit diesem, das ist doch normal, alle müssen Masken tragen und so. Nein, dieses ganze Corona ist eine riesen Lüge.
Wenn du das auch glaubst und so, dann bist du genauso krank und so.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, hör mal, irgendwas stimmt ja nicht. Und das wurde immer abstruser, also auch die Aussagen. Und ich habe dann angedacht, dass es vielleicht mal sinnvoll wäre. Deswegen ist das auch, man lacht bei dem Thema Michael Wendler, das ist auch immer lustig oder Spaß oder so. Im Moment ist es so, dass ich ganz klar sagen muss, für mich ist er krank. Also tatsächlich krank. Er hat mich angerufen, eben als er dieses Ding hochgeladen hat. Ich war auf der Autobahn und es hört sich für mich so an, wie so ein Anruf von jemand, der zum letzten Mal jemand anruft und sagt, pass auf, ich beende jetzt meine Karriere, ich komme nie wieder nach Deutschland. Wir werden alle sterben, ich will als Held sterben.
Du, wenn du siehst, dass du nach Amerika kommst, vielleicht hast du dann noch eine Chance.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, was ist denn los und so.
Ich werde jetzt das hochposten.
Also das hat schon erhebliches erzählerisches Potenzial, gerade für so ein RTL und so.
Du kannst dir vorstellen, wie gebannt ich da saß und mich aber zugleich dabei beobachtete und dachte, was mache ich hier eigentlich? Ich war eigentlich in diesem Dschungelcamp-Modus und freute mich so sehr daran, dass nochmal das Eintritt, was selbst beim Dschungelcamp der vergangenen drei, vier Jahre nicht mehr passierte, etwas Ereignis Haftes, denn es war ja beim Dschungelcamp in den vergangenen Jahren nur noch darauf ausgelegt, dass man Menschen, die ohnehin Reality-TV-Erfahrung hatte, jetzt nochmal zusammen in den Dschungel stopfte und guckte, ob die sich ein bisschen kappelten, was aber wenig überraschend war. Interessant war ja am Dschungelcamp, wenn Menschen mit einer gewissen Fallhöhe dort reinkamen, ein Mathieu Carrier, der immerhin mal eine europaweite Karriere als Leinwandstar hatte, der nun sich mit diesen Leuten dort rumschlagen muss. Das hatte etwas gehabt und das war etwas, was Roger Wilhelmsen einmal sehr schön auf den Punkt brachte mit der Überschrift, Huch, es lebt. Da gab es einen schönen Artikel von ihm in der Süddeutschen Zeitung über das Dschungelcamp und was er eigentlich daran liebt, nämlich, dass noch mal im Fernsehen etwas stattfindet, was es viel zu selten gibt, nämlich irgendeinen Moment des Zufalls, irgendeine Plötzlichkeit, die dort auftritt, etwas, das davon zeugt, dass dort noch lebendige Menschen am Werke sind. Denn wenn man sich sonst die Unterhaltungsformate ansieht, dann ist das alles so sehr schon auf Gleise gebracht, die immer gleichförmig verlaufen, dass man gar nicht mehr von irgendetwas überrascht sein kann. Man muss sich nun mal so eine Helene Fischer Show oder auch die Florian Silbereisen Show ansehen. Das ist etwas, das läuft wie im Prinzip eine automatisierte Waffe, ja, geht drei Stunden und irgendwann ist es dann vorbei. Und hier passiert aber wirklich noch mal was und zugleich aber sind wir in so einer Sensationslüsternheit, okay? Der Wendler, da haben wir jetzt eh schon so viel gehört, da gibt es so viele verrückte Geschichten zu. Eigentlich nur ein Schlagersänger, der auch nur einen richtigen Hit hatte, nämlich sie liebt den DJ und dann so eine merkwürdige Reality-TV-Figur wurde, ja auch im Dschungelcamp war und dann von diesem Manager, der dort spricht, aber noch mal nach oben katapultiert wurde. Es gibt also einen RTL-Esgab, einen RTL-Exklusivvertrag, der bis Ende 2021 gelaufen wäre, der beinhaltete nicht nur die Mitgliedschaft bei der DSDS-Jury, sondern auch weitere Reality-Formate, eine eigene Musiksendung im Frühjahr plus Werbeverträge unter anderem mit Kaufland. Wir hier hängen Millionen dran und der Wendler ist ja in großen Schulden. Er hätte sich damit sanieren können und auch weit darüber hinaus retten können und er gibt das alles auf. In gewisser Weise, nicht jetzt falsch verstehen, aber in gewisser Weise ist das fast eine idealistische Haltung, die er da annimmt. Also er ist natürlich vollkommen irre, das zu tun und jetzt diesen Unsinn zu glauben. Aber man muss sich einmal vorstellen, für welche Position wäre unser eins bereit zu sagen, ja, ist mir egal, dann verzichte ich auf alle Einnahmen, dann gucke ich, wo ich bleibe, aber es ist mir so wichtig, die EU-Agrarpolitik, dass die ökologisch wird, ist mir so wichtig, dass ich auf alles verzichte und zur Not ins Exil gehe.
Ich habe mich immer noch gefragt, weiß er, was er tut, weil so eine Story aufzunehmen, das ist ja schnell gemacht und damit kann man ja mehr zerstören, als man glaubt so. Aber der Manager hat ja auch noch mal bestätigt, vorher diesen Anruf bekommen zu haben. Und der Wendler scheint sich ja dann doch, man sagt immer so, der Wendler, also Wendler, scheint sich ja dann doch, Michael Wendler, Michael Wendler, scheint sich ja dann doch sehr im Klaren darüber gewesen zu sein, was er da tut. Und in deren Sicht ist so dieses, er ist krank, ja gut, das kann man dann so schnell dahin sagen, aber er scheint ja doch sehr klar, also sehr idealistisch klar, nicht fanatisch, sag mal so, an der Sache beteiligt gewesen zu sein.
Der Manager hat diese Diagnose krank auch noch mal relativiert dann eine Woche später und sagte ja so sei das eigentlich nicht gemeint gewesen. Dieser Manager ist auch extrem fahrig dort. Er hat dann auch Tränen in den Augen, nicht nur weil für ihn das ein wichtiges Geschäft war, sondern auch weil es wohl doch eine fast freundschaftliche Verbindung gab. Wir hören mal weiter, was der Manager sagt. Wegen dem, was da auch menschlich dahintersteht.
Ja, das ist natürlich eine menschliche Tragödie, kann man schon sagen. Und er hat mir dann erzählt, er hat mit Attila Heldmann telefoniert die ganze Nacht.
Und mit diesen ganzen Namen, ich kenne diese Leute nicht.
Ich war noch nie auf Telegram, er hat mir immer gesagt, lad das runter, mach das.
Dann habe ich gesagt, hör auf. Und bei DSDS, und das war, er hat mir vor, bei seinem letzten Tag, wir waren ja auf dem Schiff, DSDS, zum Drehen, da hat er mir an der Rehling gesagt, ja, pass auf, ich glaube, das ist das letzte Mal, dass ich hier bin.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, wie, bist du behämmert, warum?
Also nein, das mache ich nicht mehr mit, wir werden eh alle, du kriegst das alles nicht mit, was mit der Regierung um uns herum passiert.
Und ich habe gesagt, wir müssen vielleicht mal hier einen Psychologen dazu ziehen, also keine Ahnung, nein, du bist ja, bist du behämmert?
Ich bin doch ganz normal, ich sehe das klar, ihr seht das alle falsch. Und dann ist er ja vor fünf Tagen, ich habe das ja der Presse alles so ein bisschen verschwiegen, der ist ja bei Nacht und Nebel einfach abgehauen nach Amerika mit Laura. Und ich wusste es nicht. Ich habe im Hotel angerufen, wir wollen ein paar Sachen, oder Mitarbeiter wollen ein paar Sachen abholen und die sagten, ja sie sind ja Management, sie müssen wissen, der ist heute Nacht abgereiht. Also ich überlege, da ist doch jetzt auch viel heuristisches Potenzial drin, oder? Im Sinne von, ja man liest so Fake-Facts, aber kann sich doch nicht vorstellen, wie fanatisch die Leute sind, aber hier kriegen wir das so, ist ja weird.
Wir hören noch einmal den Manager zum Schluss.
Eine Stunde vor Abflug hat er mich dann eben angerufen und hat gesagt, pack deine Sachen, komm schnell hier hin, wenn du überleben willst. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ich entnehme deinen Wort und dass du jetzt nicht fliegen willst. Ach, wer redet von Fliegen? Ich werde nie wieder nach Deutschland kommen. Das wird Deutschland wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr geben, nächstes Jahr und so. Also das ist schon, das ist ein komplett anderer Mensch gewesen.
Ein komplett anderer Mensch gewesen, mit Attila Hildmann telefoniert. Jetzt muss man sich das ja erst einmal so vorstellen, dass der Wendler oder dass solche Leute aus der Showbranche, und darum geht es mir eigentlich, nicht Menschen sind, die in einem sozialen Gefüge sind, dass das einhegt, diese Verrücktheiten, diesen Fanatismus oder auch diese Positionen relativiert. Und das ist, glaube ich, ein Mensch, der sehr abgekapselt lebt, der noch Kontakte zu diesem Manager hat, der seine sehr junge Frau Laura hat, die, glaube ich, gar nicht so recht weiß, wie ihr da geschieht. So lassen zumindest ihre Statements vermuten. Und sonst ist er mit sich und dann vielleicht wirklich mit der Telegram-Gruppe und irgendwelchen Leuten wie Attila Hildmann ziemlich allein gelassen und bewegt sich nicht in einem Gefüge, in dem man vielleicht sehr schnell merken würde, naja, das ist alles unglaublich unvernünftig, was die da sagen. Und schon gar nicht wird man so unvernünftig sein, diesen Leuten nachzufolgen. Und wenn man sich ein bisschen in der Showbranche so auskennt, dann weiß man, es gibt da sehr viele Leute, die zwar vor großem Publikum auftreten und die ganz viel Presse haben und die ständig irgendwo sind, die aber doch sehr isoliert leben. Also das schließt sich nicht aus. Isoliert lebt nicht nur der, der da irgendwo in der Lausitz prekär lebt und dann plötzlich sich rechten YouTube-Kanälen anschließt und sagt, da mache ich jetzt auch noch mit, sondern das kann eben auch jemand sein, der eigentlich ziemlich weltgewandt ist dadurch auch, dass er ständig in anderen Ländern zu Gast ist. Das ist schon mal etwas sehr Eigenartiges, das man erst mal zusammenbringen muss. Und dann, glaube ich, gibt es eine hohe Affinität der Leute in der Unterhaltungsbranche zu solchen, ich will es erst mal nur Kuriositäten nennen, denn wir haben da ja ganz verschiedene Dinge, über die wir jetzt sprechen werden, dass man sich selbst als etwas Besonderes ansieht und dadurch auch glaubt, dann muss ich auch etwas Besonderes glauben oder einer besonderen Religion, Spiritualität oder sonst was nachgehen, denn das unterstreicht dir eigentlich meine Besonderheit. Und jemand, der das nicht tut, der aber auch in der Öffentlichkeit steht, ist Harald Schmidt. Und wir haben hier mal einen ganz kurzen Auszug aus einem Gespräch von Dreisatzstertstunden der Philosophie, wo er noch mal so deutlich macht, wie eigentlich jetzt gerade die Öffentlichkeit funktioniert und aber auch zum Beispiel, naja, Schauspielerinnen, die da eigene Wege der Trauerbewältigung finden.
Und deswegen glaube ich, dass so eine Normierung von Reaktionen, was man zu empfinden hat, ja, Geburten haben einen zu einem anderen Menschen zu machen, das Erleben von Geburten. Bei Todesfällen, zum Beispiel, als mein Vater starb, wie war das für dich? Sag ich, du, er war 90 und versuche ich dir mal ein Geheimnis zu verraten, ich habe mit ihm gesprochen, als er noch gelebt hat. Oder viele unserer Schauspielerinnen legen sich noch mal zwei Nächte ins Bett mit der toten Mutter, um Abschied zu nehmen, das muss ich nicht, weil ich lag mit meiner Mutter im Bett, als sie noch gelebt hat. Das wird alles als zynisch denunziert, aber es ist ja einfach nur. Dass man mit toter Mutti schon wieder ins Bett liegen muss. Und das ist aber in gewisser Weise, gibt es da eine Norm, die Reaktionen und Emotionen vorgibt, abrufbar.
Das ist ein ganz grandioses Gespräch, das habe ich auch noch im Ohr, weil er diese Normierungsidee ja noch weiter treibt, auch zu den allgemeinen Menschen, die davon abgehalten werden sollen, morgens im Bus plötzlich darüber nachzudenken, warum verdiene ich eigentlich nur 2000 Euro? Ich bin doch hier jeden Tag zehn Stunden und pflege die Alten. Und das wird alles eingehegt. Das ist da dieses emotionale Ausbrechen. Ich meine, er sagt jetzt so Schauspielerin, muss man sich fragen. Was heißt das eigentlich? Menschen, die irgendwie künstlerisch tätig sind, also die keinen richtigen Maßstab für den Erfolg der eigenen Arbeit kennen. Außer vielleicht so finanziell. Aber es gibt jetzt so dieses, es ist eine gute Schauspielerin, das sind nur Werturteile, die das so. Also man kann es nicht so richtig abrechnen, sucht aber trotzdem so halt irgendwie auch für sich, um so zu wissen, ja, habe ich jetzt mein Selbst entfaltet? Ja oder nein? Und wie weit? Wann?
Man schreibt ein Buch drüber und sitzt dann in der NDR Talkshow und berichtet davon und alle sind ganz betroffen, dass die Schauspielerin dann erzählt, wie das dann war mit der toten Mutti im Bett und dass man sich dann noch mal als Tochter auch ganz anders gefühlt hat oder Abschied nehmen konnte. Man kennt diese Erzählungen auch von ganz vielen Hollywood-Stars, die immer gerne solche Sachen berichten. Und das funktioniert wahnsinnig gut, weil es auch einem Publikum zu Passe kommt, das einfach nur sagen will, ja, schlimm, tot, ist jemand gestorben? Ja, ist ja auch schlimm, wenn man Angehörige verliert. Und dass damit aber auch eine Tür geöffnet wird für so merkwürdige, esoterische, ich mach da mal ja jetzt mein eigenes Weltkonzept draus, das wird dann oft nicht gesehen. Denn zunächst einmal kann man ja auch sagen, es ist ja wahnsinnig harmlos, wenn da irgendein Schauspieler sagt, ich bin dann noch mal meiner Mutter nahe gekommen, weil ich irgendwie sonst nicht mit ihr sprechen konnte. Man muss aber sagen, das hat eine extrem lange Tradition. Das hat mich ja interessiert, jetzt an diesem Fall Wendler, was alles schon so Verrücktes in der Pop-Welt gedacht wurde, in der Unterhaltungsbranche. Ich habe mich gleich erinnert an den Schauspieler Owe Fischer, ich weiß nicht, ob du den noch kennst, in den 50er- 60er-Jahren sehr berühmt, hat König Ludwig gespielt, der sich dann auch irgendwann in die Isoterik verlagert hatte, eine Weltformel irgendwie entwickeln wollte und sich zugleich wunderte, warum sein toter Kater Poldi im Garten nicht verwäßt und darüber dann auch Bücher geschrieben hat und dazu auch dann hin und wieder mal gerne interviewt wurde, weil es halt so wahnsinnig skurril war. Das heißt, die Unterhaltungsmedien sind auch sehr daran interessiert, etwas Besonderes zu bringen. Und wenn du einfach jemanden hast, der sagt, ja, ich bin halt katholisch oder ich bin evangelisch und gehe hin und wieder sonntags in die Kirche, dann wird das nicht ein spannendes Feature. Das heißt, das Besondere, das ist erst was, was man dann sich auch erarbeiten kann auf dem spirituellen Weg. Kennst du noch das Lied Lady Bump? Penny McLean, ein Disco-Star. Und sie wollte aber dann nicht ewig Disco-Star sein, sondern hat sich dann auch für einen anderen Weg entschieden. Wir hören hier mal ganz kurz rein, denn sie gibt inzwischen Seminare und da erklärt sie mal was.
Noch einmal zurück zu der Frage, warum inkarnieren wir? Also wir sollen edel sein, wir sollen hilfreich sein und wir sollen gut sein. Damit sind die drei Ansprüche, die den Weg der Erleuchtung ermöglichen. Und dazu ist unser Engel nämlich da, um uns auf den Weg der Einweihung der Erleuchtung zu bringen. Nun, diese Verbindung zwischen Schutzgeistern und Schutzengeln, die müssten wir doch irgendwie ins Bewusstsein bekommen, dass wir sie verwenden können.
Ja, man braucht, es gibt eine so große Sehnsucht nach Konzept, Konzept einfach, Konzept. Jede Idee wird zur Theorie ausgebaut, nichts wird da liegen lassen. Ich bin jetzt seit ein paar Wochen beim Yoga regelmäßig. Ich weiß, Yoga kann man auch zu Hause machen und im Grunde geht es ein bisschen um Bewegung und so. Aber das ist so halt eine Gruppenübung, bei der man dann doch mit sich alleine ist für die Zeit. Und es ist erstaunlich spirituell, so als ob es die Leute nicht aushalten. Also es stört mich nicht, das will ich ausdrücklich dazu sagen. Ich finde es ist eine angenehme Komponente, aber es erreicht mich auch null. Trotzdem kann ich es mal kurz ausführen. Es ist so ein ganz merkwürdiges, ja, man macht eine Stunde lang schon so intensivere Halteprübung, bei dem man auch mal ins Schwitzen kommt und dann schließt es halt so eine halbe Stunde Entspannung an. Und es ist fast so, als reichte es nicht, dass Menschen einfach mal zusammenkommen in eine Kirche. Nein, da muss vorne auf der Kanzelprogramm stattfinden. Und nein, man kann sich nicht einfach mal entspannt zu angenehmer Musik auf den Rücken legen. Nein, es muss natürlich die ganze Zeit so ein Text sachte mitformuliert werden, dass wir jetzt Weltfrieden einatmen und Liebe ausatmen und sowas. Und ich frage mich dann immer mal, warum ist es so dieses verdrehte, naja, nur der Anlass ist Pseudo, aber er ist auch wichtig im Sinne von er ermöglicht, aber dann ist er auch egal im Sinne von ohne die Kanzelpredigt würde man nicht hingehen, weil dann könnte man sich nicht gegenseitig erklären, ich bin ja hier wegen der Kanzelpredigt, aber eigentlich ist man nicht wirklich wegen der Predigt da. Und es ist ja beim Yoga auch so ein bisschen. Beim Yoga denke ich nur, ich bin ja wegen der Bewegung hier und die habe ich dann auch. Und von mir aus kann ich auch so einfach eine halbe Stunde mal mit geschlossenen Augen auf dem Boden liegen, ich brauche keinen Text dazu. Aber irgendwie scheint dieser Text doch nötig zu sein bei recht vielen Menschen. Und man bekommt die dann auch, wenn man danach will, also wenn man danach sucht. Wenn man in so einer haltlosen Welt, Wendler, ich kann mir das auch immer nicht so richtig vorstellen. Wir kriegen ja auch ab und zu, also wir hier nicht in diesem Podcast, aber ich habe auch schon mal Podcasts produziert, wo es negative Kommentare gab. Und die ärgern mich, die beschäftigen mich, jeder Einzelne. Und so ein Typ wie Wendler, der kriegt ja zu 99% nur negative Reaktionen. Ich meine, der hat auch seine Fans, die sitzen halt zu Hause, geruhsam, die denken sich nicht dabei.
Beziehungsweise ist er Peinlichkeitsstar. Also er hat auch ein großes Publikum, das einfach kommt, um zu sehen, wie irre ist der Wendler heute.
Und da denke ich mir auch so ein bisschen, das kann nicht einfach so an ihm vorübergehen. Auch wenn sich das finanziell trägt und so weiter. Aber das macht irgendwas mit so Leuten. Und in der Ansicht war der Wendler da besonders verletzlich, glaube ich.
Der Gegenentwurf wäre ja, wenn man mal bei diesen Stimmungssängern bleibt, Jürgen Dreves, der das immer ganz pragmatisch gesehen hat, der sich sagte, gut, ich will erfolgreich sein, ich stehe gern auf der Bühne, ich singe auch ganz gerne, aber ich sehe mich jetzt nicht als großer Künstler an, sondern ich gehe einem Job nach. Ich fahre einmal die Woche nach, fliege ich nach Mallorca, sing dort den Hit, lasse mich auch sonst am Wochenende, wenn es sein muss, zu vier Festivals fahren, quer durch Deutschland und mache dann den König von Mallorca und dann komme ich wieder zu Hause an in meiner Wohnsiedlung mit meiner Frau. Genau, und er hat eine sehr kluge Frau, die das gut einzuschätzen weiß, wie er zu nehmen ist. Also er hat natürlich da richtig viel Glück gehabt auch und ist wahnsinnig geerdet, er ist vielleicht ein bisschen spinnert, jetzt für ganz normale Verhältnisse, aber er ist wahnsinnig geerdet und sieht das einfach als einen sehr lukrativen Job, an den er auch mit Freude nach wie vor ausübt. Aber es gibt dann diese Leute, die sagen, gut, das ist mir zu entfremdet, ich will erfahren. Und du hast jetzt gerade schon über den Text gesprochen. Ja, was aber ganz wichtig ist, ist ja, dass irgendetwas erfahren wird, Spiritualität, die Anwesenheit von Engel. Wir haben ja in einem Salon schon mal, du hattest den Text vorgestellt, über diese QAnon-Anhänger geredet. Und wir haben dann doch verstehen müssen, dass das Leute sind, die eigentlich so eine Ersatzreligion sich damit geschaffen hatten. Und du hattest mich, glaube ich, gefragt, ob ich auch an dies oder das glaube. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ich bin ja ganz normal Protestant, ich brauche das andere ja nicht. Und das ist aber vielen Leuten nicht genug, zum Beispiel war das auch den Beatles nicht genug. Und wir hören jetzt mal in einen Ausschnitt rein von George Harrison, denn die Beatles haben ja auch diese Hare-Krishna-Bewegung toll gefunden, haben auch so Hare-Krishna-Gesänge aufgenommen. Und George Harrison sagt hier etwas zu diesem meditativen Schritt.
Alles andere ist nur mundane und zweit. Und das ist Meditation, es ist seit Millionen und Millionen Jahren da. Und es ist immer da. Und ein Knack und die Tür wird geöffnet. Das, was mich wirklich interessiert hat, war, nach dem Aufbau als Katholiker, bis ich ca. 13 war, konnte ich es nicht länger nehmen, weil es nur voll von Hypokrasie war. Und die Lehren eines Indiens, Vivikananda, die mich wirklich beeindruckt hat, hat gesagt, wenn es ein Gott gibt, müssen wir ihn sehen, wenn es ein Geist gibt, müssen wir ihn beobachten, sonst ist es besser, nicht zu glauben. Es ist besser, ein besprochener Atheist zu sein als ein Hypokrit.
Was hier ausgespielt wird, ist die institutionalisierte Religion in Form der katholischen Kirche, die Institution par excellence für Religion, gegen die direkte unmittelbare Erfahrung und die ist authentisch, während das, was in Institutionen stattfindet, was auch in Regeln in Gesetze gefasst ist, als heuchlerisch dargestellt wird und da muss man sehr vorsichtig sein, auch bei vielen Kirchenkritikern, dass wenn sie die Heuchelei kritisieren, die es ja durchaus in der katholischen Kirche, in der evangelischen Kirche gibt, bezogen beispielsweise auf Kindesmissbrauch oder sowas, dass das nicht dazu führt, dass man sagt, wir müssen jetzt eigentlich zurück, dass jeder wieder selbst nur die Begegnung mit Gott macht und dann können wir uns da alle auf unsere Erfahrungen stützen Ich kann sie nicht unterstützen und die kann mir auch niemand nehmen. Diese Institutionalisierung von Religion, die da stattgefunden hat, ist auch ein zivilisatorischer Fortschritt, muss man sagen. Und ich glaube, wir müssen sie auch noch mal ein bisschen ab, bitte tun. In Bezug auf Papst Benedict, nämlich als er, bevor er gewählt wurde, hielt er ja diese Rede von der Diktatur des Relativismus, vor der er warnte, vor der Diktatur des Relativismus, dieser Komme jetzt durch die Moderne. Er meinte natürlich damit, alles, was nach 68 kam, und wir wissen, dass das aus einem sehr konservativen Impetus heraus entsteht. Aber man kann es auch mal ein bisschen davon lösen und sagen, hier versuchte jemand, die Institution Kirche zu verteidigen, mit Blick darauf, dass wenn diese Institution immer weiter pröckeltsig auflöst, dann Tür und Tor für eine Diktatur des Relativismus insofern geöffnet ist, als dann Leute sagen, ich glaube, die Erde ist flach, ich glaube, Corona ist eine Lüge, ich glaube an Engel und ich glaube, dass ich mit Hare-Krishna-Gesängen in ein neues Bewusstsein komme. Und da hat er durchaus einen Punkt und man muss auch erkennen, dass jetzt jemand wie Kardinal Ratzinger damals oder dann auch Papst Benedikt für die Weltkirche spricht, also schon Entwicklungen antizipiert, die wir hier in Deutschland gar nicht kennen. Und dann sieht, dass zum Beispiel solche Sekten in Lateinamerika extrem erfolgreich sind und dass dort dann die Institution Katholische Kirche erheblich an Einfluss verliert.
Also wir haben im Nachgang zu unserer Lesung von diesem QAnon-Text habe ich auch nochmal so einen Fernsehpodcast gemacht mit einem ehemaligen Pastor und einem Theologiestudenten. Und da, also ich meine ich bin nicht bibelfest und so, aber wenn man das mit solchen Leuten nochmal bespricht, was sich bei QAnon wiederfindet, was in der Bibel schon rausinstitutionalisiert wurde, aber jetzt eben durch den Rückgang der Kirche als sozusagen religiöses, spirituelles Haus drum herum sich neue Formen sucht. Also alle möglichen Ideen, das ist wirklich beeindruckend, weil man dann die Kirche nachträglich, man sieht es natürlich nicht im Vollzug, aber nachträglich sozusagen, wenn sie verschwindet, kann man die Kirche nochmal wertschätzen, als sie hat diese ganz individuelle Spiritualität, das haben wir bei George Harrison jetzt richtig rausgehört, wie dieses individuelle Ich-Erlebe, wenn ich es nicht erlebt habe, ist es für mich bedeutungslos, es reicht mir nicht, dass mir jemand das Erleben eines anderen auf Lateinisch vorsagt und ich daraus dann irgendwelche Schlüsse zu ziehen habe, weil das ist nur wirklich appellativ und von außen, nee, genau umgedreht, ich muss es von mir heraus und das bricht sich jetzt wieder Bahn und da steckt wirklich, glaube ich, mehr Wirkmacht dahinter. Also wir sind alle beeindruckt von diesem Wendler-Dinger, muss man wirklich sagen, dass er das alles über Bord schmeißt, das plant, das mit Ansage macht, dass er weiß, wo er sich das Zeug herholt, noch versucht zu missionieren, andere Leute mitzuziehen, sein Manager und so. Das ist schon, da steckt schon einiges drin.
Und die Medien fahren darauf ab und auch das ist nicht neu, wie wir jetzt schon durch Beispiele gehört haben. Ich will ein weiteres bringen, kennst du noch Uriela? Diese Sektenführerin, die ist kürzlich gestorben, sie ist ja im Alter von über 90 Jahren gestorben, sie war bettlägerig die letzten knapp 10 Jahre. Aber man sagte, ihre Präsenz war noch ganz genau so da und ihr Geist immer noch frisch. Ja, Uriela war auch so ein Phänomen, dass die Boulevard-Medien gerade im privaten, aber auch im öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen sehr, sehr liebten. Und hier haben wir einen kurzen Bericht, einen Auszug daraus vom SWR.
Anfang der 1990er-Jahre kamen sie in Scharen, Ibach im Fokus der Medien. Wenn die selbst ernannte Heilerin und Sektengründerin in der Badewanne heiliges Wasser anrührte, war das natürlich ein Quotenhit. Zu Hunderten pilgerten ihre Anhänger aus der Schweiz, Österreich und Deutschland nun nach Ibach, alle in Weiß gekleidet, um sich vor den Strahlen Luzifers zu schützen. Im Ort selbst machte man sich Sorgen, dass die Sekte alles übernehmen würde. Heute gibt es diese Angst nicht mehr. Uriella heißt mit bürgerlichem Namen Erika Bärtschinger-Eike. Als die gebürtige Schweizerin 1973 vom Pferd fällt, behauptet sie danach hellsichtig zu sein. Mehrfach hat sie schon den Weltuntergang vorhergesagt. 1975 folgt dann die Erleuchtung.
Da war ich in einem Lichtkreis und wurde dann zum ersten Mal in die Volltrans versetzt.
Der Lichtkreis.
Die Strahlen Luzifas.
Die Strahlen Luzifas. Das Licht ist auch etwas ganz, ganz Existenzielles. Nicht nur im Christentum, in fast jeder Religion, aber auch bei diesen Esoterikern. Du hast es auch jetzt sehen können bei Nena, die auch so einen ganz, ganz verschwurbelten Facebook-Post machte, darüber, dass sie sich nicht unterkriegen lässt von all dem. Und sie benannte aber auch gar nicht so genau was. Es wurde viel geraunt. Und das endet dann auch damit so jetzt sinngemäß, dass sie aufbricht zum Licht. Und das wurde dann auch noch geliked von Xavier Naidoo. Und sie hat das auch dann noch mal oder diesen Kurzkommentar von Xavier Naidoo zurückgelegt. Wir sehen da schon, dass diese Lichtmetapher etwas ist, was in der Unterhaltungsbranche sehr, sehr präsent ist. Im Übrigen auch bei einem Schlagersänger. Wenn ich sage, es fährt ein Zug nach nirgendwo, klingelt es da noch bei dir? Du bist, glaube ich, als Kind nicht mit dem Fernseher sozialisiert. Es fährt ein Zug nach nirgendwo, Christian Anders, 70er-Jahre-Star, hat einige wirklich sehr, sehr große Hits gehabt, hat sich dann aber der Esoterik zugewandt und hat auch einen YouTube-Kanal. Das fiel mir jetzt wieder ein im Zuge dieser Wendler-Geschichte. Und da schaute ich jetzt mal drauf und wir hören uns hier mal einen Ausschnitt an.
In meinem Band 11 sage ich, Elektroautos könnten Unterleibskrebs verursachen. Ich habe immer gesagt und ich beschreibe es in meinem Buch, Wasserstoffautos. Die Wasserstoffmaschinen sind die Maschinen der Zukunft. Du brauchst nur Wasser. Vor 30 Jahren habe ich das bereits im Buch des Lichts beschrieben, im Englischen.
Ja, das Buch des Lichts. 33 Bücher hat er schon verfasst und er wurde aber immer wieder auch eingeladen, in Talkshows, um solche esoterischen Themen zu thematisieren.
Aber das wirkt für mich so.
Auch hat er ein Buch geschrieben, der AIDS erfand. Also auch da hat er seine ganz eigene Theorie.
Ja, das hat so eine gewisse Dimension von, ich kann doch auch meine eigene Enzyklika schreiben. So, was? So ganz groß angelegt irgendwie.
Und dann kommen so kleine Ideen raus, braune Wasserstoffautos. Wer hätte es geahnt, muss er natürlich auch eine Publikation vorlegen zu Corona.
Herzlich willkommen meine Lieben, ich bin Christian Anders. Mein spiritueller Name ist Lanou, das heißt der Schüler. Nicht der Meister, nicht der Guru, der Schüler. Und ich lerne jeden Tag hinzu und informiere mich und recherchiere. Das ist mein 33.
Buch, Corona.
Und natürlich habe ich keines dieser Bücher, die zum größten Teil wissenschaftliche Bücher sind, geschrieben, ohne zu recherchieren. Das Vorwort zu diesem Buch schreibt Prof. Dr. Serge Paukovitsch, Polizeiarzt von Berlin, Arzt für Allgemeinmedizin, allgemeingerechtlich beeideter und zertifizierter Sachverständiger, Notart und Berufspilot. Also wir nehmen mal an, wir können mal vorsichtig voraussetzen, dass das jemand ist, der weiß, wovon er spricht.
Ich habe das auch erstmal angenommen, aber dann kamen mir nach und nach Zweifel, was dann mit diesem Mann so los ist. Ich habe ihn dann mal gegoogelt und der ist tatsächlich schon in der Presse gewesen, weil er eine höhere Position begleitet hat und zugleich aber auch davor warnt, dass die Chemtrails uns alle vergiften werden. Er hat irgendeine medizinische Ausbildung, aber Christian Anders hat ihn natürlich sich sofort geschnappt und sich das Vorwort schreiben lassen.
Diese Verweise auf Reputation finde ich immer besonders amüsant. Das ist ja ganz häufig, dass du dieses Ich recherchiere hier lese, ich recherchiere.
Und ich habe einen Presseausweis, er hatte doch kein Absinn, glaube ich, bei seinem ersten Corona-Video gesagt, wo ich dachte, ja das hat ja jeder Volenteur in der Regionalzeitung.
Und dann immer so, jeder hat es schon bis dahin geschafft und deswegen kann er jetzt Aussagen treffen.
Das ist ja anders, muss man sagen, läuft Gott sei Dank unter ferner Liefen. Aber es gibt ja auch dann Leute, die wir durchaus in Talkshows erlebt haben, noch vor ein paar Jahren, die dort krudes Zeug verbreitet haben. Nina Hagen gleich mehrmals zu Gast bei Maischberger. Ich habe jetzt hier mal einen Auftritt, der diskutiert, kann man das gar nicht nennen. Also da keift sie Blubart an, den ZDF-Wissenschaftsredakteur ist der, glaube ich. Und es soll da um Außerirdische gehen, um UFOs. An diese glaubt Nina Hagen ja neben vielen, vielen anderen Dingen auch. Und wir hören jetzt mal uns an, wie das hier verläuft und wie wir merken, dass die Medien diese Eskalationen lieben, dass diese Medien eigentlich diese Wendlerhaftigkeit extrem lieben. Denn sonst würde man eine Person wie Nina Hagen nicht immer und immer wieder einladen und ihr das durchgehen lassen. Man muss sagen, ja damals war das vielleicht noch ungefährlich. Da gab es keine Pandemie, da konnte sie von UFOs erzählen. Und da war jetzt nicht, dass die Leute alle auf zum Mond gedüst sind nach so einer Show. Aber problematisch wird es dann halt, wenn solch verrücktes Denken verknüpft wird mit einer aktuellen Gefahrenlage. Aber wir hören mal hier in unschuldigere Zeiten hinein.
Es hat eine Kanadierin, die seit ihrer Kindheit maltrittiert worden ist, nicht nur von ihrem eigenen Vater tagtäglich geschlagen worden ist, sondern sie ist danach, seit der Kindheit wie gesagt, immer irgendwie aus ihrem Umfeld rausgeholt worden, abgeholt worden, in ein blödes UFO gebracht worden, gefoltert worden.
Ihr wurde das Blut ausgetauscht.
Ich nenne das eine Einkleidung.
Und er hat schon im Mittelalter die Leute genau so...
Nein, nein, nein.
Das ist eher eine spezielle Therapie-Handsung hier.
Tun Sie mir einen Gefallen und lassen Sie den vernünftigen Ansatz. Das ist ja die Atmosphäre.
Und wenn die anderen bösen, George Bush und die alle ohne abhauen würden, dann haben wir es geschafft, Leute.
Der Typ ist einfach weg. Wir haben ihn ja nicht superleid.
Nina, das war nicht nett.
Ich fand es toll, dass er jetzt weg ist.
Ich finde es super.
Ich freue mich.
Wollen Sie zurückkommen in diese Runde und bei uns für Buplatt, bitte?
Ja, Joachim Buplatt tut das einzig Richtige, er verlässt diesen Wahnsinn.
Ja, da kann man einfach nur gehen. Auch wenn jetzt das Argument immer kommt, nein, das sind zu viele QAnon, wir müssen uns auch mit denen innerlich auseinandersetzen, aber Gesprächsabbruch ist hier nie verkehrt.
Ja, und wir sehen ja ganz klar, wo das hinführt sonst und dass da keine rationale Argumentation mehr möglich ist. Ja, das war jetzt einfach mal so assoziativ ein bisschen das, was mir zum Wendler eingefallen ist, weil ich dachte, wir müssen das ein bisschen größer einordnen. Wir können nicht jetzt nur diese Einzelperson sehen, die durchdreht und dann müssen wir das, wenn wir auch diese Berichterstattung über diese Corona-Leugner uns vergegenwärtigen, doch klar machen, dass die Medien sehr stark, also die, nicht Mainstream-Medien, will ich nicht sagen, sagen die immer, die sagen Mainstream-Medien, die sagen wir die Unterhaltungsmedien, die Boulevard-Medien generell eine Tendenz dann zu haben, solche Effekte zu verstärken, sie in den Mittelpunkt zu rücken und es gerade dann lieben, wenn es irrational, wenn es möglichst verrückt wird und das, das nicht nur Einladung in Talkshows sichert, sondern auch die Quoten extrem erhöht und glaube ich unter diesem medienwissenschaftlichen Blickpunkt muss man diesen Corona-Wahnsinn auch betrachten, Um dann vielleicht auch viele Dinge nicht zu machen. Zum Beispiel, dass man dann nicht bald hingeht und sagt, jetzt haben wir auch mal QAnon-Anhänger hier in der Talkshow und die sollen doch jetzt mal erklären, woran sie glauben.
QAnon muss rausstattiert werden. Das wird ja bei Facebook und so jetzt auch erstaunlich, in erstaunlichem Ausmaße getan. Also ganz, aber diesen Monat ist keine Zeit für zum Beispiel das größte Kartellverfahren, was die amerikanische Regierung jetzt gegen Google angestrengt hat und so. Denn wir haben ja immer noch Corona.
Du hast jetzt gerade die Vorlage geliefert, Stefan. QAnon wird immer mehr aussortiert bei Twitter und Facebook. Ja, Stefan, gehen wir auf eine Diktatur zu? Oder wie ist das? Man bekommt zumindest den Eindruck, oder es sagt jemand, der sich jetzt aus YouTube vorerst verabschiedet hat, bzw. hat all seine Videos auf privat gestellt. Und nur ein einziges Video ist auf dem Kanal zu sehen. Es geht um Ken FM der sich in den Jahren immer weiter radikalisiert hat und der ja dann noch wirklich einen Höhenflug mit Corona erleben konnte, indem er dort vom Merkel Deutschland 2020 redete. Und wir werden jetzt Zeiten wie im Zweiten Weltkrieg erleben. Und schuld daran ist Merkel und ist Bill Gates, der uns alle impfen will. Also es gab ja dann im Zuge dieser Corona-Leugner immer welche, die so in den Mittelpunkt kamen und die das Ganze auch noch als Katalysator da zur Verfügung standen und da gehört Ken Jepsen hinzu. Und er hat jetzt ein Video veröffentlicht und verkündet Folgendes.
Berlin war mal Ort, da ist man hingegangen, da hat man sich angesiedelt, weil man Toleranz suchte, weil man weg wollte vom spießigen Leben da draußen in der Provinz. Heute ist es umgedreht, heute findet das pralle Leben, die Vielfalt, die Co-Existenz findet in der Provinz statt, während diese Stadt immer aggressiver wird.
Er zieht sich zurück aus Berlin mit seinem Studio.
Genau, er zieht sich zurück. Und da sind ja noch drei Clips offen. Er geht ja auch irgendwo hin und das werden wir gleich noch mal diskutieren. Müssen wir jetzt nicht beim ersten Clip machen. Aber dieser Hinweis auf, man wird hier eingeschränkt in Berlin. Man muss, glaube ich, 2020 auch wirklich mal sagen, wir haben bisher dieses Freiheitsthema ganz hochgehacken. Wir wählen die Freiheit. Das war Adenaus Spruch und seitdem kämpfen wir für diesen Satz. Und wir haben diese ganzen Sprüche, die Freiheit des einen ist und so weiter. Beginnt bei der Freiheit des anderen. Und wir sind jetzt 2020 wirklich an dem Punkt, wo man sagen muss, es gibt deviantes Verhalten. Das haben wir bisher erst in der Medizin so ein bisschen definiert, in der Psychologie und so. Aber es gibt jetzt deviantes Verhalten, abweichendes Verhalten, bei dem man wirklich ein Riegel vorschieben muss. Auch wenn der Gegenvorwurf dann ist, irgendwas mit Zensur, irgendwas mit Kommunismus, irgendwas mit Diktatur, irgendwas, egal was. Der Vorwurf ist dann erstmal auch zu behandeln, aber nicht in dieser pauschalen Weise, wie er gemeint ist, sondern der muss dann da eingehegt werden in der Diskussion. Und bei Wendler, okay, den Typ hab ich nicht auf dem Schirm gehabt und so. Ich wusste halt, okay, da ist irgendwie und so. Jetzt habe ich da gerade seine Clips gehört und das ist schon beeindruckend, in welcher, wie soll man sagen, mit welcher Energie er in Richtung Licht strebt. Und bei Kenneth M alle Videos vom Kanal zu nehmen, weil man irgendwie Angst hat vor dem dritten Strike und jetzt mal ein Statement machen will. Und da steckt ja auch so diese Hoffnung drin, vielleicht generiere ich dadurch Unterstützung, die mir vorher noch versagt wurde. Also er sieht ja immer noch Unterstützerpotenzial, dass er noch nicht eingesammelt hat.
Er appelliert ganz stark an Mittelständler. Die sollen ihn unterstützen, denn der Mittelstand soll jetzt zusammenhalten. Denn Ken Jepsen hat vor, in der Provinz, also er verlässt nicht das Land wie der Wendler, sondern er verlässt Berlin, um in die Provinz zu gehen, um in der Provinz dann ein Zentrum zu eröffnen.
Und deswegen haben wir uns entschlossen, diese Stadt, die uns offensichtlich nicht mehr will, die uns keine Räumlichkeiten zur Verfügung stellen möchte, diese Stadt zu verlassen und in die Provinz zu gehen, ganz bewusst aufs Land, in die Provinz. Und man hat uns bereits einen Platz angeboten, den wir so haben können. Aber was wir jetzt tun müssen, ist, wir müssen auf diesen Platz ein Gebäude stellen, nämlich ein KNFM-Studio. Damit ist es aber nicht getan, denn das reine Studio ist mir ein bisschen zu wenig. Wir brauchen eine Begegnungsstätte, wir brauchen einen Ort, wo man Veranstaltungen machen kann, wo man Seminare veranstalten kann, Räumlichkeiten, die wir auch anderen anbieten können, die dort zum Beispiel Achtsamkeitseminare veranstalten können. Und ich stelle mir ja vor, eine Art Campus, das soll der Beginn eines Campuses sein, wo ich zum Beispiel unter anderem die nächste Generation von Journalisten ausbilde. Oder aber ein Hermann Plopper bildet die nächste Generation von Historikern aus. Ein Daniel Leganza bildet die nächste Generation von Friedensaktivisten aus.
Mensch, was haben wir denn für Journalisten-Ausbildung gelassen? Hätten wir diese Möglichkeiten gehabt, Stefan?
Ich frage mich jetzt ein bisschen, wo wird das sein? Er hat ja noch nicht enthüllt, wo das ist. Und ich hege die Vermutung, das wird irgendwo in Baden-Württemberg sein. Dieser spirituelle Dunstkreis Stuttgart.
Ich hätte gedacht, der Osten, weil es ja dort immer mehr solche Ansiedlungsprojekte gibt. Es gibt ein sehr gutes Buch, das ich empfehlen kann, Völkische Landname von Andrea Speid und Andrea Röpke. Da geht es um Rechtsradikale, die sich in die Provinz zurückziehen, dort Höfe kaufen, die leer stehen. Wir wissen ja, warum die Höfe verweist sind, haben wir eben gelernt. Und dann sagen viele Nachbarn auch, das ist ja toll, die jungen Leute kommen da, die haben viele Kinder und die machen auch manchmal so schöne Feste dort und alle Mädchen tragen Zöpfe und wundern sich erst mal gar nicht, was das eigentlich für Leute sind.
Genau, es gibt diese faschistische Landnahme und dann gibt es den Dunstkreis Berlin, wo man so künstlerisch ausbricht, aber schon die Nähe zur Metropole sucht. Aber ich glaube, das geht hier so in diese baden-württembergische Richtung, in diese, der Stutengarten darf nicht gerodet werden für den Bahnhof und so weiter, denn die Bäume leben und dann macht man so Baumkreise und so was. Denn die hatten doch, es gab doch diese Veranstaltung in Stuttgart, diese erste irgendwie Quartett, also Querdenken 711, 11 oder wie das heißt, ist ja auch Vorwahl Stuttgart. Genau, er war ja da und das war ja eine der wenigen, eigentlich kennt man Kenneth M nicht auf so Veranstaltungen und dass er bis nach Stuttgart gefahren ist, war ja für viele schon überraschend, ihn so weit außerhalb seines Berlins zu sehen. Und ich glaube, da hat er Kontakte geknüpft, da kamen so die Leute zu ihm und meinten, oh, ich hab hier noch so ein bisschen Fläche und so. Und jetzt hat er da so ein Acker irgendwie angeboten bekommen. Also würde mich nicht wundern, wenn das so in diese baden-württembergisch-spirituelle Richtung geht. Aber wer weiß.
Wir hören mal weiter.
Was wir hier spekulieren, Mensch, Mensch, Mensch.
Aber, und da sind wir uns auch einig, die Einschläge kommen näher. Wir merken, dass der Druck auf diejenigen, die uns unterstützen, immer größer wird. Wir merken, dass auch, dass der Druck dahingehend größer wird, dass Homepages von alternativen Sendern gelöscht werden. Wir sind angezählt, wir haben den zweiten Strike bei YouTube bekommen. Bei einem dritten Strike heißt das, der Kanal ist platt, dann sind wir unsere über 500.000 User los und wir können euch nicht mehr erreichen.
Ja, die deutsche Agrarindustrie merkt auch, die Einschläge rücken näher. Jetzt haben sie schon den zweiten Strike von Robert Habeck bekommen und Fridays for Future klopft auch schon an und fragt, was sollen das? Und es ist ja wirklich so, auf der Ebene denke ich das. KenFM ist ein Unternehmen und es setzt irgendwie auf Reichweite und möchte hier was erreichen. Und ja, da wird viel inhaltlich argumentiert. Und das ist halt in Medien, da geht es dann auch inhaltlich zu. Aber am Ende ist the medium the message. Und ich glaube, er hat hier einfach, er nutzt hier eine ökonomische Chance.
Aber glaubst du, es besteht auch eine begründete Angst vor einer Löschung des Kanals? Denn tatsächlich sind ja beispielsweise rechtsradikale Kanäle gesperrt worden bei YouTube und dann bekommen die ja auch nicht mehr zurück. Und dann verlieren die Leute ja ihre Anhängerschaft. Und die kann man dann auch nicht alle dazu bewegen, zu Telegram zu gehen. Es gibt ja auch aus linken Kreisen Leute, die sagen, naja, jubelt man nicht so laut, wenn jemand von der identitären Bewegung den Kanal verliert. Denn vielleicht blüht uns das auch bald. So war das jetzt auch noch mal in Bezug auf KenFM, in einem Tweet zu lesen von dem Lower Class Magazin, einem Online-Portal, das sehr linke Inhalte anbietet und das jetzt gesagt hat, naja, wir wollen jetzt mal hier nicht jubeln. Zum einen können wir froh sein, dass er möglichst nicht zu sehen ist. Zum anderen aber müssen wir uns fragen, ergeht uns das auch? Also wird tatsächlich eine Zensur ausgeübt nach und nach?
Meine Kritik an YouTube und Facebook die letzten Jahre war, dass da zu wenig rausstattiert wird. Und ich unterscheide eigentlich wenig zwischen kognitiven Gefahrgut-Transportern und Materiellen auf der Autobahn. Also wenn hier Gefahr vorliegt, dann muss er auch mal eingeschritten werden. Die Frage ist dann, wie schreitet man ein? Und da finde ich, kann man natürlich schon kritisieren, dass wir es ja einfach YouTube überlassen, aus eigenem politischen Handlungsunvermögen, da auch mal ein Wörtchen mitzureden. In der Ansicht kann man darüber natürlich sprechen. Aber wenn man jetzt so liest, dass QAnon-Seiten aussortiert werden und das Info Wars geblockt wird und so, würde ich jetzt nicht sagen. Das ist aber blöd, weil das würde dann auch anderen passieren. Ich kann die Gründe, warum das passiert, nämlich sehr gut nachvollziehen. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich war ja auch 2016 bei Ken Jepsen in dem Interview. Das war noch vor Trump und vor, kurz nach Brexit, aber vor Trump und so. Ja, und diese letzten vier Jahre, mir fehlt wie gesagt immer noch die Radikalisierungsgeschichte Donald Trumps im Amt. Das ist ein absolut unterbelichtetes Thema, wie sich Donald Trump von der Amtseinführung bis jetzt radikalisiert hat. Ja, und diese vier Jahre sind so bezeichnet und so prägend, dass ich schon denke, nee, da muss mehr passieren in diesen Medien geschehen. Aber wie gesagt, nur die Methoden, nicht die Inhalte, finde ich jetzt kritisieren, sondern die Methoden, wie da geblockt wird. Aber irgendwie ist es auch so, YouTube und Facebook, die machen das halt, weil sonst keiner es macht. Denen wird halt Angst um ihre eigene Plattform gemacht. Das sieht man jetzt wieder bei Google und bei Facebook immer auch, dass es den Plattformen selbst an den Kragen geht. Also darüber wird dann so Verantwortung abgewälzt. Und da müsste eigentlich die Politik mal rein, dass man den Kompetenzbereich von mehreren Landesmedienanstalten und so weiter dann auch einfach wirklich mal ausweitet. Weil die müssen für mich jetzt nicht das SWR-Forum kontrollieren. Da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass das redaktionell schon richtig gut läuft dort. Und dass die da nicht drohend immer auf die Finger geklopft werden muss, weil sie mal wieder jemanden eingeladen haben. Sondern da fehlt mir halt einfach so ein bisschen.
Aber es ist halt sehr schwer zu kontrollieren. Also darf dann noch jemand von Engeln erzählen bei YouTube? Das ist ja in erster Linie eine Idiosyncrasie, die ungefährlich ist. Während jetzt eine Corona-Leugnung und dann eine Mobilisierung dazu, dass man irgendwie versucht, den Reichstag zu stürmen, eine andere Dimension hat. Wie ja auch, glaube ich, es nicht stattfinden würde, dass jetzt ein Marxistischer YouTube-Kanal gesperrt würde. Aber sicherlich einer, der sagt, so, jetzt erschießen wir alle Kapitalistenschweine und die sitzen da und dort in diesen Aufsichtsräten. Ich glaube, das sind diese kreduelle Unterschiede.
Genau. Alle kürzerischen politischen Freiheiten zugestanden. Aber wenn jemand dazu aufruft, keine Masken zu tragen, und dann sieht man plötzlich auf Twitter irgendwelche Videos für irgendwelche Idioten zu Zehnt in Berlin S-Bahn fahren und dort im Berufsverkehr einfach Leute wirklich gefährden, mit Corona infiziert zu werden, dann ist das einfach... Also dann liegt da einfach ein anderes Problem vor, als wenn jetzt einfach nur jemand mit einer blöden Idee rumschreit. Und dann hören das halt Leute, und da geht halt keine Infektionsgefahr aus. Und das muss man halt ganz klar. Und es wird aber auch, finde ich, bislang ganz gut unterteilt, wo halt hier eine echte Gefährdung vorliegt und wo nur eine Belästigung vorliegt.
Kenneth M braucht selbstverständlich diese Drohkulisse. Du hast es schon angedeutet, um potenzielle neue Spende auch zu gewinnen, um mit dieser Eskalation, die man auch dadurch hervorruft, dass man jetzt mal alle Videos erst mal auf privat stellt. Also er hat sie ja nicht gelöscht. Die sind auf privat gestellt, so scheint mir das zumindest zu sein. Und nur ein Video veröffentlicht, dann erhöht das den Druck. Also das ist die letzte Ausweg, der noch da ist. Es ist ein bisschen, hat das auch etwas Wendlerhaftes, wie das vorgebracht wird. Und wir hören uns jetzt noch mal den letzten Auszug an.
Das heißt, wir planen hier mit euch gemeinsam eine Art Raumfahrtprogramm. Wir wollen quasi auf den Mond. Ein solcher Campus kostet richtig Geld, aber es ist eben nicht nur ein Studio. Es ist eine Begegnungsstätte, wo wir unter anderem ein Medienunternehmen sind. Aber wir möchten zum Beispiel, dass dort zum Beispiel Mediziner auf einer Bühne die Möglichkeiten der Alternativmedizin unterrichten können. Vor ihnen sitzen neue Mediziner, die diese neuen Techniken dann zur Anwendung bringen. Also eine Art Messe, wo wir die unterschiedlichsten Branchen einladen können. Angedockt vielleicht ein bisschen an das, was früher in den 30er Jahren Weimarer Republik das Bauhaus geleistet hat. Also, dass man eben nicht nur Architektur hat, sondern man hat eben auch Kunst gehabt. Man hat sich über die Menschen generell Gedanken gemacht. Und ich möchte vor allem, dass es ein Ort wird, wo wir auch wieder spirituell werden. Weil ohne Spiritalität haben wir keine Chance.
Ja, also das Video ist erstaunlich wenig radikal und erstaunlich so spirituell, so annehmlich irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, so Dunskreis schafft.
Ich glaube, dass es sich auch gut vorstellen, dass die Urielle auch noch dort auftritt, wenn sie noch leben würde und auch noch Badewasser anrührt. Oder George Harrison in Hare Krishna-Song singt Christian anders noch mal den Zug nach nirgendwo fahren lässt. Alles ist da eigentlich möglich, getan wird auch so, als wäre da wirklich eine Ausbildung mitzubekommen. Das ist ja ganz abstrus und es hat etwas wahnsinnig betuliches irgendwie auch. Es ist sicherlich auch eine große Gefahr, wenn sich viele anschließen aus ganz verschiedenen Spekten. Aber das wirkt so wahnsinnig betulich und irgendwie im höchsten Maße lachhaft.
Ja, ich glaube, dagegen eine Marktforschung voraus und er hat sich Baden-Württemberg ausgesucht und wer weiß, wer weiß, wie das auch für uns dokumentiert wird, ohne YouTube-Kanal.
Aber da ja, das sagt er auch nochmal in dem Video, dass dann durchaus Aufnahmen stattfinden und wenn man die dann nicht mehr irgendwo veröffentlichen kann auf Plattformen, dann gibt man die sich über USB-Sticks weiter. Also man versucht jetzt auch so im Geheimen dann so eine Geheimgesellschaft zu machen. Im Übrigen eine Entwicklung, die in Deutschland Tradition hat, dass man eben so überlegt hat, ob man nicht dann im kleinen Kreise sich in die Provinz zurückzieht. Eine Entwicklung, die man in den 20er Jahren, in den alten 20er Jahren finden kann, dass er nochmal auf so ein Mondprojekt verweist. Da sieht man, er hat vielleicht auch ein bisschen von der Leyen geguckt, dass er jetzt solche Rhetoriken übernimmt. Und dann kommt auch noch das Bauhaus, dass er aber dann in die 30er Jahre ansiedelt. Das muss man ja auch schon ein bisschen früher ansiedeln. Das Bauhaus war das, was Ken Jepsen dort beschreibt, selbstverständlich nicht. Aber wir können ja froh sein, dass da jetzt nochmal ganz alternative medizinische Ausbildungen genossen werden können. Denn wir wissen ja nicht, Stefan, was uns mit Corona noch alles droht.
Corona! Wir machen natürlich auch noch ein kleines Corona-Segment, denn es kocht ja gerade wieder hoch das Thema, auch durch politische Ansinnen. Und ich finde, hier steckt noch so ein rentnerrepublikanisches Argument drin. Rentnerrepublik meint, Gesellschaften werden älter, die Deutsche ganz besonders. Und das verändert den Mindset, so ein Shift im Denken. Weg von Innovation, sich mal was trauen, Ideen haben, hin zu, es wird jetzt ganz wichtig, sich um viele Menschen zu kümmern. Sicherheit geht plötzlich vor. Ältere Gesellschaften sind so stagnierende, geruhsame Gesellschaften, die ziehen nicht in Kriege, sondern da gibt man den Jungen nochmal den Rat, plane dein Leben ordentlich, versuch nicht zu viel Albernheiten einzubauen, sodass es mit dem Umlagsystem auch passt, bis ich dann abtrete, so ungefähr. Und Corona ist ja nun in erheblichem Maße ein Problem der Älteren. Man sagt immer Risikogruppen, weil es auch Vorerkrankungen gibt, aber es ist dann doch ein Ding der Älteren. Und wir hören hier in das 58. Coronavirus-Update rein. Das ist also Drostens Podcast beim NDR und er hat eine richtige Mega-Meta-Studie zum Thema Ursächlichkeit des Sterbens an Covid-19 mit besonderem Blick auf die Altersverteilung angestellt. Und wir machen es jetzt ausdrücklich am Anfang ein bisschen ausführlicher. Also es sind jetzt vier Clips, die gehen jeweils über eine Minute. Denn es wird in Deutschland, finde ich, schon ein bisschen zu viel Drosten, Streh, Kikkuli, irgendwelche Namen genannt. Und die darunterliegenden Ideen sind so ein bisschen, also wie wir das beispielsweise bei Lauterbach bei Lanz gesehen haben, ja diese Vereinnahmung von, ich sage einfach mal Drosten und damit habe ich das halbe Publikum auf meiner Seite. Irgendwie so ein Namedropping sieht man schon. Deswegen hören wir uns lieber nochmal genau an. Was hat Drosten eigentlich wirklich gesagt zum Thema Ursache des Sterbens an Covid-19, insbesondere Verweis auf die Altersverteilung?
Hier wurden 962 Studien zur Infektionssterblichkeit ausgewertet. Das ist also eine extrem hohe Zahl. Da sieht man mal, was die Wissenschaft so generiert hat seither. Zum Beispiel wurden in dieser Meta-Analyse, über die wir jetzt hier sprechen, nicht nur einfache, direkte wissenschaftliche Studien ausgewertet, sondern auch Länderdatensätze, also nationale Meldedatensätze, die manchmal noch gar nicht zu wissenschaftlichen Studien zusammengefasst sind, aber doch in Statistiken vorliegen. Und da zählt dann wieder die Qualität des nationalen Meldesystems oder des auch regionalen Meldesystems. Und auch da haben die Autoren jeweils ganz genau draufgeschaut. Also die waren wirklich sehr kritisch auf Korrektheit dieser Untersuchungen. Und das hat dazu geführt, dass sie dann von diesen 962 Studien 873 gleich ausgeschlossen haben. Weitergemacht haben sie dann mit 14 Seroprevalenzstudien. Also das sind Antikörperstudien. Davon sind 9 an Orten in der Europäischen Union gemacht und 12 in den USA. Da sieht man schon, 9 plus 12 ist mehr als 14. Das heißt, einige von diesen Studien haben an mehreren Orten gearbeitet.
Und Deutschland ist schon nicht mehr drin vorgekommen?
Deutschland kommt da gar nicht mehr drin vor. Wir haben also aus Deutschland keine solche Studie, die diese Qualitätskriterien erfüllt hat.
So, Deutschland, das zweitälteste Land der Welt, nach Japan. So, gleich auch mit Südkorea. Und Italien kommt dann auch gleich. Hat zum einen, das wissen wir von Kekkole, keine fortlaufende statistische Führung, also statistische Mitführung der Todeszahl in Deutschland. Sondern die werden tatsächlich zum Jahresende dann mit einer eigenen Forschungsfrage zusammenklamüsert. So wie wir ja auch lange jetzt kein Intensivregister hatten. Jetzt haben wir es plötzlich durch Corona. Wissen wir in Deutschland immer wenig über das Sterben Bescheid, auch quantitativ, ja nicht nur qualitativ, wie geht eigentlich Sterben, sondern es ist auch quantitativ und deswegen findet ihr zum Beispiel gar keine. Es gab keine deutsche Erhebung von Sterbedaten zum Thema Covid, die diesen qualitativen Ansprüchen der Forscher hier entsprochen hat, weshalb man sich andere europäische und amerikanische Studien genommen hat. Aus fast 900 großen Datenreihen und Studien hat man also die wirklich relevanten rausgenommen und dann einzeln untersucht und ein Ergebnis ist dies.
Mit anderen Worten, Statistiker würde sagen, die Alterszusammensetzung erklärt fast die gesamte Varianz im Datensatz. Also die Veränderlichkeit, die Unterschiedlichkeit der Infektionssterblichkeit zwischen den einzelnen Studien, zwischen den einzelnen Ländern, zum Teil sind das lokale Datensätze in einzelnen amerikanischen Bundesstaaten usw. die wird praktisch nur davon bestimmt, wie alt die untersuchte Bevölkerungsgruppe im Mittel ist. Also das Alter macht es aus und sonst praktisch nichts.
Zu 90 Prozent ist die Zahl, was die geografische Verteilung angeht, in der Studie genannt wird.
Genau, das ist schon extrem viel. Eine so hohe Attribution, also so viel Zuschreibung an einen Faktor, das ist schon erstaunlich. Aber die Tatsache, dass diese Studien so gut vorausgewählt worden sind, hat gleichzeitig hier auch dazu geführt, dass die Vertrauensgrenzen dieser Untersuchung extrem eng sind. Und das finde ich wirklich sehr überzeugend. Darum habe ich diese Studie hier auch hervorgehoben.
Also, Drosten ist sehr beeindruckt von dieser Studie. Und sie sagt, wenn man die Todesfälle erklären möchte, dann ist im erheblichen über- also in nicht gekannten Ausmaße mit anderen Krankheiten, das Alter ausschlaggebend. Wenn das Virus in einem Altenheim ausbricht, sterben dort alle. Und wenn es in einer dritten Klasse ausbricht, dann kriegen die das nicht mal mit, dass es da überhaupt Infektionen gab. Das haben wir jetzt aus China, dieses Phänomen, dass die ja immer noch Stichproben-Untersuchungen machen. Und dann finden die immer mal wieder Infektionen. Und dann gehen die so in- also versuchen die so Cluster sozial zu modellieren und die dann nachzutesten und stellen fest, ja, hier ist ein Cluster von 100, 200 Infektionen, kein einziger symptomatischer Fall dabei. Es ist nicht aufgefallen, das ist diese Gefahr von Corona. Es ist für die Alten tödlich und es verbreitet sich, auch wenn man glaubt, man hätte es eigentlich besiegt. Selbst in China gibt es noch Corona. Und es fällt dann wirklich erst auf, wenn man entweder in Stichprobe macht. Dazu braucht man Testkapazitäten, die wir in Deutschland gerade nicht haben. Deswegen kriegen wir das nicht mit, wo Corona ist, sondern wir gehen wirklich erst immer dann ran, wenn es eigentlich zu spät ist. Wenn nämlich das Cluster von vor einer Woche jetzt schon bei dem ersten Ausprägung zeigt und alle anderen weiteren Betroffenen mit beginnender Symptome auch schon wieder drei andere angesteckt haben. Also Alter über die Maßen ausschlaggebend. Und er bricht es jetzt mal hier runter auf, was bedeutet das jetzt eigentlich? Jetzt sind wir wieder in der Stochastischen Gesellschaft. Für uns Einzelne, so ganz konkret, könnte man irgendwie so eine Aussage ableiten.
In der Altersgruppe zwischen 35 und 44, da liegen wir ungefähr so wie bei der Influenza. Also das ist so, wenn so ein Mittelalter-Erwachsener eine Grippe kriegt, eine echte Virusgrippe, da liegt man also auch häufig schon im Bett. Aber einige haben auch ganz leichte Verläufe nur. Zwischen 45 und 54 ist es 0, 2 Prozent Infektion, Bestärblichkeit. Zwischen 55 und 64, also die letzten zehn Berufsjahre, die man so hat, ist das 0, 7 Prozent. Das ist also ebenso im Bereich von je nach Vergleichssituation. Ich würde jetzt mal sagen, zehnmal so viel wie die Grippe. Oder sogar noch mehr. Also in anderen Ländern würde man auch sagen, 15-mal so viel wie die Grippe. In der Altersgruppe von 65 bis 74, wo man also gerade in Rente ist und das Leben jetzt richtig genießen kann noch mal, ist die Infektionssterblichkeit 2, 2 Prozent. Das ist 30-mal so viel wie die Influenza. Also in dieser Altersgruppe auf einen Grippetoten haben wir 30 Covid-19-Tote. Und die Zahlen, die dann höher sind, noch in den höheren Altersgruppen, sind furchtbar. Über 75 bis 84 Jahren 7, 3 Prozent. Und über 85 Jahren fast jeder dritte. Das ist also so viel wie die Pocken im Mittelalter oder einige Ebola-Ausbrüche in Afrika, die auch in diesen Bereichen sich entwickeln.
So, also es beginnt bei U45, da ist Corona tödlich wie eine Grippe. Also eigentlich gar nicht. Kaum. Das bricht sich dann irgendwie runter für die U35. Julian Nieder-Rübelin hatte die Studie auch mal aufgegriffen bei Anne Will. Und meint dann, für U35 ist das so 0, 003 Prozent. Das heißt, um auf 1000 Tote zu kommen, braucht man schon eine Population von 15 Millionen Menschen oder so. Und da sind wir im Range von einer wirklich eigentlich nicht nennenswerten Krankheit.
Aber wie sieht es, wenn ich da gerade mal unterbrechen darf, du wirst mir das wahrscheinlich beantworten können, wie sieht es denn mit möglichen Folgen aus, dass ich, wenn ich jetzt Corona bekomme, daran vermutlich nicht sterbe. Davon gehe ich jetzt aus. Ich schütze mich vor allem sehr stark, weil ich Kontakt habe mit Leuten, die zu Risikogruppen aufgrund des Alters oder auch aufgrund anderer Erkrankungen zählen. Sonst aber, glaube ich, würde ich das wahrscheinlich relativ wacker wegstecken. Aber ich frage mich natürlich, was für Folgen habe ich dann am Ende aus dieser Erkrankung? Und wie wird es sein, wenn wir dann die schwarz-grüne Regierung unter Friedrich Merz haben und dann mal die allgemeine Krankenversicherung abgeschafft wird, und ich eine chronische Krankheit habe und selbst dafür zahlen muss?
Also Vorerkrankungen spielen eine Rolle. Aber wir haben eben hier schon gehört, zu 90 Prozent ist es das Alter. Bei Tödlichkeit. Bei Tödlichkeit. Du hast ja jetzt nach Langzeitschäden und so was gefragt. Ich habe nicht ohne Grund hier dieses Thema überhaupt nur aufgegriffen, weil wir hier eine Studie haben, die zum einen megamäßig riesig ist und die zum anderen mit der höchsten Reputation zurzeit ausgestattete Wissenschaftler so bespricht, wie wir das jetzt hier aufgreifen können. Weil wenn der Drosten sagt, die größte Metastudie der Welt zum Thema Sterblichkeit sagt, für U45 ist Corona tödlich wie die Grippe, dann ist das eine ganz besondere Aussage, weil nämlich dieser Grippe-Vorwurf ansonsten absolut nicht möglich wäre. Also dafür ist es die Stimmung einfach zu vergiftet. Deswegen sage ich jetzt nichts zur Vorerkrankung, außer dass ich die Vermutung äußere, dass es eine Korrelation gibt. Also Tödlichkeit und Nebenfolgen und Langzeitfolgen, das ist auf einer Dimension. Und es kann natürlich sein, dass Corona jetzt eine ganz besondere Krankheit ist, aber, und ich habe gestern diese Pressekonferenz von Streeck, Schmidt-Ranassit und dem kassenärztlichen Verbandspräsidenten da gehört, die auch noch mal darauf hinweisen, dass das RKI, glaube ich, zum Stand gestern zwei Todesfälle U20 in Deutschland ausgewiesen hat, seit März an Corona oder Covid-19 und das waren eben zwei Vorerkrankungsfälle, also wo man auch wieder sozusagen die Statistik Erklärung, die eh virulent ist, noch mal anbringen kann und dass es zu den Langzeitfolgen zu sagen gibt, Lungenentzündungen eignen sich immer dafür, Langzeitfolgen zu zeigen, immer. Ob sie von den Grippeviren ausgelöst wird, ob es Erkältungsviren waren, wie auch immer. Lungenentzündungen sind einfach, also es ist eine Lungenkrankheit, die einfach grundsätzlich den Körper in Mitleidenschaft zieht, wenn sie ausbricht. Das muss man wahrscheinlich dazu sagen. Zu den asymptomatischen Langzeitfolgen, also dass die Menschen asymptomatisch die Krankheit nicht bemerken und dann trotzdem Langzeitfolgen entwickeln, da bin ich auch mal sehr gespannt. Das habe ich jetzt mal von Lauterbach so ein bisschen gehört in so einem Tweet, aber Lauterbach ist halt auch Lauterbach. Das ist, muss ich wirklich sagen, ist nicht so vertrauenswürdig. Der Spiegel hat ja mal so einen Fact-Checking-Text mit Lauterbach-Tweets gemacht, der ja so ein bisschen aufgezeigt hat, dass Lauterbach wahrscheinlich selber nicht immer liest, was er da als Überschrift weiter zwittert und in deren Sicht sind asymptomatische Langzeitfolgen, also Langzeitfolgen trotz asymptomatischem Verlauf. Da bin ich mal gespannt, das sind ja auch Sachen, die muss man dann, da muss man denen auch mal Zeit geben.
Carl Lauterbach isst ja auch kein Salz, das macht mich immer ein bisschen skeptisch.
Ehrlich gesagt, das ist noch der Punkt, wo ich immer am meisten verstehe, denn ich esse auch kein extra Salz.
Salz ist genug drin, überall, das muss man nicht noch extra zufügen. Das hat er mal ausführlich erklärt.
Aber kein zusätzliches Salz, das fände ich so entscheidend. Gut, also wir haben jetzt gelernt, und zwar von Christian Drosten aus der größten Studie zur Tötlichkeit, für U45. Und das ist wirklich viel, das sind viele Menschen. Also wir reden hier nicht so, wir unterscheiden hier nicht zwischen einer Krankheit, die als Kinderkrankheit anders ist, als dann ab 18 oder so, sondern U45. Das ist nach statistischer Lebenserwartung mehr als das halbe Leben. Ist das Krankheit weniger als die Grippe, weniger tödlich als die Grippe. Bei U85 ist es allerdings wie Pocken im Mittelalter, hat er gesagt. Und wir haben keine Erfahrung mit einer Krankheit, bei der wir das so sagen können. Malaria, Durchfall, der ganze Kram. Da ist es im Grunde ein bisschen auch egal, ob man das jetzt als 30 und Abenteurer oder mit 60 nochmal kurz vor der Rente so macht, durchmacht. Das sind einfach gefährliche Krankheiten, aber dass wir hier so ein Auseinanderklappen der Gefährlichkeit haben, das ist neu und damit muss man sich aber jetzt auseinandersetzen. Denn wir haben politische Maßnahmen, die diese Altersgruppen auch ungleich treffen. Sagen wir es mal so. Es ist einfach, alte Menschen führen andere Leben als junge Menschen. So, alles in allem Sterblichkeit in Deutschland. Der vierte Clip hier von Drosten.
Wenn man das mal ganz klar anschaut, nach einer richtigen Datenauswertung für die USA, die haben ein sehr gutes Meldesystem, kann man sagen, die Influenza hat über einen mehrjährigen Zeitraum eine Infektionssterblichkeit von 0, 05 Prozent in den USA. Bei uns ist das übrigens etwas weniger. Und gleichzeitig nach dieser jetzt richtig gut gemachten Meta-Analyse hat Covid-19, also die SARS-2-Infektion, eine Infektionssterblichkeit von 0, 8 Prozent. Das ist also 16-mal so viel wie die Influenza. Für jeden Influencertoten gibt es 16 Covid-19-Tote in den USA. Jetzt ist aber die amerikanische Bevölkerung jünger als die deutsche. Das heißt, wir müssten in Deutschland mit einer Infektionssterblichkeit rechnen, die nach dieser Auswertung so an die 1 Prozent rangeht oder sogar knapp über 1 Prozent geht. Das habe ich nicht ausgerechnet, ich bin kein Demograph. Das kann ich nur überschlagen. Aber es wäre interessant, wenn das jemand ausrechnet, die Studie ist ja frei verfügbar.
Ja, er möchte die 0, 8 allgemeine Sterblichkeit aufrunden in Deutschland auf 1, auf 1 Prozent. Und ich würde sagen, ich bin jetzt auch kein Demograph, ich weiß auch nicht, was ein Demograph sein soll, aber das kommt ungefähr hin. Deutschland ist so ungefähr, diese 5, 6 Jahre älter als viele andere Länder, die wir so dieser westlichen Hemisphäre, jetzt Dänemark, Niederland oder so, Amerika. Da liegt halt wirklich eine kleine Altersklasse dazwischen und in deren Sicht kommt diese 1% hin, aber wahnsinnig ungleich verteilt. Also wenn bei U 80 einfach jeder Dritte daran stirbt. Und bei U 45 heißt es wie Grippe, das heißt U 20 nicht tödlich. Also das zwei Tote in neun Monaten bei einer Epidemie, also Nullimmunität und so weiter, das Ding graziert dann einfach. Das sind einfach wirklich beeindruckende Zahlen für eine Krankheit. Ich hätte das ja nie geglaubt, dass der menschliche Körper so unterschiedlich sein kann, dass eine Krankheit so unterschiedlich zugreift. Also das ist ja wirklich, muss man wirklich mal sagen, das ist auch wirklich beeindruckend, das mal so zu sehen, auch wenn man nicht genau weiß, wie es funktioniert. Aber wenn man Drostens Podcasts hört, weiß man ja, was so alles miteinander zusammenspielen muss, damit dieses oder jenes passiert. Naja, im Coronavirus Update 61, also etwas jünger als das 58, der wir eben gehört haben, war Stefan Kluge vom UKE, das ist ja so das Eppenheimer Universitätsklinikum in Hamburg. Das ist ja so dieses große, wo sie dann auch relativ früh dann aus dem Umkreis Hamburg die Patienten da hatten. Und hier wird auch noch mal zur Altersverteilung von Stefan Kluge, der leitet da, glaube ich, den ganzen klinischen Bereich gemacht.
Sehen Sie denn auf den Intensivstationen auch mehr jüngere Patienten?
Das ist klar altersabhängig. Wir sehen überwiegend Patienten ab 50, ab 60 mit deutlichen Vorerkrankungen. Wir sehen ganz selten mal Patienten unter 40. Das ist einfach eine statistische Frage, die gibt es. Kinder sind ja extrem selten betroffen. Da gibt es extrem wenige Fallberichte in Deutschland. Und so ist es einfach. Es gibt auch mal junge Patienten, die einen schweren Verlauf haben, aber es ist selten. Und das führt natürlich dazu, dass gerade die junge Bevölkerung leider sich nicht so an die Maßnahmen hält, die wir eigentlich alle durchführen sollten.
So, und jetzt haben wir einen zweiten Lockdown light, von dem wissen wir noch, wie der erste war. Und den müssen wir jetzt mal ein bisschen einschätzen. Denn zum einen Kikule, der selber immer sehr gewarnt hat, macht mal schnell die Schulen zu und so weiter. Also ein ganz großer Verfechter auch der Schulschließung. Der kam jetzt hier aktuell in seinem Podcast Corona-Kompass mit Kikule 112. Also diese Woche kam er noch mal drauf zurück und muss selber so ein bisschen die Lage nochmal neu einschätzen.
Und es ist ja völlig klar, dass Jugendliche ab 14, 15 ganz klare Treiber der Infektionen sind. Also in den Gymnasien und in Amerika, in den Highschools haben sie enorme Ausbrüche. Zum Teil sind dort natürlich auch die Regeln nicht eingehalten worden. Das heißt, es kann gut sein, dass wir eigentlich im Moment nur deshalb so wenig Ausbrüche sehen, weil sich eben die Gymnasiasten offensichtlich gut an diese Abstands- und Maskenregeln halten, weil die Schulen sich auch enorm Mühe gegeben haben, im Sommer Konzepte mit Lüftung und Ausdünnung auch der Schüler zu machen. Und wir wissen nicht, wie das jetzt im Winter weitergeht.
So, und jetzt hören wir nochmal eine zweite Einschätzung von ihm, wo er nochmal dieses Skepsis so ein bisschen hoch treibt. Und dann machen wir mal eine Einschätzung zur Schulschließung.
Ich glaube, dass wir im Moment in der Lage sind, dass da noch kein, also zumindest bei den Jüngeren und Grundschülern, noch kein Problem aufgetreten ist. Das ist überraschend. Da bin ich so ein bisschen, sage ich mal, misstrauisch, wenn ich das so sagen darf. Aber ich lasse mich dann im Lauf der Zeit auch gerne vom Gegenteil überzeugen. Ich glaube, so geht es auch vielen meiner Kollegen.
So, also er ist immer noch nicht überzeugt, dass das mit den Schulen kein Problem ist. Aber die Schulen sind ja jetzt zehn Wochen offen. Und wir haben jetzt gerade diesen rasanten Anstieg von neuen Corona-Fällen, der allerdings, wenn man zwei Wochen zurückrechnet oder so seinen Ursprung hat, in den Herbstferien stattfand. Also es kann sein, dass wir und wir wissen, Kinder ab zehn geben das Virus genauso weiter wie Erwachsene oder eben dann Asylsmatsch. Es werden nicht krank, aber sie geben es weiter, dieses chinesische Problem. Es könnte sein, dass die Schulöffnung und zwar unter diesen Hygienemaßnahmen, wenn auch belächelt, aber ich habe es jetzt bei meinen eigenen Kindern erlebt, Maskenpflicht in den weiterführenden Schulen, dauernde Lüftung, klares Konzept, wer macht wann Hofpause, wer darf sich mit wem sehen und so weiter, dass die Schulöffnung von den Sommerferien bis zu den Herbstferien zu einer Reduktion des Infektionsgeschehens geführt hat und die Ferien, die Herbstferien, also Kinder verreisen mit ihren Familien, sind in neuen sozialen Kontexten, im privaten Bereich, dass das der Auslöser jetzt für diese aktuellen Corona-Welle war. Weil die Herbstferien sind jetzt, also in Frankfurt sind jetzt seit einer Woche vorbei. Das heißt, die erste und die zweite Ferienwoche sind so irgendwie Ausgangspunkt für, das kann man ja überlegen. Also angenommen, die These haut so ein bisschen hin, dass wir einfach einen öffentlichen Bereich, aber den wir kontrolliert geöffnet haben, dass der die Pandemie dämpfte. Und danach kamen die Reisen in den Ferien, die es jetzt zu dem geführt haben, was wir jetzt haben. Und wir das Beherbergungsverbot, dass das eigentlich doch ganz schön richtig war. Nur, dass die Rentnerrepublik, die nämlich gerne reist, es gekippt hat.
Ich möchte daran erinnern, dass ich zu Beginn eines Podcasts hier mich, ich glaube, das war im August oder so, wütete gegen die Reisewütigen. Und du sagtest, na ja, aber die Leute haben ja auch hart gearbeitet. Und dann sagte ich, ne, ne, ne, ne, die schleppen das jetzt alles wieder rein und die werden sich auch in den Urlauben anders verhalten. Das ist ja vor allem, mir wurde ja zum Teil, als ich das dann getwittert habe, noch vorgeworfen, ja, ich würde so tun, als sei das Virus was Fremdländisches. Nein, aber es gibt ja Risikogebiete einfach. Und wenn man dort hinreißt, ist es gefährlicher als wenn man sagt, ich bleib daheim. Und deswegen habe ich das nie nachvollziehen können, auch aus volkswirtschaftlichen Gründen nicht, denn die Tourismusindustrie ist eh jetzt am Boden. Wenn Leute zu Hause Urlaub gemacht hätten, wäre das noch zehnmal besser gewesen für die jeweiligen Volkswirtschaften. Und niemand ist ja im August gereist, weil er sagte, ich will jetzt unbedingt den armen Griechen mein Geld bringen. So denken die Deutschen ja auch sonst nicht. Also sollen sie jetzt mal nicht so tun. Und ich halte das für ein großes Problem. Ich habe in der Bild-Zeitung gelesen, wenn das stimmen mag, dass Merkel auch in einer internen Konferenz wohl gesagt hat, dass mit den Reisen, das war doch ein großes Problem, dass wir das gemacht haben.
Also ich suche jetzt die Clips nicht raus, das wäre zu viel. Aber Merkel war eine ganz große Verfechterin des Reisens, weil sie mit diesem Michael Herrmann, ja, ja, sie hat mit diesem Michael Herrmann, der als Informatiker und so dieses Ganze, die, also Merkel orientiert sich ganz an diesen Modellrechnungen, deswegen auch ihr Kontakte reduzieren. Weil ihr ist der Einzelfall egal, sie guckt einfach auf alles, was, wie, wann kann ich, und dann wird einfach abgerechnet, wie viel Kontakte reduziert das, wie viel reduziert das, wie viel reduziert das und dann wird einfach aufsummiert. Und dieses Reisen war für sie eins der ganz wichtigen Punkte. Da haben alle schon, da sind alle schon eingeknickt vor der Öffentlichkeit, also Söder und so weiter. Das ist jetzt nicht das Wichtigste mit dem Reisen und so, Beherbergungsverbot, weil es war super unpopulär und da hielt Merkel immer noch dran fest, dass sie da unzufrieden war mit der Konferenz, mit der Schaltkonferenz, weil die da alle eingeknickt sind vor der Öffentlichkeit. Aber man muss jetzt wirklich sich überlegen, zwischen Sommerferien und Herbstferien, in diesen acht Wochen, sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn Wochen, je nach Bundesland, gab es kein nennenswertes Infektionsgeschehen und plötzlich waren diese Herbstferien da. Und jetzt sehen wir gerade zwei Wochen nach diesen Herbstferien und jetzt haben wir dieses Infektionsgeschehen und diese Herbstferien, da kommt noch mal dazu, das ist dann nicht nur Reisen, sondern das ist dann auch noch Reisen, Indoor, es ist herbstlich und so weiter, man kehrt dann doch schneller mal ein.
Es ist auch nicht nur Reisen, also viele Leute, ich bin glaube ich mein ganzes Leben in der Schule nie in den Herbstferien verreist, die meisten Leute sind ja einfach zu Hause und dann treffen sich Schüler in größeren Gruppen, so haben wir das gemacht, irgendwo jemand hat ein Gartenhäuschen und dann wird die Nacht durchgemacht, solche Dinge, die finden dann eben statt. Das heißt, das ist eigentlich ein sehr schönes Argument, was dann noch zu verifizieren ist, am Ende, aber was doch sehr einleuchtend ist von dir zu sagen, diese Schulen haben, die Schulöffnungen haben eigentlich dafür gesorgt, dass es relativ niedrig bleibt und da wundere ich mich auch immer sehr über unsere sehr verehrten Kollegen auf Twitter, die ja grundsätzlich, also die ja eine Lust daran haben, alles lahm zu legen, dass man meint, es geht denen noch irgendwie um was ganz anderes. Also ich glaube, das ist deren Spiritualität, dass sie das großartig finden. Wenn die Welt sich nicht mehr drehen würde, wäre das nicht schön, wenn wir den ganzen Tag dann nur noch auf Twitter uns in den Armen liegen. Und die sind ja eben auch Leute, die solche Argumentationen kaum noch nachvollziehen können und dann immer sagen, nein, alle Schulen dicht und alles dicht und dann ist auch alles gut. Und da frage ich mich schon bei diesen Twitter-Leuten, kennen die eigentlich andere Menschen? Wissen die, dass junge Leute sich auch außerhalb einer Schule treffen können? Sogar viel besser. Und dass das eigentlich auch ganz schön ist, wenn man mal nicht in die Schule muss. Wissen die nicht, warum? Also ich weiß nicht, ob wir noch zu dieser wirtschaftlichen Frage kommen. Sonst würde ich das mal gerade hier vorweg nehmen. Mich stört sehr, dass man jetzt immer so sagt, ja, wir können das nicht alles tun, um die Wirtschaft zu retten. Und es wird so getan, als sei die Wirtschaft irgendwie sowas von uns vollkommen losgekoppeltes, das irgendwie gerettet wird. Und dafür macht man das jetzt alles. Aber was habe ich denn davon? Und dann wird auch so getan, als sei das nur für die, die jetzt die Großkapitalisten sind, oder wie man sie nennen möchte, schlimm, wenn irgendein Lockdown kommt. Aber erst mal ignoriert man damit vollkommen, dass es kleinere, mittlere Betriebe zuhauf in Deutschland gibt. Diese ganzen Zweige jetzt mit der Gastronomie, die wieder erheblich eingeschränkt werden, sind auch ganz stark in der Hand von Eigentümern und die haben zwei, drei Mitarbeiter. Und man muss jetzt auch mal sich davon losmachen, dass man glaubt, dass das jetzt alles so wunderbar sei, denn ich glaube, man hat so ein bisschen die Illusion, jetzt erproben wir mal das, was wir dann später nochmal wirtschaftspolitisch machen mit dem Klimawandel. Dabei muss man einfach folgendes mal feststellen. Es ist doch keineswegs so, wenn jetzt so ein Lockdown leid in Kraft tritt, wie das am Montag der Fall sein soll, dass wir dann eine ökologischere Wirtschaft deshalb bekommen. Es ist ja nicht so, es wird gerade so getan, als würde die Mehrheit der Deutschen in Betrieben arbeiten, die entweder Kohle abbauen oder Stahl produzieren. Die meisten Menschen sind Friseure, sind Kellner, sind Kindergärtner, sind vielleicht Zahntechniker, verkaufen Mode und und und. Und dann muss man sich auch mal fragen, was das bedeutet, wenn jetzt immer so gelacht wird über Wirtschaftswachstum oder so. Was es denn bedeutet, wenn man Wohlstandseinbußen hat dadurch, dass die Wirtschaft jetzt gerade nicht so läuft, wie sie läuft. Das bedeutet ja nicht, dass wenn ich ein bisschen mehr Geld verdiene oder so viel verdiene, wie ich halt immer verdiene, dass ich dann sage, toll, dann kaufe ich mir noch ein SUV und kaufe mir drei iPhones. Ja, diese Auswüchse gibt es und die kritisieren wir ja auch hier häufig und da sind wir immer dabei und das ist auch richtig. Aber jetzt, wenn wir doch mal von uns ausgehen und von unseren Bekanntenkreisen ausgehen, dann heißt das doch einfach, wenn ich 200, 300 Euro mehr an der Tasche im Monat habe oder weniger habe, dann ist das eine Auswirkung auf mein direktes Freizeitleben, das so aussieht, wenn ich 200 Euro mehr habe, dann gehe ich vielleicht mal zu Kosmetikerin, ich gehe vielleicht in ein Restaurant, ich kaufe mir eine bessere Flasche Wein, ich gehe mit den Kindern in den Zoo und sogar noch am Wochenende dann in den Freizeitpark oder ich glaube, das hast du kürzlich gemacht, Besucheburg, Elz, das kostet alles Geld und das sind alles Dinge, die man reduziert, sobald man ein bisschen weniger Geld im Portemonnaie hat und sobald man Angst haben muss, dass man vielleicht bald noch weniger hat und wer es ist, wenn noch irgendwas anfällt, eine große Reparatur, Waschmaschine kaputt, Heizung kaputt und so weiter. Es ist ja keineswegs so, als seien alle Leute, sobald sie ein bisschen was von einer prosperierenden Wirtschaft im Portemonnaie abbekommen, hingehen und sagen so und jetzt gucke ich mal, was könnte ich am besonders schädlichsten für die Umwelt anschaffen, um damit einmal wieder zu zeigen, wie Wohlstandverwahrlost wir sind, sondern diese kleinen Luxuriäten, die man sich gönnt, die wären eigentlich ein positives Wachstum, denn ganz häufig wächst durch diese kleinen luxuriösen Annehmlichkeiten der Dienstleistungssektor, der quasi Green Growth macht. Wenn ich sage, ich gehe jetzt alle drei Wochen zum Friseur, wenn jemand sagt, ich lasse mir eine Thai-Massage geben und und und, dann ist das nicht umweltschädlich. Das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Das wäre eigentlich ein zu förderndes Wachstum.
Ja, es sind sehr viele Leute immer überrascht, wenn sie dann so Drosten hören, wie er sagt, also für die Hälfte, mehr als die Hälfte der Menschen ist im Grunde Covid wie eine Grippe. Dann zuckt man so zusammen, weil man ja auf Twitter schon ganz anderes gelesen hat und man hat ja auch schon andere dafür kritisiert, dass sie sagen, das ist wie eine Grippe. Und wenn sie dann plötzlich dann doch mal so ein Edenhofer Interview hören, wie er sagt, ne, wir müssen das mit wirtschaftlichen Logiken machen und ja, wir brauchen dafür Wachstum, nur halt anderes Wachstum und nicht einfach nur alles über Verbote runter regeln. Nein, das muss halt alles geregelt und politisch gemacht werden. Während sich volle Zustimmung von meiner Seite und wir kehren zurück zu diesem Argument, denn das war nun gestern in dieser Pressekonferenz, diesem Gegenentwurf, so wurde es ja auch aufgezogen von Strick und Schmidt-Ranassi, weißt du, was er heißt? Was wäre, wenn wir Corona erstens mal ernst nehmen und sagen, das geht nicht 2021 weg, selbst wenn wir Impfung haben. Die Situation, dass wir sagen können, wer Corona hat, ist selbst schuld, weil er hat sich ja nicht geimpft. Davon sind wir noch ganz weit entfernt. Also, dass wir einen sicheren Impfstoff haben, der so verfügbar ist, dass wir wirklich sagen können, du warst auf einer Großveranstaltung als Covid selber schuld, sondern wir müssen jetzt mit Corona leben lernen, 22 bis 2023, keine Ahnung. Das sind jetzt wirklich keine Dekadenprojekte, aber zumindest auch keine Monats- oder Wochenprojekte. Und sollten wir nicht so schnell wie möglich einen Alltag mit Corona leben lernen, anstatt jetzt immer Hammer und the Dance, wo wir doch wissen, auf R kommt es gar nicht so sehr an, sondern es kommt eher auf dieses K an, auf das Cluster. Da hat der Streg immer wieder darauf hingewiesen und Zainab Tufetci hat jetzt diesen Text geschrieben und Drosten weist auch immer wieder darauf hin, 80 Prozent der Infektionen gehen von 20 Prozent der Infizierten aus, also dieser ganze Cluster, dieses Clustermoment. Und sollten wir nicht ein soziales Leben ermöglichen, in dem man sich begegnet, aber Cluster ausgeschlossen werden. Und ich finde, die Schule ist ein herausragendes Beispiel dafür, wie es gelingt, tausende Leute in ein Gebäude zu bringen, ohne dass es dort zu Clusterinfektionen kommt. Und das hat die Schule nach den Sommerferien ganz wunderbar gezeigt. Und dann kamen irgendwie diese Herbstferien und jetzt ist plötzlich, ja, jetzt geht es so ab. Also da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht. Und in deren Sicht, auch weil ich zum Beispiel finde, dass Kinder sehr gerne in die Schule gehen zum einen und da auch gut aufgehoben sind, also da haben auch Eltern und Kinder was davon. Nämlich gerade nach der Erfahrung, drei Monate ist es mal anders, hat Wieler hier am 22. also jetzt vor einer Woche, auch noch mal darauf hingewiesen in seiner eigenen Pressekonferenz.
Ich weiß nur eins, wir haben ja schon mehrere hundert Ausbrüche in Schulen gesehen. Wir wissen, dass es Ausbrüche in Schulen gibt. Wir wissen, dass die Schulen nicht, im Gegensatz zur Influenza, da sind die Schulen wirklich ein richtiger Treiber von den Influenza-Wäldern. Oder auch wenn es eine Pandemie gäbe, da sind die Schulkinder wirklich Treiber von dieser Pandemie. Das ist bei der Covid-19-Erkrankung nicht der Fall. Aber es ist natürlich klar, je mehr Menschen sich in Deutschland infizieren, desto größer ist natürlich auch die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Infektionen auch in Schulen auftreten. Und deshalb sind die Empfehlungen aus unserer Sicht sehr wichtig einzuhalten.
Also wenn in Schulen Infektionen auftreten, werden sie von außen hier reingetragen. Das kann man nicht ausschließen, wenn so viele infiziert sind. Aber sie sind nicht der Treiber. Und in deren Sicht fand ich es dann doch überraschend. Manchmal sieht man ja so ein bisschen Fehlerkultur, die einem dann doch fremdfalls vorkommt. Aber Laschet hier bei Anne Will, muss ich sagen Respekt.
Nun halten in Nordrhein-Westfalen eine Menge Menschen die Luft an. Wenn Herr Müller sagt, man kann gar nichts ausschließen, Kitas und Schulen könnten gegebenenfalls auch noch mal geschlossen werden müssen, was sagen Sie?
Wir tun alles, dass das nicht so kommt. Und wir haben die Lehre vom März, dass es ein Fehler war, bei Schulen und Kitas zu beginnen. Und wir jetzt alles tun müssen in allen anderen Lebensbereichen, insbesondere in Freizeitbereichen, die zunächst in den Blick zu nehmen und Schulen, Kitas und wirtschaftliches Leben möglichst unberührt zu lassen.
Es war ein Fehler, hat er gesagt, im März bei den Schulen anzufangen. Daraus hat man jetzt gelernt, man dreht es jetzt um. Schulen sind das Letzte, wenn überhaupt geschlossen wird, sondern man macht jetzt diese anderen Freizeiteinrichtungen. Und ich finde es immer wieder amüsierend, mir diesen Clip anzuhören, den wir jetzt hören, den habe ich schon ein paar Mal gehört. Wie kam es eigentlich zu diesen Schulschließungen im März? Man hat halt so die Legende, da gibt es Berater, die machen das dann irgendwie und die sagen dann so, ja, das könnt ihr machen und das wäre gut. Und Drosten selbst hat das hier mal erklärt.
Man muss regional schauen, zu der Zeit, 12. März, da waren gerade in Heinsberg die Schulen geschlossen worden. Und da haben wir gesagt, das ist eigentlich genau das richtige Vorgehen. Da, wo man jetzt aktuell merkt, dass Infektionsgeschehen ist, da kann man so etwas auch machen, ohne dass wir genau wissen, was die Schulen beitragen, mal vorsorglich die Schulen schließen. Danach sind wir rausgegangen aus der Sitzung. Und die Politik hat daraus einen deutschlandweiten Schulschluss gemacht, wo eine Senatskanzlei nach der anderen, oder Staatskanzlei in den Bundesländern, jeweils dieselbe synchrone Entscheidung getroffen hat. Und da war dann der deutschlandweite Schulschluss da. Und das wurde dann am Ende den Wissenschaftlern zugeschrieben, was nicht stimmt.
Also die machen diese Beratung, kriegen dann die Frage, den Heinzberg haben die jetzt auch die Schulen geschlossen. Keine schlechte Idee. Okay, ciao, mein Taxi fährt. So, dann kommen die raus, fahren nach Hause und stellen zu Hause fest, die, die wir gerade noch beraten haben, die haben jetzt die Schulen geschlossen. Weil wir sagten, eigentlich keine schlechte Idee, das einen Heinzberg zu machen, das einen Heinzberg zu machen. Also das ist wirklich, so wurde Politik gemacht. Jetzt kann man sich überlegen, die erste Welle, was war unsere Erfahrung, unglaubliche Todeswerte, unglaubliche Infektionswerte unter den Älteren. Also das ist ja, also die Altersverteilung ist ja, da liegen ja 20 Jahre dazwischen, zwischen dem Durchschnittsalter der Infizierten, zwischen heute und damals. Es waren diese Karnevalsveranstaltungen, diese ganzen alten Leute und so weiter. Und da finde ich wieder gut, wenn man dann doch mal jetzt so ein bisschen Fehlerkultur hört. In dem Fall ist jetzt wieder ein Ministerpräsident, Rammelow.
Wir haben uns angeguckt, was wir bei uns an Infektionsgeschehen hatten. Ich habe zum Beispiel feststellen müssen, sieben Dialysepraxen waren infektiös. Siebenmal in Dialysepraxen, wo es eigentlich gar nicht passieren dürfte. Also wo man einfach denkt, das kann doch nicht sein. 15 Mal in Krankenhäusern haben wir die Situation gehabt. Ich habe jetzt wieder aktuell im Lage-Meldung einen Krankenhaus gehabt, da ist ein Patient drei Tage lang behandelt worden, ohne dass er erkannt worden ist, dass er nicht nur infektiös ist, sondern dass er ansteckend ist.
Also nicht nur infiziert, sondern auch ansteckend. Ramelow hat das jetzt im Oktober, hat er von seinen Beratern da den Hinweis bekommen, da wurde wieder einer behandelt, ohne jedes Hygienekonzept. Und da muss man jetzt wirklich mal gegenüberstellen. Schulen, und ich habe hier selber erlebt, wie angstvoll sie hier eröffnet haben. Die Schulen haben sich selber entschieden, ohne Anweisungen. Wir machen hier rund um die Uhr Maskenpflicht, Unterricht mit Maske. Dann kamen die Eltern, haben dagegen geklagt, bis die Stadt sich dann mal entschied, okay, wir ordnen das jetzt mal an, damit die Klagen bei uns münden und nicht noch die Schulleitung sich damit auseinandersetzen muss. Und die Maskenpflicht, die am Anfang, zuerst nur die ersten zwei Wochen nach den Sommerferien hieß, wurde durchgezogen bis jetzt. Und wir haben kein großes Infektionsgeschehen in Schulen. Und wir haben diesen Gesundheitsbereich, wo die alten Leute zusammenkommen, wo Ramelow jetzt noch die Hinweise bekommt, ja, da lag jemand drei Tage auf Stationen und keiner hat das mitgekriegt, dass der da wirklich dann supersplattermäßig über Tage die Menschen da gefährdet hat. Also in der Ansicht ist das wirklich dramatisch, wie zum einen wirksam funktionierende Hygienekonzepte sind, beispielsweise bei uns in Schulen, wie wenig Obacht da auf dem Gesundheitssektor liegt, was könnte Hygienik, also große Unikliniken, klar, die sind abgeriegelt, da gibt es Schnelltests und so weiter, aber so der allgemeine etwas niedergestapfelte medizinische Bereich, wo man mal so hingeht, weil man ein Problem hat, da scheint da irgendwie noch ein bisschen problematisch zu sein. Und man muss, glaube ich, jetzt für den zweiten Lockdown wirklich mal darauf hinweisen, der private Bereich, da kann man das alles nicht regeln. Also den Erfolg der Hygienekonzepte, die wir hatten, die kriegt man in die privaten Bereiche nicht rein. Der Schmidt-Ranassit verweist immer wieder auf Israel, wo eben nicht der Staat durchgesetzt hat, also es ist nicht das Militär nach Hause gefahren, sondern hat man sich die Communities angeguckt, insbesondere bei den Religiösen. Und dann hat man mit dem Chefideologen dort gesprochen, hat gesagt, hör mal zu, es geht ja um die Sicherheit deiner Gemeinde, du musst das jetzt vermitteln. Und dann hat man die Leute aus der Zivilgesellschaft eingebunden, hat sie informiert, mit ihnen das Briefing gemacht, sie gelehrt, wie das geht. Und dann hat man also richtiges Organizing, richtiges Community-Management gemacht. Und dann, gekoppelt mit einem Lockdown, auch tatsächlich die Infektion von 9.000 auf 900 Infektionen am Tag runtergebracht. Also in der Ansicht, Lockdowns ganz kritisch zu beobachten, wie auch Julian Nieder-Rühmeli hier bei Anne Will noch mal sagte.
Die Menschen haben sich ganz sicher vorsichtiger verhalten. Und das gehört auch zur ganzen Wahrheit. Wahrheit gehört in die Demokratie, wie Sie wissen. Dafür werbe ich immer wieder. Man muss sich mit Fakten auseinandersetzen, auch wenn es manchmal schwierig ist. Es blieb dann während des Lockdowns knapp unter eins. Schwankte, rutschte mal ein bisschen drüber, blieb drunter im Prinzip. Sank nicht mehr wesentlich ab.
Schauen Sie sich die Zahlen an.
Und als der Lockdown zu Ende war, ging es nicht durch die Decke. Es gab noch mal die Tönnies-Geschichte und so, aber das war ein kleiner Ausrutscher. Das heißt, nach Lage der Dinge, das muss man unbedingt auch sehen, war der Lockdown selbst gar nicht das Entscheidende, sondern offenbar ist entscheidend, wie sich die Leute unter welchen Bedingungen verhalten. Schauen Sie mal die internationalen Vergleiche an. Peru hat einen harten Lockdown. Brasilien hat großes Chaos. Die Todeszahlen sind in Peru höher als in Brasilien. Selbst auch das gehört zur Wahrheit. Selbst das schrecklich gemanagte Corona-Krise in den USA führt zu vielen unnötigen Todesfällen. Wenn sie das auf eine Million runterbrechen, hat Spanien mit einem massiven Lockdown mehr Todesfälle. Ich will das gar nicht weiter ausführen. Vorsicht, Lockdown ist nicht das Allheilmittel. Das Allheilmittel ist, dass wir Maßnahmen haben, die gut begründet sind. Das knöpfe ich gerne an an Ihrem Argument. Wir verwechseln immer Maßnahmen und Kriterien. Die Kriterien müssen nachvollziehbar sein. Die Kriterien gehören in Gesetze gefasst. Und die Maßnahmen werden dann entschieden aufgrund dieser Kriterien, die in den Parlamenten beraten werden müssen.
Als im Februar es ein Schreiben an Jens Spahn gab, man sollte doch mal Masken vorsorgen, hat ja Spahn das Ganze verschlafen. Das darf man, glaube ich, so sagen.
Hat er auch eingestanden.
Dann hat man lange Zeit rumdiskutiert, sind Masken überhaupt hilfreich? Da haben dann auch die Bedenkenträger, die jeden Abend bei Markus Lanz sitzen, sagt, um Gottes Willen, wenn man die Maske dann falsch abnimmt und so, das wird hochinfektiös sein und so weiter. Irgendwann hat man dann auch Erkenntnisse gehabt, dass das nicht so ist, sondern dass diese Masken sehr hilfreich sind. Nun fehlten aber die Masken. Dann kam man auf die Idee, die Leute sollen sich mal selbst Masken basteln. Dann gab es diese Kampagne von prominenten Influencern und so weiter. Hashtag Maske auf. Da wurde dann gezeigt, wie man aus Unterhosen und sonst was sich Masken bauen kann. Dann kam auch sehr bald mit der Lockerung des Lockdowns dann eine Maskenpflicht. Man hat aber dann nicht dafür gesorgt, dass man die zweite Welle ernst nimmt, vor der man aber immer wieder gewarnt hat, Achtung, die zweite Welle, Achtung, die zweite Welle, dass man so viele Masken importiert und vor allem auch im Land dann vielleicht produzieren lässt, um einmal die Menschen mit vernünftigen Masken auszustatten und nicht nur mit diesem Notbehelf, das ja entstanden ist deshalb, weil nicht genug Masken vorgehalten worden. Und das ist ein bisschen traurig, das Ganze, denn ich habe als das anfing, mit diesem Hashtag Maske aufgedacht, eigentlich ganz schön die Idee, aber Vorsicht, denn mit solchen Maßnahmen hilft man zwar den Menschen, aber man entlastet auch immer die Regierung. Es ist ein bisschen wie mit den Tafeln. Man produziert Hartz IV von Regierungsseite und dann hilft irgendjemand mit den Tafeln, die Menschen irgendwie über die Runden zu kommen. Das sorgt aber dafür, dass die Regierung entlastet wird und sagt, nö, klappt ja alles mit dem Hartz IV. Und hin und wieder bekommen dann die Mitarbeiter der Tafeln den Orden überreicht. Und genauso ist das auch bei so was wie Maske auf. Man findet das dann ganz toll, entlastet damit die Regierung und die legt dann die Hände in den Schoß. Das ist im Prinzip auch das, was Helmut Kohl in den 80er-Jahren schon forciert hatte unter dem Begriff Subsidiaritätsprinzip. Das war ja etwas, was er wollte. Er sagte, der Sozialstaat wird ja immer größer und so mächtig und bürokratisch und alles. Das soll doch lieber mal wieder zu den Bürgern zurückgehen. Und das passiert dann. Und das sorgt aber dafür, dass der Sozialstaat immer schmähler gemacht wird oder dass man jetzt keine Masken hat. FFP2-Masken, was haben die gekostet, als es noch kein Corona gab, vor einem Jahr? 25 Cent, 30 Cent das Stück, wahrscheinlich noch viel weniger, wenn wir von Großpackungen ausgehen.
Hast du gelesen, was meine gekostet hat?
Du hast es getwittert, du hast 8, 50 Euro bezahlt. Ich habe für die FFP2-Masken trage ich nur, habe 3 Euro das Stück bezahlt, habe aber auch dafür 20 dann genommen, damit ich dann mal welche habe. Und das ist natürlich jetzt ein gutes Geschäft gewesen, wenn ich sehe, was du jetzt zwei Wochen später dafür gezahlt hast. Das heißt, das müsste alles überhaupt nicht sein. Das hätte man jetzt regeln können, dass Masken zuhauf vorhanden sind. Ich würde sogar so weit gehen, dass die eigentlich gratis für alle da sein müssen. Denn das hat Kekole ja auch im Podcast gesagt, diese FFP2-Masken helfen sehr stark. Er würde sonst auch, glaube ich, gar nicht in einen Einkaufscenter oder so reingehen. Und gerade diese Risikogruppen oder ich kenne ja auch Leute, die täglich diese Maske bräuchten, aber sagen ja 3 Euro und wir sind eine Familie. Und wir können ja nicht 180, 200 Euro für Masken ausgeben. Was machen eigentlich Hartz-IV-Empfänger? Die müssen immer noch mit ihren Lappen rumhängen und können sich noch nicht mal diese normalen Masken leisten, diese OP-Masken, denn auch die sind unverschämt teuer. Das ist also wirklich, muss man sagen, ein Regierungsversagen. Anders ist das gar nicht zu nennen, denn man hatte jetzt sieben Monate Zeit. Es kann jetzt niemand mehr sagen, oh, wir konnten nicht diese Masken produzieren. Und hinzu kommt auch, dass man, und das ist ja eigentlich Zivilisation. Zivilisation heißt ja nicht, dass sich alle einmümmeln, sondern dass man, wenn es regnet, Regenschirme aufspannt und auch dafür sorgt, dass es Regenschirme gibt. Und dasselbe ist ja auch bei diesen Luftreinigern. Das hattest du vor vielen, vielen Wochen schon gepostet, dass diese Luftreiniger ganz gut sind. Warum hat man das nicht subventioniert? Ich habe gestern noch im Brennpunkt bei der ARD einen Fitnessstudio-Betreiber gesehen. Der sagt, der hat für ein Stück 350 Euro 10 solche Luftreiniger gekauft für sein Fitnessstudio. Und jetzt muss er trotzdem dicht machen, obwohl er damit wirklich mal was für die Hygiene getan hat. Und wahrscheinlich machen die Leute jetzt in ihren ganz anderen Sport wohl eben keine Luftreiniger stehen. Und dann kommt noch das Dritte, was ich noch anfügen will, wo man es noch mal sehen kann, was man hätte auch durchsetzen können. Auch dafür hatte man Zeit, diese Schnelltests, die in China ja gemacht werden. Ich habe das kürzlich in einem Taz-Artikel gelesen. In Qingdao gab es 19 Fälle. Das ist eine Stadt mit 9 Millionen Einwohnern. Was hat man gemacht? Alle 9 Millionen Einwohner wurden schnell getestet. Da werden immer so Pakete geschnürt. Man testet immer 10 zusammen und dann guckt man, wenn das irgendwie noch auftaucht, dann geht man noch mal da rein. Aber so kann man das eben ruckzuck machen. In 5-6 Tagen war alles getestet und dann hat man das Ganze eingedämmt und kann sehen, wie man dann weiter verfährt. Auch das ist, glaube ich, was du schon im Mai, im April, glaube ich, schon hier über Schnelltests geredet. Das ist einfach so was von ärgerlich. Und da kann man jetzt auch mir nicht mit dem Argument kommen, ja, China ist auch ein Überwachungsstaat. Also hier geht es immer nur um Schnelltests. Ich möchte nicht, dass hier bei der Polizei mir die Tür vernagelt, dass ich nicht mehr rauskomme oder so. Das möchte ich auf keinen Fall. Aber dass Schnelltests auf den Weg gebracht werden, das hat jetzt nichts mit Überwachungsstaat zu tun. Das ist einfach ein vernünftiges politisches Plan.
Ja, Schnelltests kommen von den gleichen Herstellenden wie die PCR-Tests und die sind nicht so lukrativ. So deutlich muss man sagen. Das ist ein Milliardengeschäft gewesen, 2020 diese PCR-Tests zu machen. Im April oder Anfang Mai haben die hier in Frankfurt der Bull-Blutspender-Dienst und die Web-Konferenz. und Uniklinikums-Bereichswesen haben das Pooling für Corona-PCR-Tests entwickelt, also 10 Proben in ein, so dass man richtig screenen kann. Wenn eine positiv ist, kann man es immer noch auflösen, aber wenn man die Erwartungen hat, die sind eigentlich alle negativ, dann kann man durchaus 10 Proben in einen Durchlauf schicken. Dieses Verfahren war nach drei Monaten immer noch nicht in Deutschland zugelassen, weil es hier so ein Fetischismus ist, dass wir nur beste Qualität machen, jeder PCR-Test muss superqualitativ hochwertig sein. Und diese Schnelltests sind ein bisschen weniger sensibel, aber sortieren damit die hochinfektiösen zuverlässige sogar noch aus. Nein, hat man alles bis heute nicht gemacht, das ist ein großes Rätsel. Und das mit den Masken ist das größte Ärgernis überhaupt. Denn der Kekole hat es auch noch mal verglichen. Es gibt zwei Verteidigungsstrategien. Der Staat kann entweder hohe Mauern bauen, Panzer aufstellen, Armee bezahlen, Kampftronen, Kampftronen, alles machen. Nur die Bedrohung ist ja eine andere. Die Bedrohung kommt über die Luft und die Luft, die aus uns ausströmt. Und die kleine Papiermaske kann das alles wettmachen. Die ganzen anderen staatlichen Maßnahmen. Der Schmidt-Tranassi hat gestern in der Pressekonferenz immer wieder darauf hingewiesen, die AH plus L-Regeln, also Atemschutz, Abstand, Hygiene, allgemeine Hygiene und Lüften, reicht bei Corona, insbesondere, weil wir dieses Super-Spreading-80-20-Phänomen da wieder haben, das Kirkole auch das auch Drosten immer wieder betont. Wenn diese Maßnahmen nicht reichen, muss man nachsteuern innerhalb dieser Maßnahmen. Und dazu gehört beispielsweise Schnelltests an allen Pflegeeinrichtungen und in allen medizinischen Gebäuden, sodass alle, die da rein und raus gehen, getestet werden. Und Masken, FFP2-Masken müssen für alle Menschen kostenlos sein. Das kostet Geld, aber das kostet sehr, sehr, sehr viel weniger als ein Nachtragshaushalt, der 200 Milliarden Euro übersteigt. Und das ist einfach grandios, dass das nicht gemacht wird, sondern wir tatsächlich eine politische Klasse haben. Und das muss man sagen, die flächendeckend, die uns Bürgern die Schuld geben, es nicht richtig hinzukriegen. Und die jetzt nochmal, und das stelle ich als These in den Raum, die jetzt nochmal den öffentlichen Bereich, der die letzten Monate auch aus ökonomischen Ansinnen, Hygienekonzepte, entwickelte und erprobte, stillgelegt wird, damit das wieder mehr ins Private verlagert wird. Das ist für mich eher so ein Projekt, wir weisen Schuld zu, als wir lösen hier ein Problem. Denn jetzt ist klar, nach so einem Lockdown im November ist klar, das ist im privaten Bereich passiert, wir waren alle selber schuld. Obwohl die öffentliche Antwort eigentlich, und die politische und die öffentliche Antwort eigentlich da war. Und das ist hochdramatisch.
Das ist schon so eine Subjektivierung, wie sie im Neoliberalismus eben gern vorgenommen wird, diese selbst in die Schuld schieben. Und ich finde das erstaunlich, dass das auch nicht breiter aufgegriffen wurde mit diesen Gratis-Masken. Also gerade von diesen ganzen Masken auf Aktivisten, man hat so fast den Eindruck, ja wir haben jetzt mal durch diese Initiative wieder uns gegenseitig Follower zugespielt. Und auch jetzt so eine radikale Forderung, kostenlose FFP2-Masken und so. Am Ende bekomme ich dann gar nicht noch ein Bundesverdienstkreuz umgehängt im Bellevue. Lassen wir mal lieber.
Genau, da lässt man über die Hände davon. Und Drosten, der jetzt an diesem Lockdown nicht groß beteiligt war an diesen Empfehlungen, der weist zumindest noch mal darauf hin, man könnte ja zumindest die Zeit nutzen.
So ein zeitlich befristeter Circuit-Breaker-Lockdown, der ist dann besonders effizient, wenn man die Zeit, die man verbringt in so einem Lockdown, dann dafür nutzt, gerade auf der politischen Ebene noch mal wieder bestimmte Regularien zu überprüfen, über die wir jetzt vorhin auch gerade schon geredet haben. Genau, für die Fallverfolgung. Wenn man jetzt sagen würde, man macht so etwas, man macht so eine Intervention, so ein Circuit-Breaker, dann sollte man sich unbedingt auch vornehmen, dass man, weil man die Fallverfolgung nicht mehr bewerkstelligen konnte, das war der Grund für den Eintritt in einen Circuit-Breaker, dass man da so nicht wieder herauskommen will, sondern dass man am Ausgang dieses Circuit-Breaker-Lockdowns vielleicht noch mal bestimmte Maßgaben für den öffentlichen Dienst geschaffen und geändert hat, die dann dazu führen könnten, dass man die Fallverfolgung viel länger durchhalten kann oder anders bewerkstelligt. Da wäre beispielsweise ein verstärkter Fokus auf das rückblickende Clustertracing angesagt. Was heißt angesagt? Das ist mein persönlicher Vorschlag.
Ich habe nichts gehört davon, dass Lockdown auch mal genutzt werden soll. Beispielsweise die App ein bisschen besser zu machen. Dass wir noch mal eine besondere Schulung bekommen, mit diesem Cluster-Tagebuch oder sonst irgendwas. Wir machen jetzt mal einen Lockdown, damit zu Weihnachten die Zahlen unten sind und wir alle zur Familie fahren können. Wo ich mich frage, ehrlich, ist das die Erklärung? Kann man zum einen mal nachfragen, wer würde denn wirklich sechs Wochen Alltag eintauschen gegen ein Wochenende Familie? Also wer wäre dafür bereit? Oder sollte man ja nicht einfach Weihnachten anders feiern? Auf der anderen Seite, wenn dann die Zahlen unten sind, hoffentlich Ende November, fährt man dann fröhlich in die Weihnachtsferien und denkt, cool, wir haben jetzt einen Puffer von 3000 Infektionen am Tag. Wir können uns mal ein bisschen darauf anlegen, oder was? Also was soll diese Idee, die uns da kommuniziert wurde, gestern sein?
Und am 3. Januar geht es dann wieder rund?
Genau, am 3. Januar ist dann wieder... Also Kikolä hatte es gestern mal so kurz gefasst.
Es ist nicht so einfach nur zu sagen, hey, wir machen jetzt mal Lockdown, dann ist alles wieder gut, sondern man muss jetzt viel differenzierter arbeiten, weil den gleichen Lockdown wie im Frühjahr wäre erstens sinnlos und zweitens könnten wir die nicht beliebig oft wiederholen natürlich.
Ja, beides richtig. Es wäre erst einmal sinnlos. Und wie oft will man das denn machen? Wir brauchen halt so einen Alltag, der uns über alle Jahreszeiten holt. Kann man zumindest das Virus ernst nehmen und sagen, wir machen mal eine altersspezifische Inzidenz, sodass man mal ein bisschen ein Lagebild hinsichtlich, wie geht es denn jetzt dem Gesundheitssystem? Drosten hat es vorgeschlagen.
Wenn man jetzt nur eine Abschätzung will von der Gefährlichkeit momentan, also wenn man die reinen Inzidenzzahlen mal anders bewerten will, dann könnte man auch sagen, man nimmt mal nur die Inzidenz bei den Älteren, weil man bei denen ja weiß, dass die Folge dann immer auch mehr Krankenhausaufnahmen und schwere Verläufe sind. Dann könnte man also sagen, Ü50-Inzidenz, also die Neuinfektion über 50, also bei über 50-Jährigen oder man kann auch sagen, Ü60, je nach Festlegung und Bevorzugung. Aber das war einfach mal so eine Grundidee. Die ist natürlich auch sehr einfach, weil diese Zahlen ja vorhanden sind. Das Robert-Koch-Institut hat eine alterspezifische Inzidenz. Die werden jetzt nicht jeden Tag in der Kurzfassung für die Öffentlichkeit ausgelesen. Sondern die muss man sich aus den Tabellen holen, in den Lage berichten. Aber das könnte man ganz schnell ändern. Und dann wäre diese ganze Diskussion eigentlich schon bedient.
So, aber das sowas macht man nicht, weil das widerspricht irgendwie so im Gleichheitsgrundsatz oder so was. Nee, das wäre ja blöd, wenn wir jetzt nur, weil die Alten so betroffen sind, die Alten besonders behandeln. Wir müssen alle gleich behandeln. Aber genau das machen sie nicht, denn in der Rentenrepublik, und da spielen wir jetzt nur diesen einen Clip, fällt es ein bisschen auseinander. Wir hören hier nochmal Fritz Kuhn, den habe ich auch schon mal im Fernsehpodcast gespielt, weil mich es so geärgert hat. Fritz Kuhn, der Bürgermeister von Stuttgart.
Es ist nicht so, dass die jungen Bürgerinnen und Bürger unserer Stadt aus der gesellschaftlichen Verantwortung sich rausnehmen können. Junge müssen auch den Generationenvertrag gelegentlich erfüllen, und der heißt, umsichtig und vorsichtig zu sein im Interesse derer, die vulnerabler sind, qua Alter oder anderen Umständen.
Es gilt jetzt auch mal, Dankbarkeit zu zeigen von den jungen Leuten, nachdem so viele schöne Dinge durch die Buma-Generation und die noch älteren passiert sind. Diese SUVs, die überall fahren, diese Eigenheiten, diese ganzen eingezäunten Gebiete, sollten jetzt wirklich die Jungen einmal dankbar sein. Mein Gott, Fritz Kuhn, das habe ich ewig nicht gesehen. Aber es ist auch wieder so interessant. Ich glaube, als Kind habe ich den schon gesehen. Da hat er aber auch schon so gesprochen.
Ganz virulent. Söder hat ja das Gleiche. Das Schutzversprechen der Jüngeren sollte dann auch mal kommen. Harald Wälzer hat sich dankenswerterweise im Radio dann hier geäußert.
Mehr Empathie, mehr Toleranz gegenüber Jüngeren sollen wir aufbringen, hat Kevin Kühner-Dricht.
Ja, ich glaube schon. Ich meine, in Krisensituationen fängt man ja immer damit an, nach Sündenbocken zu suchen und besonders nach solchen, die sich nicht wehren können. Und da bietet sich schon immer, wie es heißt, die Jugend von heute an, die sich dann, so hören wir, ein halben standardmäßig nicht an Regeln hält, ohne Unterlass, Partys feiert und überhaupt so radikal verantwortungslos ist, dass all die 60-plus Politikerinnen und Politiker von alt bis Steinmeier nun aber echt doll mahnende Worte sprechen müssen. Ich kann nur sagen, ich nutze ja öffentliche Verkehrsmittel, auch gerne den ICE. Und es scheint es mir durchaus sinnvoll, solche mahnenden Worte auch an dauertelefonierende Mitfünfziger ohne Maske zu richten. Nur mal so zum Beispiel, oder die gigafeierenden Großfamilien, die sich offenbar an Dreck um Regeln scheren. Und es gibt jede Menge gesellschaftliche Gruppen, die dazu beitragen, dass wir gegenwärtig diese Steigerungsraten haben.
Hier waren es auch keine 18. Geburtstage, die dazu geführt haben, sondern es waren Geburtstage von wesentlich älteren und Großhochzeiten.
Ganz genau. Und Tim Herden, der gerne kommentiert in den Tagesthemen, hat das mal auf diesen kleinen Länder gebracht.
Ich bin gegen das Beherbergungsverbot schon aus ganz persönlichen Gründen. Anfang November wollte ich an die Ostsee fahren. Das kann ich mir wahrscheinlich abschminken.
Ja, ehrlich. Sehr schön. Als ich heute Morgen beim Frühstück saß, hörte ich wie immer SWR 4. Das ist so ein Schlagersender. Aber da ist man wirklich nah bei den Leuten, wie wir hier in Rheinland-Pfalz sagen. Und dort gab es dann irgendein Quiz oder so. Und jedenfalls wurde eine Hörerin, eine offenbar schon ziemlich betagte Hörerin, ich vermute so Mitte 70 oder älter zugeschaltet. Und die wurde dann nach ihren Urlaubsplänen befragt für die kommenden Jahre, da sie ja doch so gerne Fernreisen mache. Und jetzt sei das ja alles auf der Kippe. Und dann meinte sie, dass sie jetzt schon hofft, dass es dann im nächsten Jahr wieder losgeht. Und sie fliege oft nach Mallorca und so. Aber Kreuzfahrten seien auch so schön. Und dann fragt die Moderatorin nochmal nach, ja, das ist dann gar nicht anstrengend. Da kann man ja dann nur entspannen. Und dann meinte sie ja doch, also es sei schon anstrengend, diese Landausflüge, die man dann hat, die seien schon ein bisschen anstrengend. Aber wenn man nur auf dem Kreuzfahrtschiff ist, das sei dann doch entspannend.
Okay, wir hören nochmal Harald Wälzer. Wir müssen uns alle mehr radikalisieren.
Welche Verantwortung tragen denn jetzt umgekehrt die älteren Generationen für die Jungen in dieser Krise?
Na, da kann man natürlich über vieles sprechen. Zum Beispiel darüber, dass eine völlig plan- und konzeptlose Bildungspolitik jetzt für die originelle Situation sorgt, dass Schülerinnen und Schüler nach den Herbstferien in Winterjacken in eiskalten Klassenräumen zu sitzen haben, wo der Unterricht sicher sehr erleichtert wird, wenn in der neuen Paradedisziplin, Lüftungsmanagement, ausgebildete Lehrer alle 20 Minuten die Fenster aufreißen. Oder dass wir eine Abi-Generation haben, die auf ihre Abi-Feiern genauso verzichten musste, wie habt ihr schon gesagt, wie auf die internationalen Austauschprogramme, genauso die Studis, für die die Erasmus-Programme jetzt ein No-Go sind. Dann wollen wir mal über die Berufsaussichten derjenigen sprechen, die in diesen Zeiten einen Schul- oder Hochschulabschluss machen. Oder die Studis, denen alle Jobmöglichkeiten weggebrochen sind und die nach Hause zurückziehen müssen, sich dann von saturierten älteren Leuten sagen zu lassen, sie seien nun aber echt verantwortungslos. Das ist schon stark von Leuten übrigens, und das ist ja die Frage, die sich ihrerseits lieber doch alle zwei Jahre einen neuen SUV kaufen, als in Sachen Klimawandel selber auch nur das kleinste Fizzeich in Verantwortung zu übernehmen.
Ja, also erhebliches rentenrepublikanisches Krawallpotenzial in diesem ganzen Thema Corona.
Ich bin auch sehr gespannt, wie das jetzt angenommen wird, diese Maßnahmen, inwieweit jetzt auch da der Jugendliche wieder zum Rebell wird, nicht nur in Sachen Klimaproteste oder so, sondern auch auf diese Weise. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Also man hat es selbst jetzt in der ARD gemerkt, die ja doch diese Corona-Maßnahmen, die bislang beschlossen wurden, in den Brennpunkten zumindest immer sehr, sehr wohlwollend begleitet hat, dass es jetzt im Brennpunkt gestern Abend doch ungewöhnlich viele sehr kritische Töne gab. Insofern wird das ein sehr spannender Monat. Ich bin gespannt, was wir dann so zu reden haben.
Genau. Zum Abschluss, wie vorhin schon, ich komme hier um ein Robert Habeck-Clip-Stück nicht zu rum.
Hast du eigentlich gesehen, dass Robert Habeck auch schon davor warnte, dass wir zu viel Geld ausgeben? Dann muss man mal sehen, wie man das mit dem Sozialstaat zusammenbekommt. Hat er ein Weltinterview gegeben. Dass wir zu viel Geld ausgeben? Ja, ich hatte erst gedacht, er sei Hans-Werner-Sinn, aber Robert Habeck.
Also, dass wir als Staat zu viel Geld ausgeben.
Ja, und wie das dann nachher mit Sozialen noch so zusammengehen wird am Ende. So kann man alles rechtfertigen, was man kürzt.
Aus der gleichen Veranstaltung wie vorhin, nämlich nach der Bundesvorstandssitzung der Partei am 19.10. also lange vorm Lockdown, der jetzt gestern beschlossen wurde, hat Habeck noch mal wie folgt richtig dazu gesprochen.
Wenn wir nicht erneut in einen Lockdown reinwollen, und das sollten wir nicht wollen, ich will noch mal unterstreichen, was das war, Menschen sind einsam gestorben, Kinder wurden in Wohnungen eingesperrt, Existenzen sind vernichtet worden. Diese Leichtfertigkeit, mit der teilweise darüber geredet wird, dass als Drohkulisse aufgebaut wird, die sollte nicht einziehen in diese Debatte. Auch das Wort und das Reden von Kontrollverlust ist falsch an dieser Stelle, sondern wir müssen und wir haben die Möglichkeit dagegen anzuarbeiten, wir können das Virus da bekämpfen, wo es ausbricht. Aber wir müssen es dann auch tun, und wir müssen die technischen Möglichkeiten auch nutzen und einsetzen. Und die App ist dafür geeignet als ein Instrument, andere habe ich eben genannt als Beispiele, also sollte es auch getan werden.
Ja, App, Luftfilter, Masken, da ist es nicht ausgeschöpft, was jetzt hier gemacht wurde bislang. Und jetzt sieht man wieder die Notbremse. Ein Thema können wir nicht auf November verschieben, Trump. Auch in fortgeschrittener Stunde halten wir jetzt noch durch und beschäftigen uns zum Abschluss mit Trump, oder?
Für mich war das ja der Moment des Monats. Am Ende bin ich ja doch eigentlich ein Entertainer, weißt du? Und dann überlege ich mir eigentlich, was macht man, wenn man so Corona hat? Dann kann man natürlich daheim bleiben oder man kann sich mal per Webcam zeigen. Aber was Trump daraus gemacht hat und dass man auch noch glaubte, dass ihm das schaden würde, sondern das nicht verstanden hat, ja, hier hat er noch einmal die Möglichkeit, seine Entertainer-Qualitäten unter Beweis zu stellen, das hat mich schon sehr beeindruckt. Vor allem, als er diese Rede dort hielt im Krankenhaus, bei der er sagte, maybe there will be a little surprise this afternoon, und dann fährt er tatsächlich in dieser Limousine dort einmal an der Menge vorbei, die ihm zujubelt und er winkt mit Maske und ist coronakrank. Da muss ich sagen, wie furchtbar ich diesen Mann auch finde, war ich doch beeindruckt von dieser Entertainer-Qualität und auch dieser Sache, ich zeig mich jetzt nochmal dem Publikum. Das war nochmal ganz altes amerikanisches Showbusiness, wie man es eigentlich nicht mehr findet. Wir haben ja jetzt nur noch das irgendwelche Stars wegen Überlastung, Nerven, Zusammenbruch und was weiß ich, ihre Tourneen abbrechen. Wir hatten das Beispiel Justin Bieber und hier haben wir noch so die alte Schule, das Zirkuspferd, das natürlich rausgeht und auch das noch für sich zu nutzen weiß. Also für mich diese Sekunden, Trump fährt da vorbei, so schrecklich das alles ist, was da im Land vor sich geht und so groß die Tragödie auch ist, die diese Politik produziert. Es war für mich irgendwie dann doch ein ja, großer Showmoment.
Ich hätte es auch genießen können, wenn es eben nicht Corona als Thema wäre, denn dass da zwei Secret Service Leute mit im Auto fahren müssen und die Fenster sind zu und alles, das finde ich ärgerlich. Also das finde ich dann auch wirklich auf so einer persönlichen Ebene. Wahnsinnig ärgerlich.
Das ist ein Skandal im höchsten Maße. Also nicht, dass man mich jetzt falsch versteht, dass man sagt, das ist ja toll, so will ich Politik haben. Aber ich würde sagen, dass das tatsächlich nochmal so zeigte, wie amerikanisches Showgeschäft funktioniert.
Also man hätte ihn natürlich aus Sicherheitsgründen nicht in ein selbstfahrendes Auto setzen können, aber man hätte natürlich einfach einen Hänger nutzen können. Also das Biest fährt und in einem Hänger hinten sitzt er drin in Quarantäne und kann er winken, so viel er will.
Oder er hätte sich das Papa Mobil ausleihen können.
Genau, das oder das. Also wir sind, in deren Sicht wirst du es wahrscheinlich nicht so gut finden, aber Trump hat nur noch ein paar Tage, nämlich sechs, um genau zu sein.
Na ja gut, es gibt ja noch ein paar andere Kriterien in meinem Leben, als ist jemand ein Entertainer.
Genau, so und ich fand's, wie soll man sagen, wir sind wieder, also wir sind in einer Stochastischen Gesellschaft. Wir wissen, nächste Woche ist eine Wahl und wir wissen nicht, was da passiert. Und das ist nicht nur das Ergebnis, sondern auch der Ablauf. Es kann jetzt alles Mögliche passieren. Es wird wirklich verrückt. Und in deren Sicht fand ich es ein bisschen bezeichnend, dass die beiden lustigsten gerade im Fernsehen, ich finde, Stephen Colbert ist völlig raus, kann ich nicht mehr gucken, wie er dazu sitzt, aber James Corden von der Late Late Night Show, oder wie sie heißt, und Jimmy Fallon mit seinen News & Jokes, die er da immer macht, jeden Tag acht Minuten. Und hier hören wir nur mal sekundenweise bei beiden Reihen, nämlich am gleichen Tag, und zwar gestern. Ich glaube, das stimmt so ein bisschen, aber ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass es einfach ein haushohes Ding wird. Und Nate Silver, der ja die Statistiken ausrechnet, der hat zum Beispiel auf seiner Seite, 538 heißt sie, und macht ja diese großen Kalkulationen, diese Modellrechnungen. Da gibt es ja so ein Szenario, in dem Trump nur noch irgendwie 50 Wahlmelderstimmen bekommt. Also so weit klafft das mittlerweile auseinander, dass wirklich unglaubliches Szenarien damit in die 100 wahrscheinlichsten Szenarien aufgenommen wird. Und das einzige Problem, das er jetzt aber immer hat mit seinem, also der hat einen täglichen Podcast jetzt zum Thema, da kann man auch Fragen stellen und so weiter. Und das einzige, was die Leute noch plagt, wie er mitbekommt, ist das hier. Die Leute sind mittlerweile so verunsichert, dass ihnen alle Prognosen egal sind. Und selbst wenn die Auszählung schon läuft, wird diese Sicherheit, die die Menschen jetzt suchen, wahrscheinlich wirklich erst hergestellt, wenn das letzte County von Ohio ausgezählt ist. Und man weiß, dieser Staat ging jetzt mehrheitlich an Biden. Und damit ist die Wahl entschieden oder so.
Obwohl da ja gerade wieder kritisch sein soll, dass Ohio doch an Trump gehen könnte.
Oder Florida oder was auch immer man jetzt nimmt.
Hat wieder eine neue Umfrage ergeben.
Aber es sind jetzt wirklich die letzten Counties, die gezählt werden müssen, bis hier dann das große Aufatmen stattfindet. Also die Angst vor Trump, die auch ich so mitbekomme, wenn Leute mit mir über Trump reden, finde ich immer wieder amüsierend. Weil das Ding ist gelaufen und die glauben es einfach nicht. Du auch, du auch.
Also ich werde, wenn es anders kommt, werde ich natürlich genau das, was du jetzt hier alles sagst, rausschneiden als Clip vorbereiten für die Neue Zwanziger im November.
Naja, Hacks on Tap, da sitzen sie ja zusammen, die großen Wahlkampfmanager. Also jetzt wirklich hier die Wahlkampfchefs von Obama und George W. Bush und so weiter. Und sie machen sich ja auch so ein bisschen lustig über die Wählerschaft, weil die wissen, wie man so eine Lage einschätzt jetzt gerade. Schau, der Grund ist nicht 2016. Blablabla, sie machen sich lustig darüber, dass Menschen an posttraumatischer Polling-Disorder, oder wie auch immer, an einem Trauma einfach leiden von 2016. Die Umfragewerte waren doch so krass, und jetzt ist es plötzlich ganz andersrum. Wir hören uns trotzdem von Nate Silver, also derjenige, der das wirklich ausrechnet, der die ganzen Megakalkulationen macht, mal 1, 5 Minuten an die vier Szenarien, die er für Wahrscheinlichkeit verhält, mit denen Trump noch gewinnen könnte. Also es gibt noch Möglichkeiten. Und das sind so die vier, die jetzt Nate Silver, und das ist auch völlig ernst gemeint, die er noch so sieht.
Aber wir beginnen mit dem Unpacken von dem 14% Chance, dass Trump die Wahl gewinnt. Wie wird das 14% Chance in einer Trump-Winke aussehen?
Können wir schon mal ausschließen, so schlecht war die zweite Debatte nicht. Einige Partizipanten von den Republikanen kämpfen nach Trumps Seite. So ein bisschen, also da war schon ein klarer Win sozusagen. ist, dass er nicht nach den Tatsachen von Covid-19 zeigt. Aber man könnte gute Nachrichten von Vakzinen bekommen, die einfach in einer besseren Stimmung machen, bevor November 3. Also keiner steckt tiefer drin als er und das war jetzt so sein, ja, also wenn jetzt die Menschenversuche mit Virus wirklich gut funktionieren und das beiden nochmal stolpert in einer Debatte und aber es ist halt jetzt auch, also die Zeit ist jetzt abgelaufen, es ist jetzt acht Tage vorher und entsprechend ist ihn jetzt auch die Einschätzung der Hexontipp.
Das ganze Ding ist eine riesige, wahre Krise von einem kranker Familienunternehmen.
Und, es ist nur ein Thema, wenn ich denke, dass die Uhr sich umdreht.
Und vielleicht wird Trump ein wenig schlussen, an der Ende, wenn es um das Gespräch geht.
Ja, das muss man, es ist stimmt. Es ist tatsächlich der langweiligste Wahlkampf der Welt. Es ist nichts mehr los.
Die Covid-Erkrankung war das einzig interessante.
Ja, das war auch das Finale so ein bisschen. Guck mal, du siehst ja angeguckt, wird es ihnen schwächen? Nee, aber gestärkt hat es ihn auch nicht. Und am Ende hat halt dieses Covid-Ding auch wirklich noch mal zu einem, also die Abstände sind ja wirklich noch mal von 8 auf 12 Prozent gesprungen. Ich hätte ja gedacht, also eigentlich, das muss man vielleicht mal ganz deutlich sagen, Corona ist eigentlich die Chance für jeden Staats- und Regierungschef der Welt gewesen, jetzt richtig Punkte zu machen. So Merkel hat es wieder ganz wunderbar gemacht. Und wenn Trump jetzt verliert, dann nicht wegen Corona und war ja klar und so, sondern eigentlich wäre Corona noch mal die Chance gewesen, es für Trump zu schaffen. Ich habe ja vorher schon kein Szenario gesehen, dass es nicht mal Corona als Chance von ihm genutzt wurde, sich erfolgreich durchzusetzen, ist schon bezeichnend, dass er dann selber noch so niedergeschlagen wurde von Corona für ein Wochenende und die Leute ihm das eben nicht abkaufen, seine Schoße. Also das ist wirklich nur so als Show betrachtet, so wie du auch, sondern dass da eben nicht jetzt noch mal so ein wirkliches, so ein politischer Gewinn da drin steckt, sondern es einfach nur, ich fühle mich gut unterhalten, aber wenn es jetzt vorbei ist, okay, dann machen wir halt mal wieder ordentlich weiter. Das ist schon bezeichnend. Zur Demografie, das ist vielleicht ganz interessant. Zum einen, also es gibt ja zwei wiederstrebende Entwicklungen. Zum einen hat Mike Murphy, der sehr viele Republikaner im Wahlkampf beraten hat, das hier mal zu Protokoll gegeben, schon Ende September.
Das ist Dave Wasserman oder der Cook Politiker Report.
Die findet ihr online.
Es ist mittlerweile so, dass sich die, also junge Wähler wählen, einfach demokratischer als alte. Das kann man glaube ich so sagen, selbst wenn diesmal die Älteren, sogar märglich Demokraten wählen, zumindest sehen die Umfrageergebnisse so aus. Und dieses Wahlverhalten wird jetzt mitgeschleppt. Das ist in Europa auch so. Es wird nicht mehr so sehr vererbt, sondern es wird jetzt mitgeschleppt. Und wenn man die demografischen Veränderungen von 2016 bis 2020 vorzieht und auf das Ergebnis von 2016 legt, sind es diese paar Stimmen, die dann fehlen. Wenn die Wahl nur so wiederholt würde mit den gleichen Inhalten und den gleichen Mobilisierungseffekten und so weiter, dann würde Trump 2020 das verlieren, was er 2016 noch gewonnen hat. Unter anderem Ohio. Das sagt ja schon einiges.
Das ist ein, weshalb in Deutschland auch viele Parteien dagegen sind, dass das Wahlalter abgesenkt wird auf 16, weil das einen Stimmverlust bedeutet.
Ja, also ganz radikal. Jede zweite Stimme oder so fällt da die Grünen zu, diese Altersklasse. In der Sicht kein Wunder, dass es da Gegenbewegungen gibt. Nate Silver hat hier auch noch mal einen demografischen Faktor. Das ganze Land wird natürlich älter. Jetzt nicht vier Jahre, sondern Deutschland altert ja alle fünf Jahre ein halbes Jahr oder so. Also es sind schon Fortschritte in Sicht. Also das kann man schon mitmodellieren in solchen Prognosen für Wahlergebnisse. Da ist einfach so eine große Wähler- schaft, dass es da schon einen Unterschied macht, wenn man pro Nase einfach sechs Wochen mehr Leben aufrechnet und das mal hochsummiert, wie viel mehr Leben in Amerika drinsteckt. Also da ist schon Bewegung. Und jetzt zu den Institutionen. Das ist nämlich wirklich interessant. Angenommen, sie gewinnen jetzt nicht nur die Präsidentschaft, sondern auch noch den Senat. Und danach sieht es ja aus. Dann sind ja die Tore offen. Wenn sie den Senat nicht gewinnen, deswegen ist Biden jetzt auch nur noch in Staaten unterwegs, wo die Senatoren flippen könnten, von republikanisch zu demokratisch. Dann können sie alles machen. Wenn sie den Senat nicht haben, dann wird alles weiterhin blockiert. Dann ist es Vetocracy, wie Francis Fukuyama sagte. Und dann kann dann noch so viel von Green Deal, irgendwas Klima, irgendwas Krankenversicherung. Dann wird es nicht passieren. Sie brauchen auch den Senat. Und da haben sie hier mal eine ganz wunderbare Auflösung gemacht bei The Daily. Na, wir fangen mal vorne an. Wir gehen mal die Institutionen einzeln durch. Zum einen gucken wir nochmal auf das Wahlergebnis von 2016. Die Differenz war ja sehr gering und trotzdem mit großen Auswirkungen.
So, Trump war also schon.
Er war schon in 2016 mit 3 Millionen Stimmen in Kalifornien. Der Senat hat er auch mal genannt. North & South Carolina, da fragt man sich ja, was soll das? Wieso ist das nicht ein Bundesstaat? 1917 oder so, vor 100 Jahren, haben die beiden Staaten jeweils zwei Senatoren entsendend mehr Gewicht in Washington. In North Carolina leben 1, 5 Millionen Menschen und in South Carolina auch. Würde man das Gleiche jetzt mit Kalifornien machen, also Kalifornien einteilen in 1, 5 Millionen starke Bevölkerungsgruppen und den einzelnen Bundesstaaten Status geben, dann würde der amerikanische Senat von 100 Sitzen auf 150 Sitze wachsen. Und zwar ausschließlich fast mit demokratischen Kandidaten, die diese Senatoren-Sitze dann ausfüllen. Also wir haben es hier mit einer ganz merkwürdigen, auf vielen Ebenen ganz merkwürdigen Gemengelage von Institutionen-Gefüge zu tun, die dazu führen, dass drei Millionen kalifornische Stimmen nicht gezählt werden, aber 77.000 Stimmen in drei Bundesstaaten so einen Unterschied machen, weil durch dieses Winner-Take-All und so weiter, das da ungemuddelt wird. Warum zählt der Popular Award? So wenig, fragen wir uns. Und wir wissen, wie du eben schon meintest, die CDU will nicht, dass mit 16 gewählt wird. Und die Republikaner wollen halt nicht, dass das Electoral College abgeschafft wird. Nur das Electoral College, das ist gar nicht so subtl fest, wie man immer glaubt, weil man denkt ja immer, das steht da irgendwie in der Verfassung drin und so. Nein, stellt sich raus, ja, es steht in der Verfassung, aber schon 1970, also vor 50 Jahren, gab es hier große Bemühungen abzuschaffen.
Und das beste Erlebnis, das wir in amerikanischer Geschichte gehabt haben, das Electoral College abzuschaffen, das Präsidenten von einem popularen Votum und die Prinzipien der Declaration der Independence abzuschaffen, die auf dem Boden des Senat in einem Filibuster im September von 1970 sterben, haben wir noch nie so nahe gekommen.
So und jetzt, diese Argumentation ist für uns alle interessant, denn sie ist wirklich neu, ich habe sie jetzt alle erst einmal gehört. Vielleicht macht es gar nicht so viel Sinn, das Electoral College abzuschaffen, sondern nur die Winner-Take-All-Regel. Wenn ein Bundesstaat 13 Wahlmänner entsendet und Frauen, dann muss es ja nicht 13 Mal für die gleiche Stimme sein, sondern es kann ja durchaus nach repräsentativen Wahlergebnissen sein. Ja, sieben entscheiden so und der Rest hat ebenso. Und diese Regelung, dass man das nicht macht, dass da das Popular Award nicht zählt, steht eben nicht in der amerikanischen Verfassung.
Und im Fakt haben die Framers nicht überhaupt über die Winner-Take-All-Ruhr gesprochen. Es kam nicht an der Konvention, und als sie es in den USA starten zu werden, in den frühen 1800ern, waren sie schrecklich. James Madison, der Mann, den wir als Vater der Konstitution denken, versuchte, eine Konstitutionale Angelegenheit zu verhindern, die Winner-Take-All-Ruhr zu nutzen, weil er sah, wie korrosiv es war, um die Hälfte der Votisten in einem Staat zu erwerben.
Also die Verfassungsautoren...
Das heißt, da können auch die Republikaner, die orthodoxen Rechtsausleger hatten wir ja hier auch schon, das Thema gehabt nicht hingehen und sagen, na ja, da gab es aber mal eine Notiz bei Madison und bei George Washington, und die sagt, dass wir nie, niemals davon abrücken dürfen und dass das in Stein gemeißelt steht. Die sind ja bibl-exegetisch da drin, aber ganz fundamentalistisch.
Originalisten und Textualisten, so heißen die. Die diese ganze, da ist ja jetzt auch diese, diese neue Richterin ist ja auch so ein, die macht ja so eine textuelle Auslegung, wir interpretieren nicht den Sinn, sondern nur die Worte, die da stehen. Und die Verfassungsautoren selbst haben sich noch zu Lebzeiten gegen die Winner-Take-All-Regelung ausgesprochen. Also da ist durchaus ein Einfallstor für, und jetzt gibt es zwei Auswege, bei denen man sagen muss, es könnte durchaus sein, dass in Amerika die Erlösung von Trump als so wichtig aufgegriffen wird, dass man tatsächlich mal ein paar politische Moves hinsichtlich neuer Institutionenordnung und so weiter wagt. Und in The Daily haben sie hier zwei Auswege aufgezeigt, die wirklich nicht unrealistisch sind.
Die Winner-Take-All-Law ist eine Städtelaw. Das ist die National Popular Vote Interstate Compact. Sie geben alle Voten zu den Kandidaten, die die meisten Voten in den 50 Staaten und DC gewinnen. Und was das bedeutet, ist, dass der Kandidat, der die Popular Vote gewinnt, die Voten der Präsidenten wird.
So, das hieße, die Wahlmänner erachten nicht mehr auf ihren Bundesstaat. Also diese Repräsentanz geht an Flöten, sondern sie gehen nach dem Popular Vote. Weil Winner-Take-All auf Bundesstaatebene, ja warum denn nicht auf Landesebene? Und dann wählen einfach alle, geschlossen den Präsidenten und lassen sich vom Popular Vote dazu inspirieren, welchen sie nehmen. Das klingt zwar irgendwie irre, weil es ein bisschen anders ist, aber das ist nicht irrer als das, was wir jetzt gerade als Modus da haben. Also in deren Sicht ist das durchaus eine Idee. Je nach Mehrheiten, die man so hat, könnte man sowas dann doch wirklich mal anstreben. Angenommen, wir haben jetzt den Supreme Court, also sagen wir es mal so, der Supreme Court muss auch immer sehr auf seine eigene Legitimation achten, denn er kann sehr schnell durch einfach neue Gesetze auf Bundesstaatenebene gebrochen werden. Also es gibt kein föderales Gesetz, das jetzt beim Thema Abtreibung oder so, Alabama macht halt ein ziemlich krasses Gesetz, dann kann man auf Bundesebene dagegen klagen. Und dieses Präzedenzrecht durch die Bundesrichter gilt dann genauso lange, wie der Bundesstaat entscheidet, ich handle hier nicht, sondern sobald die Gesetze machen, gilt das nicht mehr. So, also dieser Supreme Court hat eigentlich ein gewisses Institutions, wie soll man sagen, er kann das nicht durchsetzen, wie das Bundesverfassungsgericht auch, die können keine Polizei los schicken oder so was, sondern die sind darauf angewiesen, dass dann die Regierung oder die Parlamente, die sie aufgefordert haben, da mal nachzuarbeiten, das dann schon mal irgendwie machen, aber wenn sie es nicht einhalten, ja dann weiß man dann auch nicht, was dann passiert. Und jetzt besteht ja die Gefahr, dass wir einen sehr demokratischen Regierungsapparat haben in allen drei Bereichen, also in den zwei Parlaments und im Präsidentenamt und ein sehr konservatives Gericht. Und da hat Biden eine sehr gute Antwort in dieser Ein-Torn-Haul gegeben. Was passiert denn eigentlich, wenn jetzt Roe vs. Wade, also dieses 50 Jahre alte Urteil, das Abtreibungen ermöglicht, dadurch dass es in die Privatsphäre von Menschen fällt, wenn das gekippt wird, sodass die eigentlichen Abtreibungsverbote wieder gelten. Und da hat Biden das hier gesagt. Er macht das einfach zum Gesetz. Also wir haben ja, du erinnerst dich, Josh Hawley gehört, der sich wahnsinnig aufgeregt hat darüber, dass diese Körperschaft, und damit meint er den amerikanischen Staat, überhaupt nichts mehr geregelt kriegt und deswegen die Richter alles entscheiden, beispielsweise auch die eine oder andere religiös motivierte Diskriminierung von Homosexualität einfach nicht mehr akzeptieren 2020 und das sogar republikanische oder konservative Richter machen und was beiden hier es klingt ein bisschen aus europäischer sicht aber er droht hier mit gesetzen dass man einfach das gericht übertümpelt mit ja da macht man ein ganz tolles gesetz und das formulieren wir dann so dass es halt trotz textuellen auslegungen die möglich sind durch die richter trotzdem besteht und das muss man sagen das ist schon eine kleine revolution in dieser wetokrisi amerika wo donald trump überhaupt gar nichts mehr geregelt hatte nicht mal als er mehrheiten hatte im senat hat das ja hinbekommen zum Zum Beispiel Obamacare zu kippen. Also in der Ansicht ist das schon ganz interessant, dass er hier sagt, wir können ja einfach mal wieder Politik machen. Wie wäre das eigentlich?
Das heißt, das ist die einzige Hoffnung, auch die man haben kann bei einem Kandidaten wie Biden, dass der auf diesem institutionalen Feld Änderungen vornehmen kann, Gesetze einbringen kann, Reformen durchsetzen kann, die dazu führen, dass sich dieses ganze System insoweit verändert, dass dann irgendwann vielleicht auch ein progressiver demokratischer Kandidat Dinge durchsetzen kann.
Ja, man hat ja immer nur, das besprechen die ganz häufig, kurze Momente, weil du kommst ins Amt und hast dann vielleicht beide Kammern hinter dir, aber nach zwei Jahren ist ja Midterms. Und dann droht immer The Wave, die Welle, also der Gegenschlag sozusagen. Und man hat diese kurzen Zeitfenster und beiden wird auch so ein Zeitfenster bekommen. Und ich könnte mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass es schon sehr viele, man sieht es auch, wie viel Geld jetzt in diese Präsidentschaftskandidatur fließt, also wie viele Leute sich da einkaufen. Es wird jetzt schon sehr viel vorausgedacht, was man so in diesen zwei Jahren machen könnte, ohne das natürlich öffentlich zu sagen. Sie sträuben sich ja sehr gegen alles Mögliche. Also bloß nichts jetzt sagen, was nochmal die Gegenseite mobilisiert. Ja, in der Sicht ist das auch so ein Wahlkampf, der jetzt einfach verdeckt, was eigentlich gerade zu thematisieren wäre. Aber das sehen wir dann alles in der Transition und so, was dann so als Themen aufploppen. Naja, zum Abschluss hier ein paar stilistische Noten zum Wahlkampf. Bei Hex on Tap hat sich Mike Murphy sehr darüber lustig gemacht, dass die republikanischen Kandidaten immer so gestelzt, gestochen reden. Diese Ansprache an das Volk und dieses vernunftbasierte Betonen und so weiter. Er erklärt hier mal, wie man diesen republikanischen Kandidaten so beibringt.
Trump bezahlt nichts in den Kosten.
Amerika braucht einen Präsidenten mit einem ambitiellen Haarschnitt.
So, können wir sagen, er wollte das nur mal vorspielen, wie das so ist. Er hat gesagt, wissen Sie, was Amerika braucht? Einen Präsidenten mit einer guten Frisur. Man denkt, das war zu übertrieben, das hat er nur so illustratorisch, damit man weiß, was er meint. Dann schaltet man so um, guckt sich diese Trump-Tornhalle an, die er dann noch so spät ins Programm geschoben hat, um Biden eins auszuwischen. Und dann kriegt er diese Frage gestellt von einer Bürgerin.
We have Paulette Dale.
She leans slightly to Biden.
She voted for Clinton in 2016.
Good evening, Mr. President.
So you're so handsome when you smile. Ja, jetzt kommen wir mal zum eigentlichen Stefan. Das ist ja alles schön, was du da von den Institutionen zu sagen hast. Wir haben noch nie über das schöne Lächeln von Donald Trump gesprochen. Aber es gab auch, du erinnerst dich an die erste Debatte zwischen Biden und... Es gibt ja... Zwei. Aber die erste Biden-Trump-Debatte, da gab es doch auch diesen wunderbaren Satz von Trump in Richtung Biden über das Maskengebot, er trägt auch eine Maske, wenn es sein muss, aber er würde Biden ja nur mit der Maske sehen und dann sagt er doch so einen Satz wie, er trägt die größte Maske, die ich jemals gesehen habe. Also wirklich wie so im Kindergarten, die größte Maske, die ich je gesehen habe.
Es ist genau auf der Ebene. Deswegen hat Mike Murphy auch nicht so ganz unrecht, wenn die da so auf Frisuren so... Das ist halt alles gelungenes Frisuren-Marketing am Ende.
Das wissen wir doch auch noch. Da haben wir doch auch schon Debatten in Deutschland gehabt zum Thema färbt ein Kanzler sich die Haare mit eidesstattlicher Erklärung des Promi-Frisörs dann. Und jeder weiß natürlich, dass das Wort färben vielleicht ein sehr enger Begriff ist, dass es aber andere Möglichkeiten gibt und so weiter. Da kann man das jetzt nicht hier aufgreifen. Nicht, dass wir auch noch einen Abmahn-Anwalt auf den Hals nehmen.
Da kann man überspezifisch dementieren und das wurde ja damals auch kunstvoll gemacht. Als allerletzten Clip und das auch wirklich als Verabschiedung von Trump, es ist unmöglich insgesamt. Es geht 36 Sekunden. Trump macht eine Rallye, steht in Florida, hält eine große Rede und erklärt 36 Sekunden lang, warum Biden nicht gewählt werden darf. Und es ist so im Grunde beispielhaft für den Gehalt der ganzen Präsidentschaft von Trump. Es ist einfach nur noch, man könnte vielleicht am Ende sagen, ok, wenn das wenigstens gut geliefert ist, ist es eine geile Show, ja. Aber diese Szene wird auch niemand vermissen. Also, vier Jahre Trump können wir, also uns fehlt die Kapazität zu begreifen, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Und wenn jetzt noch jemand die nächsten sechs Tage damit verbringt, irgendwen zu erklären, dass der wiedergewählt wird, dann stellt bitte die Rückfrage, verstehst du gerade selbst, was du da sagst? Und zwar ganz ernst gemeint, verstehst du selbst, was du sagst, wenn du meinst, er wird noch mal gewählt? Weil dafür fehlen uns wirklich die Konzepte. Wir haben dafür wirklich keine Konzepte. Wir wissen nicht, was es bedeuten könnte, wenn Trump noch mal vier Jahre, wir verstehen nicht mal die ersten vier Jahre, das ist wie so ein Traum an uns vorbeigezogen und wir konnten es einfach nicht glauben, dass hier keine Atombomben geflogen sind. Und es ist vieles kaputt gegangen, aber manches dann vielleicht doch nicht. Und niemals noch mal vier Jahre, so was. Also es wird einfach, das kann man sich nicht vorstellen. Ich kann es wirklich vorstellen.
Ich bin gespannt auf den Kommunismus, der dann jetzt bald kommt.
Genau, freuen wir uns doch alle gemeinsam auf den venezulanischen Kommunismus da in Amerika.
Ja, wir machen uns dann auf in den Salon, würde ich sagen. Du hast ein Buch vorgeschlagen, das wir wieder gemeinsam besprechen werden. Angry Nomics. Willst du zwei, drei Sätze noch vielleicht dazu sagen?
Genau. Angry Nomics. Also es flatterte hier so rum, ich wollte es immer lesen. Und dann hattest du die Idee, dass wir eins zusammen besprechen. Aber ich sagte, dann lass uns doch Angry Nomics nehmen. Vielleicht als kleiner Teaser so, Angry Nomics ist ein Buch, das ganz klar unterscheidet zwischen das, was Ökonomen im Fernsehen sagen und das, was tatsächlich passiert. Und das eine ist Economics, ausgedachte Wirklichkeiten. Und das andere ist Angry Nomics, nämlich das, was Leute wirklich beschäftigt, wenn sie einen Präsidenten sehen und ihnen gefällt diese Frisur nicht.
Genau, und was das auch bedeutet, wenn die Wirklichkeit nicht mit dem Modell zusammenpasst, das die Ökonomen dort im Fernsehen vorstellen. Das ist ja etwas, was wir sehr, sehr leidvoll auch aus Deutschland in den letzten Jahrzehnten kennen.
Genau, und das ist auch ein besonderes Buch, weil es als Dialog geschrieben ist. Und mich interessiert vor allem da Kapitel 3. Das hat mit Demografie zu tun, darauf werde ich mich so ein bisschen einschießen. Ich bin gespannt.
Was bringst du sonst noch mit? Bringst du noch ein Trump-Buch mit oder nicht?
Nein, es liegen keine Trump-Bücher mehr da. Es ist aus die Maus.
Ich bringe noch ein Roman mit von Samantha Schweblin. Ein Roman, der aus dem Spanischen übersetzt ins Deutsche jetzt erschienen ist. Der heißt Hundert Augen und der handelt von Menschen, die sich verwandeln lassen in Haustiere oder possierliche Tierchen, die dann andere Menschen halten können. Man begibt sich also in eine unterwürfige Position. Das ist dann quasi ein neuer Beruf, der da mit entsteht. Es ist ein sehr ungewöhnlicher Roman. Mehr dazu dann im Salon und dann selbstverständlich noch vier journalistische Texte.
Genau, Krimskrams. Ich hatte noch Reetestings. Du kennst ihn, er ist der Chef von Netflix. Einer, wie ich finde, Klügeren aus der Riege. Und der versucht ja tatsächlich, eine Null-Bullshit-Firma aufzuziehen. Also einfach Bullshit-Jobs auszusortieren. Und unter all diesen Manager-Literaturen, die es so gibt, dadurch, dass er selber ein Praktiker ist, muss ich sagen, es ist doch ganz beeindruckend. Es ist Selbstbeschreibung, das ist schon klar. Aber ich glaube, da gibt es noch ein paar Insights hinsichtlich David Graeber's Bullshit-Jobs. Was wäre, wenn man es wirklich mal ganz konsequent angeht und sagt, Bullshit-Jobs ist für mich das Handbuch, wie ich meine Firma säubere, von talentfreien Mitarbeitern. Und dann zieht er das so hart durch und das ist schon ganz beeindruckend, wie das so funktioniert. Gut, dann seid gespannt auf den Salon.
Und einen schönen Monat.
Genau, ich werde nochmal die Gästeliste verlinken, denn es gab eine einzelne Gastgeber, die nochmal fragten, wo ist die Gästeliste? Und ich habe sie tatsächlich nicht verlinkt. Ich werde sie allerdings jetzt einmal leer machen und alle, die das Ansehen haben, können jetzt neu ihr Wunsch reinschreiben. Und für alle, die dann eins haben, bitte nicht durchstreichen oder erledigt, sondern einfach einfach rausnehmen, sodass diejenigen, die in der Gästeliste stehen, einfach tatsächlich die sind, die noch nicht eingeladen wurden in den Salon und dann haben wir da ein bisschen Übersicht. Sehr gut, dann sehen wir uns im November in einer neuen Welt. Wir können ja, wir machen ein kleiner Teaser hier für alle, die noch nicht im Salon sind. Wir werden natürlich den Salon nach der amerikanischen Präsidentenwahl aufzeichnen. Entsprechend werden wir das erste Mal aus dem Wasser schauen in die neue Welt. Schon im Salon und nicht dann erst in der Monatsfolge.